Oh My god, where am I?
I hate take I hate take I hate take I absolutely never again
will I ever play take again I I thought I was double
checking if I was muted or not I I was like oh my god, I
hope I didn't unmute myself with me just be like I hate take
I Take is so fucking miserable I This is the last time I'll
ever willingly play take it's so Miserable, I don't know how
you all do it.
It's so Oh my god, it's such a terrible experience.
I'm sorry.
I don't know how you all do it.
I don't know how you can you can take this
It is pure suffering.
Take is not a role where you can enjoy life.
It's like you're depressed and you're like, you know what
else I can do?
Be more depressed.
Just...
It's like nothing happens.
Oh my God.
I can't see what's going on.
I can't...
Oh, I fucking never...
There's a reason why.
This role.
Nobody plays this role.
It's like, there's, it's like an endangered species.
Anyway, let me set up my stream stuff.
I'm sorry.
I, I've been like hard doing a crash course on tank the last
24 hours.
And I wish of, I do not wish that for anyone.
I do not wish this experience.
for anyone else it truly is a thankless job it really is i
was i had to ask like how how the fuck do i play tank i need
i need to learn this in 24 hours i asked madara for those
who don't know madara is the nrg coach and he like nrg
player and i was like please teach me oh let me show you
guys something cool that i learned he plays take for energy
i was like please give me a crash course on on on tanks i
can play all right watch this pretty cool watch this guys
watch this look at this guys it's pretty cool look at this
tech that i learned buddy hop i can buddy hop now all right
here also um you see this boom reload cancel you see that
there you go that's all I had to learn that's it oh yeah
watch this watch this combo that I learned guys watch this
guys look at this boom that's right I can combo I know the
combos oh watch this combo too boom She's not 250 HP.
Look if she was 250 HP, I'd kill her.
Look at that.
So cool.
All right.
That's all.
That's like the basics.
That's like the tank 101.
She's a natural.
There you go.
Tank 101.
I will say right now.
I don't know how tank players do this.
I do not know how tank players can play this role for longer
than two hours.
I also can play a secret third and fourth take well not but
yeah I can also play a secret third and fourth tank that
won't be a secret soon no venom was terrible oh my god it
was so bad I got flame so hard I did not know what I was
doing I venom venom you actually have to have like like 900
IQ to play this guy it was so bad it was I got yelled at a
lot when I try to make Venom work, but I learned, I think I,
I think I can do it.
I get ready for, get ready for some very, very battles.
All right, I'm going to ask for my teams ready.
I'm more chill, I'm more chillier.
My tank is not that great, guys.
I don't know why.
People were saying like, oh my God, B-Hop's team is so, I'm
not Captain, by the way, B-Hop's team is so broken.
There's Doki and B-Hop.
tank.
What the fuck do you want?
I literally, I literally was an emergency sub like
yesterday.
Right?
They're like, you're back in.
You want to do this?
I was like, ah, okay, for you.
I will do it for you.
I will fucking join back the tournament and play tank.
No, they do.
They know I play tank.
It was announced and everyone was like, everyone was like,
that team is so I was like, no, you don't understand.
I have less than an hour on tank in Marvel Rivals because I
hate tank.
I hate playing this role.
I'm so selfless, guys.
The sacrifices I make for Marvel Rivals.
Anyway, let me ask the team if they're ready.
Are you guys ready for a quick play?
Yeah.
Yes, yes.
All right.
Let's see.
Kick you in anomaly and I are in a lobby right now.
you can invite me are you on your main air i request to join
cool cool okay who are you missing i just requested to join
too all right all right nice all right started
i am oh all right i'm so i'm so ready to keep on playing
tank i i think i might have i may or may not have made a
mistake.
He's like, I'm ready.
I unmuted, I think.
I think it's Quick Play.
It's harder to gather stuff because it's Quick Play.
Yeah.
In Quick Play, we can, like, fuck around more, honestly.
It's more so practicing your mechanics rather than
coordinated play.
Yeah.
On life.
unmute it for now yeah yeah you can leave the the quick play
of muted just because it's it's just like practicing
mechanical it's not like because like behob's already street
technically streamed the scrims so yeah as long as we're not
doing like comms leak or whatever then it's fine like like
actual like strat leaks all right let's go okay yeah i was
like guys we gotta make sure Our scrims don't get leaked and
then our captain leaked their scrims.
Everyone was like, alright then we all privated pro.
Like everyone, this entire tournament is so sweaty.
Everybody private their profile.
Even before I told my team to private their profile.
Every other team private their profiles.
Nobody streamed any of their practices.
Every team has scrimmed.
In one day.
It's crazy.
There's a pinner here.
all right here we go
oh i have to get rid of my i have to get i don't have shield
oh yeah yeah i can't do anything here
i'm trying to help you i got you i got you i'm not i'm not
white fox yeah I got the mines.
I got the mines.
I'm breaking the nest.
Give me a second.
Is it breaking?
Yeah, yeah.
It's hard.
Yeah, it's hard.
If the nest is down, we can probably go in.
Any heals?
Oh, I'm sorry, sorry, sorry.
I went to the jet.
Help!
Help our deadpool.
Is it fireman?
Oh, they don't jet.
Yeah.
No TPR and, uh, whitepox.
I don't armor anymore.
I don't see.
You lasered me.
Wait, Fox's up!
I'm breaking the nest again on the left.
I have ult.
I'm on Penny, I'm on Penny, Penny, Penny, Penny.
Penny, Penny.
I'm on Penny, Penny, Penny.
Fox is on our...
Book is on Fox, we can.
Fox have?
Jeff is also back.
Oh, he is?
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm backing up.
Penny heals.
Honey reload.
I'll get my gun real quick.
Okay.
Getting the Wanda off the top.
White Fox, no cheating.
Okay.
I'm going on the White Fox right now.
White Fox, look!
And Wanda, too.
Maga's walking out to the...
I got White Fox.
I'm a ult.
Um, we can use Rocket ult here if you want.
Shift low?
Okay.
Iron Man has ult, by the way.
I got Iron Man.
He's ult, he's always ult.
Nice.
Good rocket ult.
I need help.
Thank you.
I'm here, I'm here.
I got it.
All right, nice, nice.
I know.
I do not know how you enjoy tank beehives.
It's such a miserable experience.
It's fucking miserable.
My aim is not good enough for DPS, so...
I'm just gonna reload here.
One on the left.
Yeah.
Down one too.
Oh, she has no flared, yeah.
Mag one, mag one.
Oh, nice, nice.
I'm pushing up.
Oh, wait.
We lost her.
I'm down.
Wait, wait.
We lost her raccoon.
I got him.
1-1-1.
1-1.
Got me.
Okay, I'm backing up.
I'm backing up below.
I need heals here.
Good.
I'm on Wanda.
Wanda's low.
Oh, wait.
Oh, fuck.
I...
Oops.
I finally...
No, that's me.
I actually pressed F.
I was trying to press D.
It's against me.
He's gonna chill.
We get back.
See you guys.
One hour on tank.
All right.
I can.
I'm gonna go up.
I'm trying to take more off angles.
All right.
I'm back.
I'm trying to take more off angles.
I can move up if you want.
I'm pushing the Ironman.
Okay.
We're catching you guys.
I'm in.
Wanda.
Wanda to our top left.
Help our siloed.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Wanda behind us.
Wanda's behind us.
I'm trying to shield.
Just shield.
Just stand behind me.
I got Wanda.
Nice.
I'm trying to, uh, shoot you guys.
I'm coming over.
I might be able to ult.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Fuck this shark in particular.
Not with any- Oh, they popped both of them.
That's fine.
Yeah, this is 9.
Yeah, no more else.
I shielded, I shielded.
Nice, he missed.
Got him.
Nice, good, good.
Yeah.
I'm just pushing up.
That's good.
Nice, nice, nice.
Ooh.
Broke that.
Oh, I'm shielding.
Just stand behind me.
You need to?
He really tried to.
hit me i'm gonna go for the shark oh the sharks coming
coming for you they're coming for you oh they got three they
got three they got three yep that's fine if you can heal me
in we have five minutes so we could just yeah we didn't
chill honestly yeah when you go to this victor i'm gonna pop
shark don't let anything stand in your way i'm gonna heal
food yeah we have we have res here all right i didn't die oh
charclan uh scarlet low she gets out of fade i know where
she went oh she's still in the lower i got a shark i got a
shark i'm gonna need help i need help here Thank you I got
her nice More for the Luna Oh, nice.
Thank you I'm going for that.
I think I can alt this I'll let you alt first Yeah Or we
just win it Hey Hello Alright, I still have rock at all You
can technically rock it all when yeah yeah just yeah when is
the best time to use it's offensive defensively so uh
basically whenever uh whenever like whoever gets a first
ults the first defensively depending on the comp we can i
need i need someone else to call for it because like when i
play tank i don't i can't focus on calling stuff yeah all
right yeah i thought about it enough on the first point but
it's weird because their comp didn't have like a traditional
all right let me see b hops down a little bit yeah b hops a
lot because i was queuing with him a little bit to help and
that comp it's aggressive but it depends on the comp okay if
they have like hello or like sidewalk or something like you
would use it to stop that uh i'll try to look at the comp
and i can let you know as well Gotcha.
I'll try to remember.
All right.
I'll do Phoenix this time.
I think I'll try, I'll play something else just in case they
ban Deadpool.
Does it look like I had one, I have, I basically learned
tank in one day?
Does it look like it?
Um, we could try something else.
We could try Gambit actually with Rocket and I can do Mag.
Oh, wait, I can, wait, what, oh, I can do Groot.
Yeah, do, uh.
Yeah, we do group phoenix combo or venom.
Oh, give me that shoulder right now.
Looks like you've been playing for like a week.
That's team up in the game right there.
I crashed.
I told you I had a crash curse on the easiest tanks I could
pick up in a day.
Champanus all.
They can't, if they have three bands and they use it all on
me, I have a fourth tank.
Do not worry.
I have a fourth tank.
uh three two one
are they have a door Punisher and Magneto
okay I'm getting out of there behind all right I'm coming
back helping with the door I'm helping too yeah there's a
there's a fantastic spike one oh he's out yeah he's one he's
one all right cool draw one draw one nice good pick
uh fantastic behind you all right see you all right I got
you also um Don't stand on my, don't stand on, sound on me
too much.
Yeah.
Oh, that's a fantastic.
It's really...
Green one!
Four one!
Fantastic's in a rocket.
You're done?
One he'll be careful.
Fantastic being.
I'm trying to...
I'm trying to tank front line right now.
Yeah, that's fine.
I need to help.
Oh, that's fine.
I'm stalling, so you should maybe...
Oh, I can portal.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'll portal.
Yeah.
They have plenty, so I may swap the plenty here.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, I'm plurling now.
Be careful.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, the Thor is not letting me pass.
A portal, I portal.
I have my y'all.
I'm going to come back.
Oh, my God.
I need heals right now.
Oh, we might just have to go check it out.
Yeah, yeah, it's fine.
Back up, back up, cat.
Don't go into it.
Magneto here.
Yeah.
And a hoe.
All right, we can do Gambil.
Gambil and then if we don't win the fight, a Squirrel Girl
it.
Or Phoenix?
If we can.
Gambit Phoenix?
Yeah, we can do that.
Okay, I can do it now.
Yeah, do it now.
Oh.
I think everybody, I think I missed one.
Oh, they're gonna lose.
Nice, nice.
Oh, yeah.
or when we say a gambit uh uh phoenix you don't have to all
up there you just keep it okay yeah oh i could shoot him he
could die he's half yeah he's low i have alt go in the back
be careful rock it all whenever when they throw we can
probably rock it all yeah or if they use one of their
invisals we could rock it all
Okay, I'm gonna go with the sun.
Use it, use it, use it, use it, use it.
Okay.
All right, it's good, good, good.
Get the way.
Oh, they used it.
Be careful, they're gonna try to break it.
All right, it's broken.
Yeah, I'm ulting after this.
I'm ulting after this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All them, all them.
I'm down.
Oh, they're still all so low.
Yeah.
Got the mag as well.
Nice, nice.
I'm done, I'm done.
Had the words kind of flanking or kind of walking back.
I gotta support so good.
I stalled for a good amount, so...
Yeah.
I'll wait here.
Bye.
Don't come back.
I don't cloaked now instead of invoves.
I might swap off Punisher only because...
a spot-top group because they're playing Punisher.
Fair enough.
And Squirrel Girl Alt.
You can use it, Squirrel Girl Alt here.
Just use it, just use it here.
Nice.
Doors in our health pack.
No key to runes.
Oh yeah, look is right here on me.
Uh, that door.
Door is low.
Oh, he teleported back into us.
Yeah.
Oh, they're on Iron Man now instead of hunter all right go
in all right that's done nice he's low or yeah but be
careful oh he was so low wait he's going on the left we
gamble here yeah gamble this gamble this okay nice go for it
Huge?
Nice.
Careful, the Ironman is just alone.
Yeah, backing up.
I have all here.
He's one.
That's a good kill.
Thank goodness.
I have all here, I'm gonna wait for all.
Outside mine, we can combo.
Yeah, yeah, I'm gonna alt here.
I'm gonna try and find a good one.
Wait.
Let them walk up.
Hey, let them walk up.
Okay, pop on here.
Good.
Oh, it was just the spy.
I'm gonna pop on you.
Pop on your left.
That was unlucky.
That's fine, that's fine.
You should have time to recontest.
Yeah, I can portal too.
Actually, yeah, I'll portal this.
Whenever the portal goes down, we can just rock it all
through it immediately because they use both.
Yeah, I'm at 99.
Yeah, you should have it.
Just got it.
Alright.
And they killed me immediately.
I didn't even go through the portal.
No, that's fine.
I'm trying to shield it as fast as I can.
It's really hard right now.
I got him.
I need it back out though.
Nice.
I'm backing up.
I'm going back in.
Okay, we gotta go in.
We gotta go in.
Get it.
All that you can.
Oh no.
The portal closed.
Oh, that's unlucky.
I'm shielding.
I'm shielding the tank from coming over.
I need my health.
I need heals here.
Thank you.
first.
Mag win.
I'm trying to kill him.
Keep, keep.
We have no more wounds.
I'm backing up here.
Nice.
Door's on the right.
Yeah, he is.
Oh yeah, they're back to go.
Door's on the right.
Door's on the back to go and be careful.
We're playing as well.
Door's stop.
He's so low.
I'm backing up a little.
He's falling.
He's on the left.
He's probably gonna flank around.
Oh no.
Oh my god, we got somebody in the...
There's an Iron Man hole in there.
Iron Man got us immediately.
I got two supports!
Nice, nice.
I support.
Sorry, they're on me.
No runes though, no runes.
No heals, no heals, no heals.
Okay.
I have my own.
That's fine.
Oh, I don't have a portal though.
I don't know if we could stall.
I don't think so.
No one thing we can recognize.
Yeah.
Our game is still in the other spawns, so we should back up
here.
Yeah, backing it back up.
We got someone back here.
Oh, yeah, back up fully.
I'm backing up fully.
I think you guys might die.
I'm just going to go.
We went there.
I was trying to help.
Yeah.
Help.
Oh, no.
Yeah, we'll just respawn.
I'm out here.
Sorry.
We are all here now.
Yeah, we're in the back lane.
Uh, you're anchoring that.
You're, you're peeling, right?
I'm anchoring it.
All right, we can walk up now.
Yeah, I'm walking up.
Did I know I screw up?
I don't have shield.
Oh my gosh.
I'm not like you.
No.
We could gamble right in.
Yeah, we can go gambling down bomb and find that.
Oh, I'll try and poke a little bit so you can All right,
heal me if you need to Oh, that's unlucky Yeah, yeah, you
win On me every single time Yeah, um I got chase When we're
pushing You don't have to be next to me You can play further
back Just try to get your heals Because that's like right
next to me and that's why he died instantly there so like at
support you can play further back you don't have to play
like next to tank and i a tank of dps yeah as rocket you
want to be as far back as possible as i can yeah i'm seeing
yeah okay just yeah your main job do not die
what's the new map the one that will not be in there yeah oh
yeah it's okay the right heroes
Oh Beware open your are you open your eyes reality is but an
illusion I'm gonna try this out too just in case you like
double front when you in this rocket and do the for the team
up
Gambit will probably be better as something we run on attack
because on yeah, it's a little little rough If the enemy
team gambit lets you just We just marry it or married Invis.
This map sucks.
He's got funny wall hacks, man.
Or this map is really bad in pro play.
From what I was told.
I can only imagine.
I thought Squirrel Girl was one of you guys talking for a
second.
It's so loud.
Yo, you saying we all sound the same?
Yes.
Oh, no, no, no.
And we all sound the same, all of us.
Me included.
Yeah, always.
Three, two, one.
You have to stop them from securing the mission area.
Where are they?
Oh, there they are.
Yeah, they are.
Moon Knight route.
Oh, they're running.
They're running the car.
Come here, more, more.
Careful.
What?
No, they're not.
They're not.
They're right here.
They're a mistake.
They're poorly.
Are they?
Oh, they are now.
Now they are.
I mean, that's fine.
Oh, it's like a troll portal.
Yeah.
They're not actually portaling.
I'm gonna need, I'm backing on heels.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, he was solo.
Trying to just go low.
Holy.
They do have a silo.
You just have to be careful if she goes off angle.
Any heels here?
Thank you.
I was trying to just walking in yeah he's one he's one yeah
yeah nice thank you
you don't go past this yeah just stay here it doesn't really
matter because we're not playing honestly just wait don't
use it yet
they have white fox i mean you can use it here honestly you
want to use it use it use it Yeah, that's good.
I want to win Fox.
Fox is one.
Yeah, I got it.
I got it.
All right.
I have ult.
Use it here?
Oh, that's getting strange whenever you get it if you want.
Yeah, I'm going to do it now.
It's huge.
Big, big, big.
You're at one to one.
Nice.
Ah, sir.
Holy.
There you go.
We're good.
Oh, strange one.
That's fine.
Am I out here?
I'm gonna try ulting their backline, but they may, uh, I can
force out their lanyard.
Yep, that's there.
I'm over.
There you go, forced it.
I got you a bubble.
All right.
We're gonna get ours rolling?
Yeah, they have strange out, by the way.
Okay.
We need to move that.
Yeah.
I can, I'll try and save my shield.
I'm gonna save my shield for it.
They have Groot up, by the way.
I don't have a shield now.
We can rocket for this gambit all when you pop it.
When they have gambit.
Yeah, when they do the gambit.
Just tell me when because I won't recognize it.
Don't worry.
All right.
Just someone call for it.
I'm Altinas.
Oh, they have two, two, two, two, two.
Got it.
I like it.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
They still have...
All right, so we let our sue heal a little bit so we have
the sue alt for gambit because he didn't gamble
I'm just not I'm not gonna use my shield here.
Oh, yeah, I'll help you
All right, yeah, you can heal now rocket Your sidelog's like
your sidelog.
Oh, they're portaling again I think they're actually gonna
go to point They're yeah yeah they're they're pointing
they're pulling point point point point point point Yeah,
yeah, yeah, you can see all on point still on point Okay,
I'm sneaking there.
I'm seeking.
Oh, they go on there.
I'm trying to get in Oh, what?
That's crazy.
I didn't know where it was shielded I got the moon.
I can oh I can't I can't portal that I would have lived if
uh That's fine.
Yeah That's all right.
I must have my health.
You might be able to pull.
Yeah, I'm portaling in this.
I'm opening up.
Just a shot.
Just stall as long as you can.
I'm on point.
Yeah, I'm on.
I'm heading.
Oh, that's fine.
I got it.
Go back to press G if you can so we can reset.
Go come back fully.
You need to stay.
You'll look pretty good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come back or die.
It's a really smart portal from them.
I can't lie.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Martial bar.
Re-effect.
No unauthorized entry.
We don't have...
Nice.
All the merit.
Oh, they have Moon Knight.
I got him.
Nice.
They're strangers though, they're strangers though.
I'm gonna try it.
Yeah, I got her off, I got her.
I don't have shield for this.
Oh, one?
One second.
I'm red.
uh yeah you're yeah you're just even you're even now
hands are shaking again focus i have my ult again all right
i can rock it all right no not yet not use it defensively no
i just said i just got oh yeah okay yeah we'll use uh rocket
first they're not a support yeah just push up if we can
huge There you go.
There's one.
Someone's on the left in this building.
Did they get back?
Yeah.
I got you.
I'm in silent.
All right.
We probably back up.
Just seen if we could get them real quick.
They did my strange all the way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I need help.
Any help here?
Thank you.
All right.
It's going to hold it.
Yeah, yeah.
Rocket, you have to hide a little bit because...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There it is.
We need rocket.
Rocket when you live.
Yeah, yeah.
Nice.
All right, cool.
Just reset and do it again.
I'm out here.
They have an Elsa now.
They might be close to Gambit.
I'll have mine for Gambit again.
All right.
That's good.
Oh, they're portaling.
On point, point.
Just play on point.
Maybe 4v9.
Yeah.
You know, too old, I guess.
Yeah, behind us, behind us.
We're just putting it to block us.
Just back up.
Yeah, yeah.
You have Gambit.
Shall we?
It's Alex in our backline.
No, they got me.
I'm trying to help you.
Yeah, they've been chasing me around.
I got her.
Thanks.
It's fine.
We're even now.
We're even.
I got I got cloud red Oh, he killed it Yeah I'm coming back
as soon as I can Thomas, I'm running I fucked it up I
thought I had alt there I can portal this This leaves my
old, I'm sorry Yeah, we can do a portal Yeah, yeah I have
portal in my hand They don't have portal So No, I'm trying
to be up No Oh, I'm also, yeah.
Are you good?
It's just me.
I should be good.
Yeah, you're good.
Oh, I didn't get anybody.
No, I didn't get anybody.
We have Rokin.
I did.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, go, go, go.
Nice.
Oh, okay, no Rokin again.
That's fine.
Got it.
Nice.
All out here now.
All that one here out now.
No, I got stunned immediately.
Yeah, you're fine.
Hold it.
Hold it, hold it.
I'm one, I'm one, I'm one.
Yeah.
Got it.
That's good.
Oh.
That's so fun.
It's fine.
I'm gonna pop my y'all after this.
Nice.
2Gs.
Very nice!
Nice.
Still have an hour till our match.
yeah whenever they're whenever the first match starts I'm
gonna watch it though just to see what they play yeah yeah I
mean we could do like two I think this is our job and then
we leave we'll never know I don't think I've ever done that
good on squirrel girl holy I mean we could you could do
because like casual more casual players uh it's like a new
crusher basically it's hard to counter squirrel girl i'll
try magneto i think i'm actually the feel for rocket let's
see i'll do emma while you do mag i don't like avoid her but
like i usually when i'm playing by myself like i die i get
like taken out so fast when i play her
yeah i've been trying to give you bubbles if i see you're in
a rough Yeah.
Y 'all have all been goaded.
And the heals are great.
Yeah, good heals.
The strange ults are fat.
All right.
I might actually have to use the tank skin.
All my skins are default.
You all got the drip.
It's because that's how much I hate tank.
I have no cosmetics on any tank.
You don't...
You don't deserve the free currency that rivals give me.
It is a free Emma skin.
No, isn't that the bathtub towel skin?
You can't remove it though.
Oh, God.
All right, here we go.
Give a penny.
We have an angel in the far right as well.
Brick in the nest.
All right.
Me too.
I'm breaking it.
I broke it.
Smell in.
Boasting everyone.
Oh, behind.
We got someone in the back.
Yeah.
Oh, behind.
Oh.
We got someone in the back.
Good.
Brick the nest again.
Yeah.
Penny.
I've got the nest.
I got the nest.
Nice.
They're coming after me again.
Oh, poor, poor.
Everyone, everyone.
I got away from him.
I dashed.
Angela in the back?
Oh, where'd she go?
Just seeing everyone?
Got her.
Nice.
As if I wasn't strong enough.
Where'd she go?
There she goes.
All right.
They have a Thor instead of Penny.
Oh, Angela's flying over.
I hear her to my left.
I was on Phoenix now.
All right.
They don't really have a great front line.
Angela over here.
Yeah.
I'll try to peel.
Just let me know.
I'll be the peeler.
You can anchor.
Oh, I'm getting res.
I'm getting res.
She's res.
The sandwich.
Angela's coming in the back.
Be careful.
Yeah.
Oh, yep.
I need big spray.
Not yet.
I kicked her.
I kicked her away.
Uh, Thor's on back.
It's invisible.
Really aggressive.
White Fox is walking.
I got walk fox.
I'm gonna go for the cloak.
I'm down.
Thor got me.
Thor.
I got the cloak.
Yes.
I got the front line spine.
Nice, nice, nice.
I have Penny and Phoenix now.
Oh, you're in the edge though.
I have my own.
I can pop it first when they push up.
I think it's gonna be just a bit of actual going at one
point.
I can force throw.
I can pop it.
She missed.
Thor in the left.
Thor.
Thor behind.
Yep.
I got her.
I'm peeking.
Got both supports.
Nice.
I know.
Get onto the back.
Nice, he's dead.
Funny over here.
We're done both supports, so be careful going too far.
Yeah, that's fine.
I got health back here.
I hear Phoenix here?
He's dead.
No, maybe I may play smooth.
I need help here, I need help.
Actually, I'm gonna use this, so I get...
I got him, I got him!
I just... I got him.
The fox.
Nice.
Oh, that's unlucky.
Oh, and I hit mid here.
I got rock.
Use rocket alt next.
Use rocket alt.
Now.
Actually, yeah, yeah, yeah, no, no, no, no, no.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There one.
Yeah, Phoenix.
Nice.
They wasted.
They wasted Phoenix.
Nice.
I still have my ult.
All right, that's good.
Mine is gone.
Goodbye, Rocket.
Guys, does it look like I have been...
I had one day to learn tank, guys?
Does it...
I learned tank in one day.
I...
Yes, yeah, I know.
I know it does.
No.
It helps a ton.
I might try this part.
I literally only had...
Like, before I said yes, I've had less than an hour on tank.
I didn't even know how to...
I didn't even know how to strange port them.
Yeah, I can play with you.
I literally had to learn everything in 24 hours.
Who's the tank coach, Madara?
Shout out to Madara.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Got it?
All right.
I don't know.
I'm pointing.
Round point, aren't you?
Okay, Angel's going far right.
Oh, here she is up.
Getting attacked at the back.
Not anymore.
Yep.
Shirley's flying away.
Incapping blood.
Oh, my, no, no.
Oh.
Where is he?
Oh, I can't get that.
Someone else has to.
That's why I rock it up there.
Victory, I mean, yeah, I'm good.
Come on back.
Oh, my God.
He was so low, honestly.
They're just sitting up there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can put a shield up there, but that's it.
Yeah, it helps.
Yeah, there's a story.
Oh, Thor in the back.
We don't have it.
Okay.
Oh god, I'm fine.
Just die on point.
Don't use anything.
We don't have anything anyway.
Dude, white fox and angela.
They should have hella up here.
Hella and rocket up.
And phoenix up.
They don't have hella up.
All right.
Yeah, they do have like a lot of ults here that they can
use.
They should have phoenix up in.
Yeah, my phoenix.
Hella was at 30%.
If I get mine before she goes, I'll use mine there.
Okay.
It's the most time to break it.
pushing up.
Uh, Angela.
Oh.
I don't have to add it for him.
I'm on Thor for you.
I'm on Thor.
I'm trying to peel right now.
I can ult.
Hey, nice.
Angela's also in the back.
I'm gonna go on those supports.
Oh, I got it.
He's done.
Uh, Phoenix one.
Phoenix one.
nice I'm gonna Angela on our rocket I'm helping help our
rocket help our rocket help our rocket nice there you are
nice good comms I don't think I've ever had my stun so
accurate ever you're locked in hey you're locked in for the
tournament yeah uh-huh uh-huh we're Phoenix and Hella and
Broly Rocket.
I have all here.
I can alt the...
I can engage with my old purse.
I'll go with me.
Me first.
Okay.
Nope, never mind.
There you go.
Dory, Dory, Dory, Dory, Dory, Dory.
Dory.
I mean, I'm going for them.
I got the amp.
I'm broken.
I'm gonna try and go for the healers.
boosted oh oh it's fine it's fine i got the three of them
away they're also down angela's here yeah i got rocket alt
ready yeah uh we'll tell you when to use it oh nice oh nice
nice sick
nice i was like who said easy lozi enemy team
They aren't wrong.
It was easy for somebody.
When does the...
We have enough time for another one?
Yeah, we do.
Where they started?
I mean, yeah, we do.
They have to have an intro, remember.
Like a little intro to everything.
We're going to try for support backline.
We're going to try White Fox Invis.
Or White Fox Gambit.
Whichever...
Yeah, we could try a White Fox one for sure.
Yeah.
Whatever.
The right heroes could make all the difference.
Where are you gonna play?
I'll do Mag here.
No timeline exists where Magneto yields.
I'm trying my...
Tank is so hard.
It is so hard.
Like, my brain is just trying to remember where buttons are.
That's why I don't...
I don't... IGL as much.
I'm just like...
Boop!
Just...
There's so much thinking.
Versus like playing support.
I swear it's so easy.
...
Four, three, two, one!
You have to stop them from securing the mission area.
Angela again.
They like that character.
Door.
Be careful the squirrel girl spam.
Yeah, I'm sucking up the spam right now.
What?
Nice.
They have a wall.
Yeah.
I'm saving my I'll save my probably save my blah blah.
Oh.
Oh, he didn't get anybody.
Not in his.
Nice.
Nice kill.
You're actually trying again.
Okay.
I mean, I got you a bubble.
I'm shielding.
Storm might die.
It's just me.
It's me.
They're going super hard for a man.
I got him.
I have bubble.
Is that a person?
I got you?
Throw one, throw one, throw one.
I got- Thor's one!
Thor's still one!
Oh, he's got- he got up.
Uh...
We need to stay alive until we get a support hole.
I'm trying to help him.
Oh, no.
Nice.
Uh, get in front of me, get in front of me.
Good one, good one.
Um...
Oh, Thor's still behind.
Nice.
There is an Angela back here.
Oh, like one.
Got him.
I got there.
It's so good!
Oh, girl, I was like, dang, she could do it one hell of a
day.
No way.
Use it when they run up, when they walk up the choke.
Yeah.
Angela, above.
I have a...
White Fox.
Oh, yeah.
I have a...
When, when they're closer to choke, it's better to use it.
They're gonna have Wolverine and Angela.
So, yeah.
I'm going light jumper and grabbing him.
Yeah.
Try to pull you.
I'm my aunt still.
Guys.
Oh.
This is all of them.
I'm going to, I got Luna.
They're behind you.
Bye, Angela.
I'll see you.
I hear the wolf right here.
Anyone here?
I'm hearing something.
That's fine.
Stay left.
All right.
they have uh i have bubble for you if you can get out bubble
up there got you nice i saw my ult we'll just use it here
are we looking for a no yeah he is i got one no i got one no
i got stunned oh i got one i will portal us back yeah okay
yeah the moment uh i'm gonna go uh i'm gonna go venom then
yeah they're still down in support but they're gonna move we
can white fox out of this portal we want gotcha
have they doubled on time if we can live long enough to get
close then we i'm trying to right now
yeah yeah that's fine uh Go back to mag here.
There's a wolf.
There's a wolf in this one.
There's a wolf?
Oh, no.
Yeah, they're not willing anymore.
What are we going to do?
I'm going to grab him.
We can blow him up.
I'm trying to help you.
Got you?
Nice.
Good.
I can walk up.
And it was behind.
I have a bubble.
He grabs you.
It's fine.
I have bubble.
Yeah, I jumped away too.
Never mind, it's not fine.
He burst it, he burst it.
Yeah, yeah, it's okay.
We should save Cloak for Angelo or whatever offensive ult,
just save for that.
Got it.
Angelo, bro.
I'm coming back now.
Oh, that's fine.
I don't know, wait.
Oh, me too.
Yeah, I'm just gonna...
There's just a lot of damage.
Yeah, I'm just gonna die here.
Yeah, we just do a full reset just back up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We could!
Don't go out yet.
Actually, no.
I was gonna say we could just aggress with the cloak up, but
they do have two offensive ults here.
I'll use my ults whenever we want.
Okay, I'm shielding guys.
Here, I'll shield you.
Got the dead pool.
Yeah, cloak up.
Cook up this.
Good luck.
Nice.
I got taken out by me.
We're still in the back.
I got their scroll.
That's alright.
They backed up.
I got the wall.
Oh, no passive though.
Oh my god.
What a crazy off.
I mean, fuck it.
Okay, they live with one.
That's crazy.
i don't know maybe just back up here to wait for our mag and
our white fox yeah we're coming back now once they get back
we'll go and contest i'm coming back
whoops all right there's like angela on the left yeah
there's a thore there's a thore there's a thore nice all
right angela as well she's gonna be trying to grab yeah i
guys all right i know you're probably screaming um if you're
streaming uh can you change the category to marble rivals
sorry i shouldn't probably mention that earlier it's fine
i'm sorry what was that you have change your category to
marble rivals uh some had like yeah some just had just
cherry so thank you agile is low never mind good luck have
fun thank you guys i got white box all ready you can use it
here okay honestly use it here yeah door is dead just push
up push up with it push up aggressively they got me stunned
oh what there you go he's one too you got me far you're fine
you're fine we can kill them in one thanks thank you oh i'm
down oh no i'm backing up fully oh That got me.
It's all right.
We can use cloak here when we not now not now, but when
we're all dead
Nice, I'm coming back now
There's a wolf right here nice No, I got somebody on my ass
Oh, I should be That door grabbed in the back.
Alright.
Yeah, I'm nice.
I'm chilling.
I am ready to put on a show.
Alright.
I'm one.
Just stop them from doing anything.
Oh, they shielded.
Nice.
Yeah, you just use everything?
I'm one.
It's the last fight.
I'm here.
Here, here.
Two tanks.
One over here.
One over here on me.
Wolf.
I'm coming with you.
There you go.
Nice.
Yeah.
Oh, it's not last fight.
If they portal, it'll be last.
Yeah.
I thought it was last fight.
I was thinking about rank time.
I forgot how quick play is longer.
Yep.
I don't know.
I don't even know what they have.
That's fine.
He fucked it up.
Everything.
Everybody okay?
There you go.
Oh, that's the best I could do.
Give me my last heals, Bihar.
You're getting every left spin.
Oh my god.
Holy.
I mean, that's...
I don't know if we can, actually.
Oh.
Oh, did the game start?
Is it?
All right, let's see.
I'm gonna check.
All right.
uh nope they're not start i mean i think it's just us
waiting to see you're doing like intro stuff yeah yeah intro
stuff yeah
all right i wonder how long it's gonna take i'm gonna see oh
let's see how long it's gonna take till the first match
starts oh they're not they're not in the lobby yet that's
the thing Then they were in the lobby.
Yeah.
Are we going to have search up?
Okay.
I gotta feed my dog.
I'll be right back, guys.
Dad needs food.
I'll be right back.
All right.
I'm back, guys.
Oh.
I am nervous, obviously.
I'm nervous.
But not as nervous as last time because I am off rolling.
So because I'm off rolling, uh, stakes are not as high.
Stakes are not as hot for me, because I'm literally playing
an off-roll that I learned in one day.
I learned all of these characters in one day, so whatever
happens, happens.
Also, sound guy, I hope the sound balancing has been okay.
But it is most definitely, I hate aiming on tank.
Because there's only one character that's hit scan as tank
for me, and it's dead.
It's tank pool.
And, like, if we're playing tank pool, B-Hops is playing
tank pool because he's obviously a tank main.
And so, um, so, like, I'm the best at hit scan and hit scan
and tracking.
So, like, oh my God, it was so hard trying to learn.
Yeah, Emma as well.
Emma as well.
But I feel like Emma might be bad.
If Emma's not banned, then maybe I'll play Emma.
But, um, um, but, it's definitely difficult just because
just because players are a lot more sweat.
Also, they're a lot more sweatier.
Yeah, they're in the lobby.
I guess we just watched the match.
Yeah, they're in the lobby now.
I'm watching.
But they're definitely... Yeah, I'll take some notes and see
what they play.
Yeah, I'm gonna be watching too.
But yeah, like...
This time around it's even more sweaty because they're like
it's full of roll lock so nobody's allowed to swap off their
rolls um and even for strange stall only tanks are allowed
to play strange for stall portal like we can't have like if
we're stalling we can't have a dps or a support to swap onto
strange to stall portal it's heavy roll lock uh no no team
coaches allowed um to like look over team wise No, uh,
there's like, uh, and then there was a team.
I think everybody hit their profiles.
Everybody's profile is private.
So I wasn't able to, you know, scout out stuff like last
time because everybody's profile is private this time.
It was crazy.
And then nobody streamed their practices except for our
team.
Our team accidentally, like, Bhop accidentally streamed his
practice.
Like, nobody.
Nobody streamed any other practices.
We had every team has scrimmed.
Our team just scrimmed today.
Like, we just practiced together today.
This was our first time.
Not right now, like, two hours ago.
Two hours ago was the first time we practiced together,
chat.
But every other team practiced together since yesterday.
I think one team scrimmed for eight hours straight.
No, not straight, but, like, they would take gaps in
between.
But one team had a scrimmed for eight hours.
They really want to win.
Like, which is understandable.
It's a tournament.
Like, it's understandable.
Um, but yeah, this is serious, serious.
I thought it was funny, too.
Remember this form sign-up sheet, guys?
Wait, let me read the sign-up sheet.
Guys, remember the sign-up sheet for this tournament?
Uh.
Wait, okay, I thought it was really funny.
Wait, let me find the tweet, the sign-up sheet tweet.
I
This shit is sweaty sweaty I didn't even think I was Gonna
be playing not gonna lie Like I said I found out yesterday
that I'm back In it Have a fun and chill event Not meant to
be competitive
It doesn't I don't that like definitely uh uh definitely a
lot crazier than i thought it was gonna be
we're into we're trial running we're trial running roll
queue right down this vtuber marvel rivals tournament this
is the trial run this is this is the trial run right now
like what if roll queue existed yeah all right let me write
on here uh watching no it's so like i i'm not as nervous as
i was last time like i said like i'm i'm playing i'm off
rolling and i literally learned the characters yesterday so
like there's no pressure on me to do well everyone knows
what they're getting from me
like with one day to practice with your team like everybody
knows what they're well yeah everybody knows what they're
getting into uh watching first game right now
okay um it's because of me
because they were like okay this is very funny on the forum
It was like Doki Bird, Tant, Locked On Tank position.
And they're like, Doki Bird should better not swap off Tank.
So they created the role.
So now no one can swap off their role.
Because they don't want me to play Supporter DPS.
Like, that's why.
They don't want me to play either.
the dokey bird better not yeah i was like showing madara um
i was showing madara the form because he was like okay how
what's the team's gonna be like and i was like and he's like
why does your say dokey bird must not swap i was just like
oh yeah
Why does that say that no one else has that on their on the
sheet?
All right, but I'm watching I'm watching the comp right now
Wait, are we like right after?
Okay, what is it?
Ba-ba-ba-ba
Ba-ba When's my next match after?
Okay, oh, it's back to back.
Okay, we gotta figure out bad line right after.
Alright, I'm just watching the games now, guys.
I just thought it was funny.
Wait, let me see if I can show it.
Uh...
Here.
Yeah, everyone got caught in the crossfire.
Alright, here it is.
Uh...
I thought it was funny.
That was me.
Locked on tank position.
Cannot play anything else.
Yeah, so I had that.
I had that on my thing.
All right, I'm just watching, guys.
I just gotta take notes.
If I'm not talking, I'm just so locked in right now.
They really had to make sure they did.
I thought it was really funny.
I was like, what the fuck?
Because it wouldn't be fair.
To be fair, it wouldn't be fair.
Learn it.
It's really cool to see you coach the supports in your team.
Lolly, thank you, thank you, thank you.
It's really hard.
really when you're playing tank i can't micromanage i would
have been able i could it's easier micromanage when i'm on
support because it it's like so second nature for me to play
support that like i can easily micromanage everybody like to
be like what like the macro and micro but for this one i was
like it was really hard because when you're tank i'm just
focused on like trying to be sure making sure i'm pressing
the right buttons and aiming correctly because like i said
i'm so That, like, I'm so used to aiming on support that I
can just, like, do it reflexively, like, autopilot, aiming
for it.
But on, like, all the other tanks, I have to, like, think
about my aim, too.
I have to be like, oh, I gotta aim.
I have to aim this and aim that.
All right.
So, that's why it's, like, it's, like, a lot harder to micro
and macro.
watching because we need to know what to do bad line there's
a difference yeah it's like um there is because it's like i
do like all track it's so hard to all track i can all track
uh well i can but like my all track is late you know what i
mean like i have to do late all tracking because i can't all
track in the in during the games because i'm like trying to
fucking survive i'm trying to fucking survive so I can't all
track in the moment but as a support you can because both
for me I can because like I said it's all just second like
second nature for me because I play it so much wait they
have a Scarlet witch player as well oh oh my gosh we like
Scarlet versus Scarlet all
right oh this might be this I hope you're listening we went
all in you'd be a monster I think if If I had more time to
practice tank, I would be kicked out.
Not kicked out, but they would be like, we got to rebalance
the teams.
Like, if I had, if I had more time, they'd be like, we got
to rebalance.
Because I think I didn't.
I was literally practicing in GM lobbies tank-wise.
Because my alt account was like diamond placements.
And I think I got to GM too.
Just practicing, like, literally, the creeping lobby.
But I ranked up.
Is it really griefing if I was ranking up?
Like...
I was playing...
Yeah, I was playing in a tank in GM lobbies.
So it can't be griefing if I'm ranking up.
I'm not.
I'm not that good at tank.
It's so...
It's just...
Tank is such a frustrating role to play.
Because it's like...
The things I want to do I can't do.
That's the biggest issue.
I can't do the things I want to do when I'm playing tank.
Let's see.
No, I'm never playing tank after this tournament.
This is a fucking miserable experience.
I'm sorry.
I'm not depressed enough to play tank after this tournament.
This is the first and last time you'll ever see me play
tank, guys.
Like, willingly.
Oh, like, literally first and last time.
It's ever gonna happen.
I said, it's a fucking miserable experience playing that
role.
I don't understand how tank players do this.
I don't understand how tank mains do this, like, every day,
for five plus hours straight.
Like, are you okay?
Are you, is this, is it a fetish thing?
Just give it to me straight.
Is this a kink or something?
is it, I don't understand.
I don't understand how, how people enjoy this role.
Yeah, I, that was, I realized solo tank, like, after playing
tank, now I know why tanks complain about solo tank.
I was, in the past, I'd be like, Why are they so mad about
solo tanking?
God, like, we can heal you.
And now I understand.
I understand that.
No, solo tanking is never meant to be.
It is never a good time.
There's no reason for anyone to be solo tanking.
There's...
But now I know.
I'm sorry for ever doubting the tank players when they
always complain about having a second tank.
sorry i know now i was foolish to assume
it's not but it's so fucking miserable it really is it's
such a miserable experience
i understand i had to learn it the hard way i did i really
did
all right uh
we're strategizing oh we're strategizing right now all right
i learned i realized your pain now i realized your pain guys
what tank i practiced five tanks i learned five tanks the
basic tank 101
all right that's game our game was about oh i see 6 30 i
called it 630 called it correctly oh they full held too I
think show your team is the strongest team honestly they
have like an uh a DP an actual like DPS main that's not off
rolling um and a very strong enough strong backline they
actually have a strong DPS they have a strong DPS line a
backline so i think like show this team is the strongest out
of all of them i showed our peaches team
does you feel bad for tanks that would mean you play more no
my hate for tanks is justified
my my hatred of that role is justified
anytime someone will be like can you play tank i will
continue to lie and be like, I don't know how to play Tank.
Because I still do not.
I'll continue to lie.
And be like, I don't know how to play anything.
I still only have one hour on Tank.
Our game is up next, guys.
That was a fast game.
I think...
That was fast.
I think we...
Wait, but I was thinking we just keep the same bandline I
proposed, though.
Yeah.
Because I, honestly, I think their front line is, their
front line is the scariest part.
I'm pretty sure.
Oh, okay, okay.
Because we're playing against them right after Peach's team.
Does everyone know what's our first map that we play?
Or did they not say it?
I think it's in the...
rule set because are we still playing the same map as oh
because it says convergence but like which convergence map
it might be a random oh okay unless it's the same one they
just played yeah i was thinking is it the same one they
played or whatever they might not do yeah guess what's here
then it's convoy and then domination all right guys give me
a sec because if it is a oh If it is a...
I'll brush this up.
I will say this one is also pretty easy.
And then...
Yeah, it's fine.
Alright, because if it's a convergence map, I'm ready.
I know what to do.
do.
And then...
Alright, mine for the win.
But only if it's that map.
Only if it's that map.
I just gotta make sure...
Yeah, anyone can play Penny.
anyone can play pennies just wait penny is good against like
i said the more casual player base like if you're in high
elo it's very easy to destroy penny mines and everything but
like you know in the in the lower rank it's harder because
people just want the w key all right yeah go in now i am so
i'm still a little nervous i will say right they put the
lobby in our chat i think we could yeah we have to leave the
lobby leave like leave the lobby and then join it
individually um i need to find this lobby
anyone seen it oh wait you have to go to tournament yeah i
was gonna say is it the turn yeah i see it now and it's the
one without the one i'm in it uh i'll invite the people i
have and yeah if i could get an invite because i'm like yeah
me too i have no idea we'll do we knew marvel ui id invite
i'll invite is everybody in here no i need it oh well we
have someone extra is in this lobby then oh that shouldn't
be here i mean last oh there you go yeah i was gonna say
someone is in here that shouldn't be in here
what is going on yeah yeah we got like they they're still in
the lobby for some reason they're not leaving yeah it's some
of the people from last match yeah they'll figure it out
yeah
yeah like we're all here where's like the supervisor there's
no spectator there's no spectator here they gotta join it
says what that we they need to confirm that we're ready in
lobby town yeah but their team is not even ready so yeah
there's also no spectator here there's no staff in here It
is.
Yeah, it's the one without the one.
Unless they gave us the wrong one.
Convergence.
We got this.
Bro, why is he scared of me?
I haven't played tank before.
There's no reason to be scared of me.
They literally got me to replace their plat tank.
Because that's how they see me.
And I was like, I agree.
I should be the first friend.
I'm like, that's a bit too high of a rank to categorize me
as.
I know who we're banning, right?
It's only when I'm a little chaos.
I literally had to learn Tanks in 24 hours.
Maybe we know who we're banning already.
Yeah, we got more.
Yeah, I gave you the ban line.
Yeah, type in chat so we can just send it.
Oh, yeah, I sent it.
I sent it to him directly.
Right, I'll just...
reply yeah yeah here gotcha gotcha oh no it's the wrong one
no we're in the wrong lobby what oh there should oh they
gave us the wrong lobby i was gonna say where the fuck are
the staff
okay is the password gonna be the same i think might be i
feel like it would be
oh oh wait that's different Yeah, it's the same.
Yeah, it's the same.
It doesn't matter which side we're on, I guess, as long as
we're on the same side.
Oh, no, it does because it says Team B-Hops.
Oh, true.
All right, I'll invite.
I invited.
Thank you.
All right.
We are missing...
Me, me, me.
So is it just bands or is there a save too?
No, just bands.
It's ranked bands.
Okay, cool.
yeah well this is who's missing yeah we're missing someone i
saw it me me me well captain why aren't you inviting people
to the lobby i don't think i have anybody you just do i i
didn't do just go to recent players oh go to recent players
and click the plus oh big dude come on captain come on
captain you still you play this game every day I don't.
They're asking for ready.
Are we ready?
Yeah, I'm ready.
Let's go.
Yes.
All right.
All
right.
Let's see what the map is.
Only Beehawks has to.
Yeah, only Beehawks has to press the stuff, not us.
Okay.
Oh, it's, oh, it's this one.
still muted what you do you think you want to be today all
right do you want rocket or do you want uh don't press don't
select anything yet just wait okay let's select all jeff all
jeff who are you calling a raccoon oh adam across the reflex
the reflex all right
okay all right let's see what they bad i'm curious I'm
curious.
Oh.
No portal.
No portal for either team.
No stall.
That's going to be interesting on the defense.
We get a pick.
It's just immediate point cap.
I wonder what their reconnaissance has gotten them.
I think you just saw me do like five man ults.
Okay.
They're probably in the house.
I'm pretty sure they just watched our streams while we were
warming up.
Should we ban Rocket?
No, we're banning Black Cat.
We have to ban this character.
Oh yeah, yeah.
I'll have a Wolverine.
It's fine.
We have Mag.
Okay.
All right.
We could run.
What do you want to run?
Because I can do Mag Groot.
What do you want to run for us?
Because I can do Mag or Groot unless you're a better Mag
than me.
Oh, yeah, we have a team up, but...
Yeah, we could do Mag Groot from him.
All right.
Then I guess I'll run Rocket.
Oh yeah, you can run.
I guess so.
Yeah.
You want me in Vids or Dagger?
Uh, the thing is I'm gonna be an old battery.
Dagger's better for the first point.
For the uh, the distance like the old that can go forward.
Yeah, yeah.
Just do cloak first.
If they end up on Wolverine, we might have to swap.
Yeah.
We'll see.
I mean, we can see it early.
Yeah.
They're going to have a Gambit, though.
That's fine.
We have Cloak Alt for the Gambit.
We should outlive that.
Yeah, if they don't have Gambit Loki, then you don't always
have to match it.
All right, and how do you want me to handle Rocket Alt this
time around?
We'll call for it.
Gotcha.
Yeah.
We'll let you know when I got it.
We can try to look for, like, Punisher Rocket, Con.
Yeah, if they have wolf call for it, and I'm just going back
to swap.
I'll swap for it.
Deadpulls, DPS, Drupal, Drupal, Drupal, so we're going to
have to go, like, top right, or left.
I'm just going to put that here so we can walk through.
We're going to have to go all inside on the left, because if
we go main, we're just going to be staring at them.
Just come here, come here, come here, come here.
The tank is walled off.
A lot of damage.
Be careful.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm fencing them off.
Bubble, bubble, bubble.
Let's go, the roll.
Break it, break it, break it, break it, break it, break it,
break it, break it, break it, break it, break it, break it,
break it, break it, break it, break it, yeah, yeah, it's
fine.
Oh.
Was that a regroup?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He can.
Nice, nice.
I got one.
Just back up if you can.
Back up if you can.
Yeah, try to live.
I think if I go main, I can wall them off.
Let's wait.
I'm down.
Just wait.
We don't have to go.
Okay, I'm back.
I'm just gonna wall it.
You guys.
You want to set a lot here.
Just wait.
The healers are not here.
All right.
Almost have a.
Oh wait.
Are you sure you want to go back?
Okay, I can wall.
I have a big wall.
We're not here.
A rocket's not here.
Yep.
I'm right behind you guys.
I got rocket alt too.
I almost set my own.
I'm gonna set my own.
I can combo.
I also have alt.
Okay, I have it.
I have it.
Whatever you want.
We can cloak in.
Cloak in.
Oh, it's fine.
All right.
Now in.
Shoot the mag on the right.
Mag is low.
I'm on penny.
That's all low.
You want rocket yet?
Don't scream.
Rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket.
Rocket, rocket, rocket.
Rock it out right now.
Shoot the penny.
Penny one.
He's blocked from those heels.
No one on her.
Nice.
Keep her on.
That's what really- They wasted her.
They wasted, they wasted.
He's alone.
Nice, good, good.
Rock it, rock it, rock it.
Nice.
They wasted both supports.
Yeah.
Nice.
That's fine.
Whenever you get Wanda, let me know when you want to use it.
I can bubble here.
I'll save it for you.
Yeah.
Nice.
All right.
Good kill.
Nice kill.
Nice kills.
Let's get one on the card at least.
Okay, I'm coming back.
Yeah, one.
I just don't go too far.
because otherwise the cart won't move or just hold this
corner yeah i can try i can look for all i can look for all
i'm looking for all cars so we can build all with club i'm
looking for all i'm looking for it go for it yeah i'm
waiting for it we are down at your level because the cars
should just be aware of that yeah yeah i'm waiting waiting
for them to pull up i'm just waiting for pull up just don't
don't push up too much because i'm gonna wait for it he's
just we have free push we Re-push.
Yep.
Whenever you're...
Go, go, go, go!
Huge one.
Oh, we blocked it.
There is it.
Mag one, mag one, mag one.
Yeah, I got you.
I got you.
Nice!
Nice, nice, no more else.
No more else.
Nice.
We might have used too many though.
Yeah.
It should be fine.
I'm not a portal.
Oh, yeah.
That's true.
I can block it here.
You're on point?
No, that should be.
They shouldn't be able to recontest.
We can use the venom wall on the right way.
You can play Glamf, please.
Alright, now we got it.
I will stop my ult.
You can combo this with the super health.
They're on blue root now instead of pinning.
That's fine.
They don't have a Punisher for it.
I have a Punisher.
I'm my ult too.
I'm trying to do aggressive.
We need help here.
Break it, break it, break it, break it, break it.
I'm not there.
Yeah.
I got rocket.
Back up.
Back up, you can.
I'm putting some walls off to block them.
They don't have any super notes, by the way.
Yeah.
Do you want me to use it?
I'm a muster.
We're dying.
Oh, you have to come back.
I'm down.
Wait, so you two, two, two, wall up.
Wall up, wall up.
Yeah, yeah, push up, push up, push up with this.
Push up with this.
They're walled out.
Get a new one.
No, we don't need it.
No, no, nothing.
No else.
All right.
Back up, back up again.
Only P. Yeah, yeah.
Oh, run around.
Oh, wait.
Never mind.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Yeah.
Bubble, bubble, bubble.
Nice.
Wait for the car.
Yeah, I have all.
I'm going to look for all.
I'm on it.
I'm looking for all.
They can't see me.
If you can let them push up, if you can let them push up.
I'm going to look for health here.
You see where I am?
I'm going to try to eat it.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm looking here.
Looking here, here.
Oh, I'm fucked.
Oh, wait.
Got it.
I got it.
Nice kill.
I'm on the rocket.
Burned it.
They stun me right away.
That's fine.
Just hold die for it.
Yeah.
We can go.
We're gonna, I'm gonna die here probably.
Yeah, yeah.
We have Rock Adult to go through.
I do have it ready.
Oh, nice.
You have to die, though.
Nice.
We gotta wait, wait, wait.
Just wait for him.
Yeah, the moment they showed up, I got stunned.
Yeah, yeah.
We can do, uh, we can do Rock, Rock Adult here first.
Gotcha.
That's a bubble for a little bit.
Yeah, yeah.
Quick as well.
They're gonna have, Gamda?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, actually, uh...
They don't have to buy shit.
Do you want it?
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Through it!
You can use it soon if you want.
I almost have my own.
It's close.
We can use Rocket here, right?
I didn't use Shit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Rocket, Rocket this!
Rocket this!
Rocket!
Okay.
I got somebody on my ass.
Dude.
They're down to support.
That's one.
They use Gambit and Deadpool.
I'm down too.
We still have one more fight.
Alright, so you use Gambit, they use Deadpool.
I think that's it.
I have, we can...
You want Cloak in aggressively or no?
We're cloaking aggressively with Punisher.
You're supposed to be careful, because I can only bubble one
of you.
Yeah, that's true.
Okay.
Fall back, they're coming to you.
So just don't charge the ult at first until they cloak this
far.
you cloak and yeah cloak and punish you're up i'm coming
over you just let me know when are they gonna have mag well
you have bubble for it okay i'm gonna need another 10 now i
think yeah they have it they have it bubble bubble thank you
nice nice good dodge i held after this i'm gonna look for it
mag mag i got it i got it oh wait nice nice mag is resin
alert deadpool going in the back kill the deadpool I'm
looking I can't see him.
Deadpool one!
Deadpool one.
Oh, nice.
Gone, gone, got him.
I'm, he's got me, got me.
He's on you soon.
Which is nice.
I'm dead though.
They were sitting on this team.
We can back around the corner.
Yeah, I'm trying to back up.
I'm trying to back up right now.
You can keep me up.
Back up with it.
Try not to die.
I'm trying.
They got me from the side again.
You're by yourself.
Got a TP.
We have to charge.
There's no TP.
We just don't have time.
Yeah, that's fine.
We just have to have a good first one.
I mean, I could play Penny here.
I would only do it if you're comfortable on doing it.
I'm comfortable.
I mean, Penny is pretty easy.
Oh, we got this.
I had to go shield mode.
We got a hate raid.
Oh.
What?
That was a good hold on.
We push a three fire.
I'm here to finish the fight that my father began.
That was good.
Alright.
Let's do this.
He's a little annoying.
It's not like tank pool though.
Tank pool is worse.
Yeah, true Okay It's a mine's here
All right They can't portal pass so yeah Unless You gotta
press your f again.
Yeah I just noticed it.
3, 2, 1.
Who cares?
My feet get square over angle.
I won't be surprised if they don't do it.
Better put like some webs connecting it like a little
further.
Yeah.
Throw it in my bubble.
That's annoying.
That's fine.
Yeah.
You got res.
Nice.
It's really good.
Okay.
That was nice.
Now we have time to just don't go too crazy because we're
still down one.
They are probably just farming for Gambit ult.
Yeah, yeah.
And then they're just going to go in.
I'm going to stop doing as much damage.
Yeah, I'm just waiting.
We can farm a little bit too.
Yeah, I'm just not going to shoot.
They're just waiting for Gambit.
Yeah, just just wait.
Just wait.
Don't shoot as much.
Yeah, because we can farm our own Gambit ult because I'm not
shooting as much other day.
Oh.
Oh, be careful.
Be careful.
They're doing a lot of damage.
Deadfold is off the old thing.
I'm trying to peel.
i got it we're even we're even bubble bubble bubble try to
stay in it oh we're trying to shoot i'm shooting it i'm
shooting it i'm down okay we just shoot the squirrel girl a
lot more all right we could swap later b hops where i play
mag and you play yeah we could try that after all it's
We have Punisher ult here.
We could aggressively that.
As long as you guys come back?
Gambit with Cloak.
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, yeah.
If they gamble, just match it with.
Or we can Cloak as well.
Okay.
We can Cloak first.
Oh.
Yeah, or you have to die there.
Okay, cool.
You have to...
I think we should go...
You can use Cloak.
I'm trying to heal him.
I'm trying to heal back.
Come back, come back again.
I got you.
Oh, he missed, he missed, he missed.
I got him.
There are wins.
Group can die.
I've got Rocket Alt.
Whenever they Luna Alt, we'll just try to match that with
Rocket.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can try to kill it with the...
I have Alt here.
I'm going to try and look for Alt here.
Stay up.
Just don't die here.
You have to be careful positioning, guys.
I'm looking.
I'm looking for it here.
That should be good.
That's a huge up.
Rock kill.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
No, no, no.
They chased me away.
They got Skroto back on me.
You're down both supports.
Be careful.
All right.
You're down both supports.
So just be careful.
Play a little further back.
Yeah.
Scarlet, Scarlet, come back a little bit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come back.
We don't have supports.
Give him a little bit of space.
Yeah, yeah.
They're going to get back quicker.
I'm just...
I'm back.
backing up a little.
All right, we're almost back.
They're going to have Grudel.
Yeah, yeah.
If you can.
All right, I'm back now.
He's looking for Alt right here.
I can tell.
Yeah, we need to rock it for another Grudel.
We can rock it.
Rock it, rock it, rock it, rock it, rock it, rock it.
Rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket.
Oh, yeah, they pushed like crazy.
Holy.
Holy combo.
Wait, what's your...
Okay, you have Mag out.
All right.
We have another push here.
Yeah, when you hear the gambit, just instantly throw the ult
out.
I did.
I was just a little bit behind.
Yeah, I'm backing out, but...
I'm pushing up a little bit.
Oh.
Got him.
Luna low.
Luna one.
Nice.
No, they're down two.
They're down two.
No more.
Yeah, no more else.
No more else.
Kill this one.
Oh, yeah.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Oh, no.
It's gone.
We can still kill these people.
Yeah, get good, get good.
Any kills are big.
More time they have to lose.
What do they use?
They use Squirrel Girl?
They should have Deadpool and Maglet.
I'll use Miles first, but don't use anything until after
Miles.
Don't use anything yet.
If nothing dies, then we'll use something.
You want a combo?
Yeah.
If nothing dies, we'll use something.
Okay.
I'm looking for it.
Here, here, kill it.
Big ears!
Nothing, nothing, nothing, nothing!
Nothing else, nothing else, nothing else!
Go here!
Kill me, heal me, heal me!
Okay.
There you go.
Okay, the magic mag win, mag win.
Nice, we didn't have to use anything.
That's good.
Nice timing out here.
Alright.
Next ult, we'll use Punisher ult.
If they use...
Groot, Gambit, we use Cloak ult.
We use Cloak ult.
Okay.
We should try to use Rocket Punch.
Punisher.
Okay.
Yeah.
Rocket Punisher.
We can use that here.
Do it here.
I don't know.
Second you get rocket.
Whenever you get it, press it.
Stay alive.
Nice.
Really good.
There's a bubble.
There's a bubble for you.
Nice.
They only have a minute.
That's like a fight and a half.
I think like from my last, my last battle.
Oh no, no.
No, you didn't have to use that.
It's fine.
Back up.
Yeah.
Don't go too far.
They're about to use, like, land it probably and explode.
Yeah, they have a...
They have...
We have to save Coco for the...
The last buy, like, I think.
Wait, Groo, Groo, Groo!
Oh, he was so low.
I'm backing up.
I'm backing up, but...
We were by yourself.
Yeah, I was.
All right.
I got their Luna.
Nice, nice, nice.
Scroll one, scroll one.
Scroll one.
I think someone...
They're gonna use Groo's stream, eventually.
Yeah, yeah, he's looking for it.
He's looking for it.
Group one.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
They have to...
Alt to touch soon.
Yeah.
We can hold aggressive.
Just be careful, Aura.
Nice kill, nice kill.
Yeah, they can.
They have the alt aggressive.
So at the moment they all...
They can't.
You win.
Oh wait, on the point.
Someone see nine.
Someone go back.
Go back.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Go for it.
I got you.
I'm gonna...
I'm shielding it.
All you have to do is kill them.
Big kill.
I'm almost unable to.
I almost have all too.
Use it.
Use it here.
Use your old.
Use everything.
Big, big, big.
They're dead.
They died.
Nice, nice, nice.
We got it.
They died.
Nice.
We did it.
Good job, guys.
First win.
Let's go.
Oh my God.
Good job.
Yeah.
I'm gonna bed my family.
My heart.
Oh my god.
GG's.
That was stressful.
I was like shaking this.
I just kept lobbing shit.
Holy shit.
Go to heels.
I'm brooding it.
Because I told you over 45 every time.
I tell you.
We did it.
My minds had to deal with a hate raid that entire map oh no
i got one yesterday i got one yesterday that's why i stream
on youtube i got none they're targeting like mario i was uh
oh really oh yeah go on yesterday
oh that's bad i'm sorry i'm sorry that's going happening
right now holy i need also b-hop also comment that's okay my
mods are goaded they took care of it oh my god i All right,
next up, it's Shoto's team.
Yo, you guys crushed it.
Wow, that was great.
Oh, thank you.
We're going to drag you to the chat, and you can talk to
Mouse Farm, okay?
Oh, that's kind of cool.
All right, good luck on interview.
Okay.
Good luck.
Okay, good luck.
Have a good one.
I'm so...
I hate Tanks so much.
Wow, I hate playing Tanks.
I'm gonna be so honest Like at first It's being nice I can
only see it In the corner of my eye So much I was like Oh
thanks for the raid No And then I saw What it was saying And
I was like Oh no Shield mode Shield mode Shield mode Yeah
Thank you I thank you I know how to do Groot ult My walls
Might be a little shaky But like I know how to do ult So
Well, not the first one.
Look, it took me a lot to get the hang of it.
It took me...
I had some practice in rank.
Except for the few solo ults.
I need them to...
That's the thing.
Groot is so easy to abuse in the lower elo.
Because people don't know how to eat Groot.
Yeah.
I just know how to do walls when I...
That's really it.
Walls went ulting.
That's it.
I was trying to wall people off.
It was very hard to do.
I can't believe I got target banned.
I can't believe it.
Me?
I'm the one to get target banned.
That's crazy.
but it backfired that's right because i knew it i had a
feeling that it might happen they're like there's no way she
could learn more than three tanks there's no way she could
learn more than three tanks in one day but i did i played
the i played this game like it's fucking chess i i was like
I have to learn four tanks just in case just in case this
might happen to me
actually Madaya was like maybe you should learn a fork today
he was like I think you might need to learn a fork tank just
in case I was like oh shit okay all right he's like have you
ever played group before and I was like not really like all
the other things I've never really played takes before and
he's like I'm gonna give you like a speed run on Groot as
well like oh I knew that might happen to me I knew oh my
goodness the game oh how's the interview bro oh yeah how was
it yeah i was so nervous what did they ask you uh they were
just asking like they asked us how we felt when they back
capped us and then like what why we couldn't get third point
and if we had any secrets but for like the other teams but
obviously i didn't tell them nothing obviously definitely
yeah obviously that'll be a captain that'll be a captain all
right we got we have next game soon oh perfect oh yeah are
you next yep well yeah it's back to back and then we get one
chill and then uh another one i think showed us seems gonna
be the hardest out of all of them that's who we're doing
next yeah um just because they have a really good they have
a good front line and also a wait i don't even remember it i
think it's front line and uh dps we gotta take papa down
dude so yeah he's the problem we gotta think about because
like uh actually i think they just have like a solid player
in each role honestly so they're very uh well rounded as a
team oh oh i'll give you the band line for this one okay
okay um let me see if i can find it because i don't remember
what i wrote
Connor just said it's a five minute break before the next
one.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
I think we need a little breather.
Yeah, do we have to leave this one?
Yeah, I think we need that.
I think we're on the second one because there's no staff
there.
I'm pretty sure.
The third ban, it's up to you to want to ban this one unless
you want to ban something else.
What's our third map?
is it uh i'm a nation okay the third one i think oh sorry
second this our second one is okay the second one's payload
too so uh the third one is up to you if you want to do this
ben
and but if you don't you can it's it's either that or
whatever you see we saw from the stream um okay it's from
the stream oh yeah the second one if they play that they do
that was the the first match that we yeah the first match so
uh most likely uh
uh honestly is really up to you because uh
can we also have a good one that plays that too yeah that
this is the reason why okay it might be a good idea because
we are more flexible on yeah so we can just do that yeah
just do that band line then that's the only reason why 10
for it
we're going to a small intermission before your match we are
we playing the next one yes we're back to back and then
there's a game break yeah oh my god back yeah no it's like
it goes fast it goes really fast it's only during the finals
where it drags done.
Yo, I can't believe it's already 10 p.m.
with the break.
Yeah, I was surprised it started so late in general.
Yeah.
I have no idea why Peach didn't ban group because they don't
want me on Strange.
That's the reason why.
I was literally playing Strange during Quick Play and
they're like, oh, no.
Because Strange is more is DPS heavy.
That's the only reason why.
but little did i know i can actually play four tanks maybe
more depends on the situation okay yeah they told us to take
a break too i'm gonna go pee i don't have to but i think i
might after this match yeah just you know i think i think
i'm a stretch you know get some blood yeah no everybody's i
think every team scouted i'm pretty sure i'm pretty sure all
team like every profile was super locked I couldn't even
scout if I wanted to I literally went in, looked at it You
know when Everyone's super tryhard When the casual players
have their profiles Locked, that's when you know
That's when you know
I hate tanks so much I'm sorry not enjoyable
it's the sacrifices I make I'd rather like let someone else
stress out
let's see
also there's not enough tanks to ban us out too to be fair
there's not enough bans to ban us I still can't believe you
can't save anything for a tournament it you can't save
anything that's crazy all right let me join the other room
just join in advance uh i should know p me p me join room
and then p there you go yeah i knew it i predicted it yeah
by the way it is in the second room all the spectators are
here now i'll start inviting people in.
Thank you.
Predicted it perfectly.
It would be like, how did they know?
We know.
How did they know?
All right, I'm going to use the bathroom now.
Playing Aurora on the other team.
Aurora, come over here.
They haven't, oh, they named it already.
So yeah, we're on this one.
Aurora.
Aurora betrayed us.
Aurora's on the other team.
She's a double agent.
Oh, she's gone entirely.
Aurora's gone!
They killed her.
Adano snapped her away.
Can I get another invite?
Aurora, come back!
You did it!
You blew it up!
I sent you one.
Aurora, stop going to the edge.
just hit the join button on our team hit the join nope
that's coach yep there you go i don't know what to do with
my hands and this is which team this is we're going against
shoto's team now yeah shoto i'm gonna pee myself a little
bit i can tell on this one no we got this i'm scared you
gotta trick yourself into oh it's like stockholm simply is
that how they do it is that how all players do it?
Is that is that it?
Is that why you're all tank means?
You just play it enough that you just get Stockholm syndrome
and just be like, I guess it's an envoy this time.
Oh my god.
After you beat yourself senselessly trying to play the role.
That's fine.
Pretty much.
Convoy's gonna think for us.
Ew.
Oh, yeah, and alcohol, too.
I drink and abuse.
Classic.
Hmm.
Oh, all right.
Let's try this out.
We are not ready, right?
Is everyone here?
Are we in here?
I mean, yeah, I'm ready.
Oh, we're all in.
Wait, no, but then someone might have.
Is Aurora here?
Yeah, I'm here.
Okay, so we're all here.
now i think we're good yeah we can r okay thanks i think
we'll just do the three three bands that you sent
spider islands oh we're gonna attack or defense for i think
we're i think we're a defense defense yeah we were on the
left side left side is really d which hero do you think you
want to be today yeah um black panther i'm gonna use
spider-man spider-man only my neighborhood is not like
multiple realities i want to play spider-man now who am i
gonna banish from this match i guess the order doesn't
matter too much but i'm gonna do that one first yeah it
doesn't matter there's no protect yeah i mean it might
affect what they ban but i they probably have it set in
stone like read it
oh okay that's good for me good look that cute oh yeah yeah
and the third one is uh we're wanting to do cloak still
right is that good for everybody and yeah because we can run
other yeah we can run invis yeah yeah they don't like the
tank pool i know i'm a target fan all the teams i think it's
because i saw you play tank pool like non-stop it was it was
working way better in the quick play than the scrum though
too it's weird plug-in yeah
okay i'm curious if they they're only gonna be here oh yeah
man that's fine they're gonna give me Wanda again.
Nice.
Oh, okay.
And we can do this, right?
This is strange.
Yeah.
Or you can do Emma if you want.
Yeah, I'm sure you think Strange is better.
I think Mag is better for defense.
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, you can do attack Emma.
I'll do attack Emma.
Yeah, you can like bubble the ult and stuff.
Yeah.
Okay.
Be super clear about when my ult is ready.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Also, yeah, and also we got to make sure we don't use all
our ults at the same time because that was an issue for one
of our fights.
be like only this ult don't just hold it just we just gonna
use one ult yeah i like those communications on the ult
that's really nice all
right i gotta be careful of your dps
i'm thinking phoenix yeah i think so i don't know oh yeah
phoenix is cool yeah i think you might uh might have to swap
the white when you die.
Me?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Rocket has swapped the white fox.
We'll do.
Oh, they have Angela.
You can save your pushes for Angela.
You're getting- Angela backline?
Yeah, Angela backline?
Angela?
That's fine.
Angela win?
I'm gonna fine, fine, fine, fine, fine, fine, fine, fine.
I'm just- Just play like this chair of- Yeah, yeah, I mean.
Oh, yeah.
Nice trade.
Good trade.
I don't have my bubble right now.
I gotta play a little.
They're on me.
They're on.
It's fine.
She didn't get anybody.
Yep.
They got any more?
They got a bunch of clones when we can, when we have them.
Angela, back lane.
Just remember to save your push for Angela.
Okay.
Angela back lane.
Oh, she got me.
That's fine.
She got bubbled.
Oh, my God.
Nice.
Wait, I've got somebody on me in the back.
I need heals though.
Yeah, you're good.
You're good.
I got Rocket.
Save it from now.
If they use this portal, use it and use yours to match
theirs.
We'll try to comment.
It'll be the fox ult when they turn into the fox.
My guy.
Oh, nice.
I'm a nice pick.
We can try to get another pick, but don't go too far.
I'm backing out here.
We have a really good spot here.
We want them to use ult instead of this.
Do you want Rocket to do ult first?
rock y'all first, yeah.
Yeah, I'm gonna try to burn their fault.
No, no, no, no, no.
One-night push-up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll call for it.
Wait, Bios, you call for it.
You call for it.
Yeah, yeah.
She took out your revive.
Try to hide it a little.
Angela, hold up.
Angela, I got her.
I got her.
I got one.
Oh, thank you.
Bios, you have to call for the rock y'all, okay?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got one.
Big fish.
Mag, mag?
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
No ammo.
They might also have one.
They're gonna have mag ult.
One to ult.
Wait, we can do...
The one con is Angela.
Yeah.
You don't want to do Punisher Rocket right now?
Angela, backline, Angela backline.
We should wait for them to go first.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, all right.
Just when I ult is here for mag ult.
Nice.
I have to reload here.
I'll be next to you.
Be careful of Nomura.
Oh, nice.
Burn it, burn it, burn it, burn it.
We're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
I'm gonna pop.
i'm shielding i'm shielding yeah they have it you want
rocket yes yeah rocket rocket rocket rocket rocket rocket
rocket rocket rocket rocket rocket no more no more else no
more no more else no more they got me no more else no more
else no more else are we down one i know we're good we're
good nice i'm not gonna go right and die as well i will here
i'm gonna hide for it behind be careful yeah we can maybe
kill going for the health pack i think i can get her she's
she's out yeah i'm I'm gonna hide for the alt.
I'm gonna hide for the alt.
They have Elsa now, but you're not gonna have stacks or all.
I think that's better for it.
My alt first?
They went Moonite and Elsa.
They made changes.
We have our...
Alti?
I'm gonna... I'm gonna get...
Break the runes, break the runes.
Loki, I'm pinged.
That's Loki.
Loki one, Loki one.
Nice.
Angela, Angela.
We're res and they're...
Yeah, yeah, we're back.
I need backup.
We jumped us from the back.
It's fine, it's fine.
Angela win Angela win I just have to give a little bit of
space Yeah Yeah Keep backing up Keep backing up I'm on my
way back I need I don't have shields I don't have Shields
It's fine It's fine It's fine So back up Yeah I'm backing up
still Once our rocket gets back They may have Angela Okay I
still have my Wanda She's looking at me Yeah We can use
Wanda Yeah I'll There you are I'm происходит I don't have
They're gonna push us here They're on me They're on me
Alright They can't give us Um Okay Do you have TP?
I can, I didn't die here.
I didn't die here.
If we can like sit on it.
Do you have any swap?
Papa's been going after me hardcore.
I don't think I can.
We're gonna have to go second.
Yeah, just back up fully, back up fully.
We're staggered really hard there.
Just back up fully.
I'm gonna try and shield you.
It's fine.
It's fine, it's fine.
I had full level up.
Back up, back up, back up.
Keep backing up.
Don't peek.
I'm going to use my shield for us to back up fully.
All right.
We can use...
Do you want to use the Scarlet with Mag?
Yeah, I can.
Yeah, we can.
Yeah, we can use that to engage.
Just call for it.
I'm going to...
I'm pushing forward.
Oh, Angelica.
They're going after me again.
You might have to swap off Scarlet after.
Yeah.
I got both supports.
We can...
Yeah, I'm coming over.
I'm coming over.
I'm hoping for you.
I got him.
Oh, they got me.
No more.
No more else.
No worlds.
No, we're fine.
We're fine.
We're coming back.
No worlds.
They'll get back quick.
So just back out.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, hold point.
We saw both supports.
We got to use Scarlet.
Oh, hide your res.
Hide your res.
Dispand that res.
Hide it.
She's after it.
Oh, she's on the roof.
You want me to counter it?
Wait.
Got it, got it, got it, got it, got it.
Circuit clerk.
That's fine.
That's a lot of damage.
Are they usually...
Angela Moon Knight.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just die or back out.
Die or back out.
You're stalling yourself.
I can try to do a portal Wanda ult.
Yeah, yeah, I can do that now.
Yeah, I think that's gonna be our thing.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, they're just coming.
They're coming.
Ready?
They're trying to calm it down.
Three.
I'm gonna try to protect.
I'm going now.
She said.
They're down the tank.
I got it.
No more no more ults.
No more ults.
We got the support.
Help, boy, help!
I'm trying to get you.
But down to support, we can keep pressing them.
We got rocket alt.
I don't have shield right now.
I'm trying to put this last fight, honestly.
We can stall it.
Just stall it.
You want rocket?
Right now?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, right now, right now.
Tapping, popping.
Only half.
Oh.
They're on me again.
I got it.
Look at me, look at me, look at me.
Look at me, look at me.
Got you, got you.
We're coming.
We're gonna TP probably.
Yeah, yeah.
I have all for TP.
I have all for...
Nobody's Portland yet?
Wait, wait, C9, C9, C9, C9!
I'm...
Yeah.
C9, C9, C9, C9, C9, C9.
Oh, they got me.
They got two of us.
It's fine, it's fine.
We just gotta get the right kills.
We got another.
We're on a show.
Huge ball.
Yes.
Come on, come on, come on, come on, come on, come on, come
on.
Nice.
They have no support.
Angel is on us.
I'm coming over.
I got the Luna.
They have no supports.
You guys can win that.
They're down all supports.
Use the, use it, use it now.
Use it.
Got it, got it, got it.
Using it.
I got it, got it.
Ignored it, Angela.
I can't get Angela.
Keep the same target.
Call targets.
I got it, I got it.
Nice, nice, nice.
Nice.
i'm on my way back angela's at our spot nice really good
that's super good yeah we're fine real good two that's
that's good angela was determined to take me out time to
switch things up including which sides you're on the support
oats are really good we're getting value yeah yeah top notch
team to win this one all right do you want white fox this
time oh i think rockets working rocket's working yeah yeah
the only reason why is that they go on phoenix yeah if
they're where you swapped a white uh white fox yeah it's
funny working i want to try a small um i think it's fine i
mean you want to go phoenix too yeah if you want i think
something else would be better yeah i'll try and then if it
was my crosswalk funny is just really good for shooting the
angular but still is phoenix you want money on mag or emma
um i'm gonna try emma at to see if they have like a compact
oh sorry do you want me on mag or strange sorry um maybe i
think you should stay that for now the only thing we'll have
to be careful of is the uh you'll have to stay in your
punisher when she alts yeah yeah yeah i'll try to coordinate
that i have to make sure yeah when you are gonna alt i'm
gonna you need to make sure that my shield is full okay i
still have Angela that's their win con he might try to go
for a pull immediately yeah I'm gonna try to go for a pull
immediately oh hi there she I hear it goes above the spawn
door yeah I see it I can't shoot him he's going for it give
him an ammo I'm looking for your virus yeah I'm good
Angela's going for you no he's gonna push Angela's on the
left just be careful though they're gonna go around got me
she hit me a little bit it's fine Angela it's She's real
aggressive here.
They use runes already.
I'm putting a shield behind their ammo.
Oh, I need heals.
Oh, I got caught.
We're losing people.
Hold on.
We're just reset.
Reset here.
Yeah, I'm done here.
They're coming up.
Yep.
They're coming out for me.
Just reset fully.
Back up fully.
Back up fully here.
I shielded it.
Yeah, save your push.
We're going to save your push for the Angela.
Okay.
How to break the low key clones if we ever...
I'm in one.
That's fine.
Why am I done?
They're putting on a lot of damage guys.
They're coming to me in the back.
Nice.
Nice guy.
Stabilize.
We're...
Come to me.
Are you guys going backline?
I see you.
I'm good now.
I have my ult.
Do you want me to use it?
Her.
Probably not.
They got me again.
Oh, they got me.
Papa's been going after me like crazy.
I think we reset here.
Yeah, we reset.
We reset.
Do you want me to switch to Squirrel Girl to focus the back
line more?
Yeah.
Yeah, because every time Papa can't, he does come straight
for me.
Yeah, we just need to appeal for the Angela.
Do you want me to swap to White Box or stay Rocket?
That's fine.
Stay Rocket.
Yeah, stay Rocket.
I'm going to use Rocket all aggressively if we can when we
get it.
I think or we could wait for Punisher and combo right either
way.
Yeah, I think we should wait for a Punisher combo.
Yeah, we could do that.
I might be able to...
Look in the runes.
Okay.
Nice.
Just call out when the Angel is in the back.
Angel's here.
I got Rocket Alt.
I'm shield.
I can't shield.
I can't shield anywhere.
I got caught.
Yeah, me too.
That's fine.
Just full wipe nice and nothing.
Don't use anything.
Yeah, they use...
They're gonna have Moon Knight all here and they use...
Their Moon Knight's cookie.
Oh, they have...
Uh...
They have Elsa all here.
I can try and...
I can try and do a...
Yeah, I'll try and do a strange one here.
Yeah, I'll bubble you.
Yeah, I'll bubble it.
Let me know when you guys are ready.
Yep, I'm ready to hit it.
Yep.
They're probably gonna have Ender up.
I can't do it here.
Ow, ow, they're on me again.
Oh, no, no, no, oh, you guys used it.
We'll take advantage of it.
Got one.
It's just you two.
Got two.
I'm coming over, I'm coming over.
If you guys can- There's a lot of damage, a lot of damage.
I'm holding back.
They're down in support.
I have, they use, we might have to use the rock y'all
aggressively.
You have to be by yourself, but have to be by yourself.
Yeah, I'm there, there, there.
30 seconds.
Yeah, yeah.
Are you guys ready?
Do this here.
Yeah, I have squirrel ult.
Okay, ready?
Oh.
I'm good.
Maybe helps is down.
Back up.
Wait, wait.
Okay, I'm gonna try and use this aggressively here.
Are you guys all ready?
You guys have to do this without us.
You can play like I'm there.
They're on me again.
That's fine.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You have to all.
Broke out!
Broke out.
Broke it out.
Get all the Moon Knight old can.
I can come back with Portal.
You'll have to keep fighting until we have a winner.
They're still trying to dive me, yeah.
I'm a win.
They're gonna get flustered here.
It's time over time, so.
I have Ragnarok.
Come on.
I have TP already.
It's fine.
TP's up.
It was on me.
She got me.
I'm reviving.
I don't need help, though.
Coin, coin, coin, coin.
That's fine.
I'm down.
I think we need a- we definitely need a- we definitely need
a- I think I know the problem with the rocket.
You have to come to us when they're diving you.
You have to fly to us.
I'm not that far behind you guys.
It's just that he keeps coming after me and he takes me to a
random corner.
Yeah, like when you hear the Angela flying, that's also, we
need like our other support to cover for you for that.
That's why, so when you know that he's coming, our Invis has
to push him.
So you have to play next to a rocket.
You two have to play next to each other.
You're not playing next to each other at all.
rocket keeps getting uh dragged on by the Angela I try to
push but doesn't come back fast enough yeah but it's just
you just got to stay with him because the Angela can't do
anything if you pocket each other if you patty kick each
other she can't do basically um that's the only issue like
you're two you two are playing way too split up if our
rocket is the one getting picked all the
time yeah we stopped the end of the getting value should
yeah I think I think one of us to come back and peel.
Alright, next up is we guess we wait.
Yeah, Invis is like Angela's greatest counter.
If anything, um, maybe if we fight them again, they go
Angela.
I think you might have to go Emma to grab the Angela or
something.
And I can go Mag.
Oh, that is a good plan.
I like that plan.
I could try it.
Yeah.
Because you can grab the Angela and I'll just bubble people
who get That Angela was aggressive.
Angela is so hard, though.
What if we just, like, ban Angela and keep the cloak?
Yeah, we can do that.
We can ban Angela.
Yeah.
I agree with that.
Because she is just a problem.
Yeah, we can just do that.
If we fight them again, if we win the next game, if we win
the next game, we fight them in finals, basically.
Yeah.
The annoying thing is if we do leave the cloak open, instead
of having Cloak Loki, or Luna, Loki, they're going to have
Cloak Loki, which is even harder.
So we'll just have to do something about that.
We have to do, I mean, we'll have to match mirror the Cloak,
most likely.
But then, yeah.
I mean, we're running Emma, Mag.
It wouldn't matter if we're mirroring.
That's basically it.
Yeah, I think it just sucks because B-Hop died there last
second so we couldn't have a proper fight i had to like
engage and then when we both got pulled they everybody
popped all yeah and we're very limited with what we can play
because there's like casual players so we have to like play
around the we have to play around everybody i just didn't
yeah i was just like whoa
can we ban it like also are you still bucky i think bucky is
i mean we could if you want to give her bucky if she has
more time on bucky than elsa i don't think elsa was that
disrupt i think bucky always more disruptive than elsa it's
just when elsa altered us uh she altered both our tanks and
you guys popped all while we were off the when we died i
think there is a Like, Bucky might be easier to deal with
because he's always in front and he's kind of slow.
That's true.
The Elsa ult, like, fucks us and the front lines super hard.
And it's not easy to react to it.
Like, whenever she ulted, I pressed mine and it canceled it
and put it back to 50 and took us off the map.
Oh, I see.
I didn't realize that.
It's super annoying.
I mean, if you want, yeah, we can swap the band from Elsa to
Elsa.
Because the Bucky is, like, usually, that's, like, a
frontliner.
So it's mostly going to be on me and you who's getting
attacked by it.
If we're running M of M, because you're on a ship.
yeah if we're running emma mag then i can uh i can just
bubble anyone that gets pulled yeah and i have my shield and
diamond it shouldn't be too bad but i know if we probably
ban angela he'll probably play rogue yeah but rogue is
easier to kill for us like yeah we should ban something like
you just need to tell us if the rogue is diving you and then
do you want and then and then b hops can turn around i'll
anchor perfect i'll be the anchor That'll work.
Where are you going against next?
We're going against Rhyme's team.
We have bans for that one too.
Yeah, I can give you the band line.
I can take it.
You can, for the second one, you'll have to figure that
third band, you have to figure that out yourself.
Okay.
Because I don't think I have enough information.
okay um i know they already played on the broadcast yeah but
it's not very uh they did have oh they had a scarlet witch
okay i think we could deal with that yeah
actually how's the tie i'm gonna look at tiebreaker there
might be a tiebreaker
they banned angela elsa loki um This is what I have for
them.
Did you put it in there?
Okay, let's see.
Um...
Okay.
If we're gonna play like...
Yeah.
We also probably need to potentially ban...
Uh, I don't know.
They played this one too?
Well, it's felt right.
Yeah.
Um, their DPS only plays that character like there are dps
had coaching from for that character i don't know if we ban
the this one because uh after the first point they swapped
off of it and i think we can play against that character
like you want it's up to you though because the alt for that
character is really not that good you can just i mean that's
fine but you just what do you want to ban for second or
third
the what the first one that kick you put or also rhyme plays
this character and we were having trouble against that
earlier yeah we can she's gonna be off-angling a lot and we
really did not like playing as that character i know that
they also they have a scarlet witch player as well so it
would be scarlet witch versus scarlet witch who who will
prevail who has the most chaos energy oh they started they
won't ban it yeah
oh i need to look at how tiebreaker because if there might
be a tiebreaker around maybe actually i'm not sure wait no
actually there's no no way there's no way if because uh
they'll have to fight unless if peach's team wins against
teams then we're going to might be tie breaking one of them
tie breaking yeah i don't know if because it'll be like two
two wins like two wins one loss oh but i don't know what the
rule set what the rule set is for it hopefully it's not
something like whoever won their match faster that's that's
dumb that would be kind of lame i like that's something I'm
going to check it.
Yeah, I'm going to say check it.
For final match.
I think they just assumed there's no ties.
Because it's all about the second match, like the finals.
I'll double checking.
Oh, tie breakers.
Hide ahead is priority in terms of any two-way tie.
What's head to head?
Oh, the score of each individual game will come into place
to place one team higher.
Score.
I guess that means like they're going to count like the one
or one to O, three to O type things.
Okay.
Interesting.
Wouldn't that like disproportionately benefit people who go
overdone?
What about dominant?
Yeah.
That's weird.
So potentially there could be a tiebreaker.
They left open the Black Cat.
Are they playing Black Cat right now?
Yep, they are.
I don't think they realize...
I think only the higher rank players realize how shitty
Black Cat is right now.
Because the lower Evo players...
They're on the Siyu.
Siyu's just twerking.
But yeah, lower Evo players don't know yet.
Because they don't know how to play Black Cat yet.
Yeah.
it's feast or famine you're either great or you can't you
can't outplay it there's no counterplay it's dumb as hell
the only counterplay is like counter dive and kill their
backline before they kill yours oh they're running strange
hulk i think should we do emma for that against the hollow
yeah yeah counters both of their tanks yeah but we probably
need a mag meter for the punish yeah i can go mag then you
can go either do you feel more comfortable on emma or do you
want on emma but i think you can counter anti-dive better
than me yeah yeah it's just the only thing with magneto is
you're more you have to look for like poking certain people
out but it's both fine if they're on both melee tanks it
should be free yeah i think they might use their punish roll
only with rocket if they're good enough i don't think so you
won't be able to like counter it as easy i guess we'll have
to see how they're both their supports are gold so unless
unless they call it out obviously yeah like exactly what i
was talking about earlier whenever they use deadpool just
now they didn't even push up with it that's why i don't
really want to ban it because they didn't get anything with
it yeah you could just kite it they are winning the fight
though they are winning the push i think they're just
getting out damaged but i guess it might it could
potentially be worth banning just because they get it so
fast I want to see the black cat.
There's no black cat.
They're running mag, ammo, white fox, Luna, and another team
is rocket dead boy.
No, black cat is like insanely good.
There's no counter.
Like you can't outplay a black cat one trick because there's
no cooldown in her abilities is basically how much money you
have.
That's her cooldown, which she can get by just hitting
people.
Um, so, like, Black Cat is just, like, uh, it's just so
broken right now.
In the higher Elo, Black Cat is, uh, an Insta band.
It's the first band, because of how bad it is.
You can, we'll see all the pro players learning Black Cat
right now.
Uh, because, like, she is currently the strongest character,
but also the strongest character in Marvel Rivals.
Like, there's no outplayability.
Even if you go triple support.
There's no outplay ability to Black Cat.
Oh, there he goes.
Black Cat kill three.
Yeah, they're about to have Punisher and Rockets with them.
I'm assuming they'll combo it.
I have to, most likely.
You have a Wando, a Wando, too, because they haven't used it
in a while.
The only worry with Hulk, well, I'll be there peeling it,
but he's going to try to go into our backline because he's
going to...
already attacking the white fox a little bit yeah but not it
won't be as annoying as the angela
yeah oh damn
oh they're not portal oh they can't portal
it's a domination for our next one yeah yes oh i got this so
we're playing whoever wins no we play we play rhymes team no
every we play every team once so we play rhymes steam next
yeah
honestly when they were on loki we could have just ran moon
night too true yeah yeah i think i should also swap yeah i
think we could have swapped maybe like phoenix like got
phoenix and uh oh we if they're running oh wait not they're
running rocket let's just run phoenix true they do have a
phoenix player yeah just run phoenix if they only use their
ult together which this time they didn't they could counter
it with like ulting at the same time they could just shoot
it but it looks like they're not stacking it every time we
could also do magneto phoenix combo so that they can't break
it I don't think they're going to shoot it honestly in my
opinion yeah probably not especially if you just slam it
into a wall all the wave will kill yeah i don't think you're
gonna shoot it
i don't think they know they're they ban out rhyme i don't
think they know they were getting c9 i don't think they i
was watching the cart slowly walk away uh totally yeah
i think we're gonna ban okay well this team doesn't play oh
yeah this team doesn't play black cat like uh rhymes team
they have their hit scan hit scan and scarlet witch that's
their uh dps rhymes
team might be it might be hard are you sure you don't want
to point band support pool he's doing a lot for his team we
can we can yeah especially like the biggest worry is on the
first attack push when they're on attack they might just
like overwhelm you because you won't have yours yet yeah i
think we should ban support pool yeah i'm down i think he's
better at it than i thought he would be when we do this he's
got his practice uh no every team is trying it's i like how
the forum was like this is a fun and chill event it's not
meant to be competitive that was a lie you have money Yeah,
that was a lot.
I was like, that's a lot.
We want the third band to be though.
Um, let's see.
So...
You put a support pull on there, right?
Yes.
Okay.
Yes, yes, yes.
So...
I gotta figure out the third one.
I mean, it could be the sigh.
Wait, oh, the enemy team banned the Invis to force him to
stay support pool?
Interesting.
I don't think he doesn't play Invis.
No, he has- I think that's what he swapped to on the first
match.
Yeah, he did.
They didn't lose that first match.
Yeah, but then like, he doesn't, he only plays support pool.
He doesn't have hours, he doesn't have hours on the other
supports.
Oh.
Or like, not to the point, because like, if you're getting,
trying to learn support, like invas in one day it's a lot
like it's just gonna be hillbotting it's not like actually
like the mechanic wise for like the push and pulls and stuff
yeah oh i
mean there are strangers have have a lot of big olds too so
we have to save uh be aware of where the strange is yeah or
save the bubbles i can try and save very obvious when the
strange i'm usually able to comment yeah i'll try and save
shield or bubble or shield yep if
they play hulk it should be so good for us because that
character takes a lot of skill to play to be really good
otherwise you just die a lot yeah i mean you're appealing
i'll i'll anchor like just you just handle the hulk for me
if i'm on the most of the time if you get dope by hulk just
comment and you two need a stick to Don't just be always be
next to each other.
Don't be off angling or anything If you're getting dope
like, just heal each other look at each other and just heal
each other Cuz the support shouldn't be like by itself
getting picked
Just watching the game right now.
It's definitely a lot harder because like I don't I'm not in
the backline So I don't have oversee of everything.
So I don't know what's going on in the backline I'm just
trying to survive in the front, so it's harder because
there's support like I said it's if we have died dive if we
have any dive dps or dive in general it would be so easy
diving the back line it would be because like like i said
like the the casual players wouldn't know what to do with
that which was basically what happened you just didn't know
what to do and like that's like just the win con i just god
we had any dive characters it would be so fun if i hadn't i
i wanted to try and learn that dive tank so then it's just
me and bee hops diving together but like um literally he was
like you're not learning venom in one day and i was like
what about captain america and he's like captain america is
even harder you're not learning this in one day so i was
like i could only do a cram session of all the tanks that
And he was right.
I literally tried to pull up Venom.
And I was just like, how do I do this?
I was just like, I'm climbing.
Oh, I'm falling down.
Where am I supposed to climb?
I was just trying to climb the wall.
And I was like, I can't go anywhere.
Where do I go?
I think Rhyme's team is going to win this one.
So that means we have to beat them in the next one.
Yeah, if we have to beat them, then we get finals.
If we don't, Rhyme's team goes to finals.
So we're guaranteed third, question mark.
Actually, wait, actually, wait.
We probably need to win.
I mean, we're going to try to win anyway.
Yeah, yeah, we're guaranteed third.
We lose, because then, unless Peach beats Shoto's team, I
think Shoto's team is the strongest team out of all of them.
Um, it's just because of the Angela, because like, uh, the
casual players have hard time dealing with Angela because
she's such a high skilled, uh, such a high skilled character
that you don't really see in the lower elos.
Because like Angela is very easy at counterplay, it's just.
only if everyone's check yeah actually
I think on no if we're banning Angela I would be like if we
do White Fox I think it would just save it would just help
in general but if we're banning Angela we don't have to play
we could still play White Fox but
we have if we make it to the finals we have three match we
have three games to three or two games to theorycraft
essentially three yeah it's best of three so I try and
control there's try to do White Fox and still ban Angela.
Yeah.
I feel like we've on average had a lot more success with the
Rocket Alts.
But if they have Phoenix, then we're going to have to swap.
But they never played Phoenix, so I mean, yeah, we could
just do just do Rocket then.
Rocket.
If they end up doing any dive character, just go to White
Fox.
If you're feel like you're getting picked a lot oh they have
one minute to push this through
oh yeah oh yeah i was gonna say the strange they're gonna do
the strange scarlet combo all the time and i don't think i
have a bubble i don't have enough bubbles for this yeah
we're gonna have to counter the strange by like invis push
yeah yeah you have to save your push for a strange out when
we call for it because I think they're just gonna do a
strange they've done it like the last three fights or the
last three fights they've had that combo wait what just
happened oh they didn't touch rhyme one yeah rhyme one oh
they didn't portal yeah so now we're going to see third yeah
unless Peach does an upset against Shoto's team and then
it's a tie but then it could be a tie-breaker.
Are we next or are we last?
We're next.
Actually, let me double check.
No, we're last.
Oh, we're last.
I need like a double break here.
Next, it's Peach and Shoto.
I'm going to play it.
Rank.
Someone else can watch Peach and Shoto.
Someone can watch Shoto's game.
I'm going to play Rank.
Good luck, good luck, good luck.
Actually, yeah, I have to play Rank on my other account.
Oh, I can't!
I can't swap accounts!
Fuck!
Alright, I guess I'll play quickly.
I can't because everything's linked to my Steam account, so
I can't swap accounts.
Yeah, I can't swap only because...
You have to play quick play as Tink.
I don't want to play quick play as Tink.
wait guys i just added a new chat in ours is this what are
we going up um
no wait they yeah they copied and pasted a wrong thing oh
yeah they copied and pasted something different that's not
us yeah that's not a that was from earlier
Wait, I'm going to be playing Mag, right?
Alright, I'm going to practice for Mag more.
Yeah.
It is domination, so it's a lot faster, too.
So, yeah, there's less time to adapt.
It's going to be super important.
Oh, they deleted it.
They deleted it.
Yeah.
Can I plan my altar now?
What the fuck?
Or is it really okay?
Alright, nice.
Oh my god.
You can tell I have to think a lot when I put a tank, too.
Get out of here!
Oh my god!
Get out!
Alright, there we go.
I hate having this thing so much when I'm playing this
character.
I'm playing this goddamn rug!
You love tank, you love it.
You take care of it.
Oh my god.
I didn't realize I was not muted.
Whoops!
Man, if only I had my own.
Sorry, I have to leave.
Oh, she doesn't live.
I was like, I believe she'll live.
She didn't live yet.
Oh my god, oopsie, that's not great.
Me fucking rant about how much I hate this role.
Oops!
This real fucky sucks.
No one TPs?
All right.
How does it work if we make it to the finals against Shoto's
team, but they never lose and we lost a match?
Did they have any advantage?
No advantage.
All right.
Where are they?
Oh, fuck that was him fucking you.
Nope.
There we go.
Oh, portal time.
Portal time.
All right.
Do not portal.
Oh, no portal, I guess.
He fucked up portal.
All right.
I panicked.
It's all right.
Oh, shit.
Wait, I can portal.
I'm not taking this as seriously as I should be.
I just absolutely hate tank so much.
To be fair, I saw the shark and I was like, fuck that guy.
We see nine?
We all really wanted to kill that cloak.
the same.
Fuck that one guy in particular.
We really wanted to kill him.
That's crazy.
There we go.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Oh.
No, it wasn't even the shark.
It was like loot.
It was the fucking... It was the fucking cloak.
I really wanted to get up oh I hope there is a supporter oh
hello whoop hello there we go there we All right, there you
go.
All right,
goodbye.
Wait, where did my support go?
Oh, they all died.
Wait, we have someone with zero, zero, zero?
How?
What are you doing?
Did you just got here?
All right.
You must have just got here something.
Bro, stop.
Stop.
Actually, stop.
Alright.
That's fine.
I'm a tank.
It's no longer fine.
That's fine.
I'm practicing with him.
There we go.
He's dead.
Is that alright?
Okay, that's on him.
He definitely has a lot though.
What the fuck?
Get out of here.
Unlucky.
Get out of here!
Get your ass out of here!
I don't care about charging that up.
If I could kill you!
There we go, get out of here!
There we go.
Usually you're supposed to charge that, but I really don't
care.
You're supposed to do like this, the combo.
Oh, she's opening it.
Oh, there she is!
Oh.
Oh!
Fucking getting out of here.
Oh.
There you go.
Where are they?
All right, they don't have portal.
Let's go.
All right, I have a...
Hello.
Strike what?
Hello, Sharkboy.
Get over here.
Oh, goodbye, Sharkboy.
Get out.
Where's the hook?
Fuck this roll.
Get over here.
Nobody's having fun with this roll right now.
Nobody's gonna have fun.
Oh my god, wait, we might have to...
You're fucking crazy, Luna.
God, you're fucking crazy for that.
It's fine.
More practice.
I'm having so much fun on this roll.
Turkey's not having fun.
No one will.
Wee-hop.
It wasn't seen now.
we all fucking died.
Guys, it's not a scene, not if we're all dead.
Okay.
Alright, let's...
Do we have...
Alright, there we go.
I'll just say it.
Alright.
I mean, I'm fine staying here.
Oh, whoop.
hello there we go
there we go fuck you in particular you know what yo fuck me
I guess oh wait you're so low I forgot that was a cloak I
always get confused I forgot that was a cloak it's alright
fuck me I guess
I didn't even see this strange.
I was like, nothing will save you.
Oh, cloak, cloak fade.
I got a little impatient.
I'll wait a little bit.
I think our Spider-Man.
Oh, unless our Spider-Man.
Yeah, our Spider-Man's dead.
Oh, yeah.
They're going to have strange out, though.
Get ready for shark up, guys!
Oh.
Oh, this is where I get eaten.
Goodbye, everybody.
Oh, goodbye.
I ran into that.
Oh, nice.
Oh, shit.
Go, Captain America!
Go!
Oh, yeah, we have no support ult for that.
It does suck.
We do.
We don't have a support ult for that.
Thank God this is quick play.
Thank God.
Tank is so fun, guys.
I love this role.
This role makes me so happy.
I would have played Rink, but I can't play Rink.
That's the worst part.
I live in happy land.
Aren't you having the time?
Yeah.
I'm having so much fun.
Guys, I have no time to learn Rogan DP in 30 minutes.
I don't think I can learn Rogan Deadpool in 30 minutes chat.
I just gotta keep up the mechanics of the current characters
I have in my roster.
All right, they're playing their next match.
All right, this one next.
That's guys, I'm not trying to grieve here.
But...
Bop, bop, bop, bop, bop, bop, bop, bop, bop.
Alright, let's go.
No, I will never learn tank.
I've hated tank since any hero shooter.
I've never enjoyed that role.
I only did this as a favorite.
I'll let you guys know I have I have never enjoyed this
rock.
What?
Wait, how did I lose all my HP?
Oh, we have one healer.
We have one support.
I'm not good at tank.
It's just my game senses carrying me right now.
I mean, that makes sense.
I was like, what?
How do I not- how do I not have PS?
There's no way.
I don't even know if there's an animation cancel for
Magneto.
Who?
I'm just gonna...
All right, hey, I'm so fucking dead.
And he's just walking forward, I guess.
Oh my god, is that second support?
That's crazy.
I'm just gonna reload right this.
All right.
Here I'll go.
Get out of here!
Oh, he's so lucky.
Oh, I guess I'll get bubbled.
I should just die.
Fuck it.
Just take my stuff.
Wait, they used...
How many ults did they use?
They did not need to use all of that.
Oh, we have three supports now.
Oh, thank God.
What a luxury.
Not gonna have that, though, in the actual tournament.
Man, if only...
I don't know, just do that.
Jesus.
I mean, we're winning this, so...
Alright.
Oh!
Actually, I should have just done this, actually.
Woo!
There was nothing I could do.
Oh, she was over there.
Wait, where did she come from?
Okay, I should start locking in.
I'm not... I'm just being lazy right now.
I'm actually not...
My hate is making me lazy.
I'm...
I'm actually being really lazy.
I'm not even practicing anymore.
Gotcha.
You're fine.
Oh, she was one.
Man, it would be cool if I had a wealth for that.
It would have been really cool.
Oh, that's shit.
That's nice.
Oh, bye.
Can't bubble you, Jeff.
Wow, Jeff.
Only I could have bubbled you.
If only.
There we go.
If only I could have bubbled you.
Where is he?
Oh, he got yammed with it.
Alright, I'll actually have to...
I should have to try.
Alright, I'm gonna try now.
Starting now.
I'll start trying now.
Oh my god, the stupid fucking range.
Alright, starting now, I'm gonna start trying.
See, look at that.
I hit a shot.
I
think it'll be okay.
No.
Oh, he lost.
See, this is what I'm saying.
Oh, I see him.
I see him.
Where's my ultron?
There it is.
Alright.
Oh.
Bye.
I can't see.
Wee!
I love tanking!
It's so fun!
Yay!
I love tanking!
What's going on?
Oh.
Where is she?
Okay, she got bubbles!
She got bubbled, guys!
Wait!
This time she got bubbled!
It's not on me, that was a bubble.
I did.
There was a bubble that blocked it off.
You don't understand.
Someone jump over.
Oh, nobody?
Alright, goodbye.
Goodbye.
Charles dreamed of a safe haven for all mutants.
At last, I have made it a reality.
It's okay, I'll lock in starting now.
She got bubbled, guys.
There we go.
Oh, that's unlucky.
What the fuck?
Okay, well, at least I got him.
There we go.
Oh, what the fuck?
Their match is over.
Already?
Oh, shit.
That was quick.
Who won?
I think we got Angelo play again.
Shoto won.
Yeah.
I mean, domination is good for Angelo.
So that I'm not surprised.
So yeah, we're guaranteed third.
We're guaranteed third right now.
double here we win one more guaranteed second right yeah
where did my other support go oh oh alright there she oh
yeah let's Support ults.
I'm just like, where did my other...
Oh, where did my other support ults go?
Gonna sit.
There we go, guys.
There we go.
See, guys, I locked in.
Something will hit here.
Oh, oh my god, I almost hit him too.
Oh, he's got him.
Fine.
All right.
Oh, goodbye.
Oh, oh my god, why would you put me in here?
Okay.
He just spit me back into hell.
I mean, that's fine.
Yeah, I was just like, that's not ideal.
But that's alright.
Oh, nope.
He's gonna get me.
Oh, this is where it ends.
He got me.
Oh, hell is over.
Can't wait to play tank again.
again.
All right.
It's time.
You're close to the lobby?
All right.
Someone else invited me this time.
I've done my job.
Not this thing, Captain.
Surely.
I'm going to pause their stream.
What's the bad line?
The one or the two?
It's the one.
Okay.
All right.
when i get in the lobby is this domination so that also
matters a lot as well okay i'm in there one second i'm the
only one in here yeah now invite us in oh i got aurora
anomaly that one that one i think that's everybody yep okay
she would definitely do the the red-headed lady and then the
the Deadpool yeah what do we want to do for the third one do
we know so well it is domination so it's really what you
feel against right thank you yes she's been playing a lot of
Punisher I don't know if that's like something we want to
ban she plays Phoenix as well if we want to make if we want
to run Rocket
Remind me, they run Rocket, too.
They were running Rocket Support Pool.
So if we run Phoenix, we can just destroy their Phoenix
Island.
And we can run White Fox.
White Fox.
Yeah, I can do that.
Invis.
Or White Fox Luna or whatever.
Or Cloak.
White Fox Cloak, honestly.
No.
Yeah.
I like it.
Honestly, it's my like my best.
You gotta come over here.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so...
And then...
so what is your third support pool um what tanks have they
been playing it was hulk strange we want to leave the
strange open because you're probably going to play it huh i
mean i could i thought we're doing mag emma if you're doing
hulk okay we could ban strange then if we want as a third
one because the ults were large yeah the ults were pretty
good yeah i saw they were yeah we do that we just have to be
able as long as we're capable of dealing with uh if she goes
siloed if rime goes Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
I mean, if you want to, we can ban silo then instead it's
either stranger siloed for sure It's just like an awareness
check is mainly what it is and I just don't know if they
played Siloed at all in this tournament I don't know if they
played it here, but I know she can play it.
I just see where I'm playing it in the tournament They
played Elsa.
They played Elsa Phoenix oh okay then we just ban siloed
then okay all right ban siloed then um what was the other
one uh uh then what else support pool siloed yeah that's
fine or if we're not scared of the elsa we could go support
pool siloed strange but i feel like the we can play against
the elsa better than the siloed Yeah.
Well, no, her she...
No, but she got coached on Elsa by, like, Rye and them.
Yeah.
Okay.
She basically spent, like, crab session just coaching Elsa.
So I'd rather she just not on Elsa.
Yeah, yeah.
We'll get rid of that one.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
When he was first, bad Elsa.
Stepping out of the shadows.
i'm very chill i just know i'm not last so i don't really
for me it's like whatever happens if we lose i get to peace
out if we oh maybe i can try and get eternity if we lose i
try to get eternity in ring if we win i guess we're going
another game i i can play support again if we lose okay
that's my second
we want psylock right see this is why we don't stream our
scrims guys we could have at least one tank full game i
think rye would have known because she knows i play that
already but maybe the other teams wouldn't have had it yeah
we want psylock 100 yeah they ban gamut they ban gamut just
so psylocked in uh you don't want to ban phoenix i thought
we're playing phoenix because they're yeah because they have
rocket all uh all right no audience i mean we have to play
finish anyway you want white fox right if they run hawk yeah
um
yeah you're gonna have to call for bubbles or uh i can't if
you're when you're all ulting i mean we could call for you
honestly when you're about to um all
right i hate this first point is very open yeah i hate this
map 30 seconds before you attack get ready we could either
fight for height or we could immediately go like bunker on
the bottom and fight for point i think that's I think that
might be too big brain stuff where our players the bunker up
the bunker up might be too much It's only works if we
actually try it out before Yeah, that's valid.
Yeah, it's just like the you actually have to like Just play
it by ear.
I'll see you where they go see what they have It's a very
hit scan a really good long range point
Yeah are they strange portaling on top of us you might be
yes oh yeah they are i couldn't get through you guys break
the wall on this card yeah yeah break it i'm breaking it i'm
breaking it i'm here no they haven't gone through yeah
they're on me oh they're coming on here now yeah i got i'm
fine i'm fine i'm fine i'm fine yeah i don't have resources
though now i'm backing up i need to reload i got their cloak
guys we can push i'm on strange i'm on strange Oh, strange
one, strange one.
I have bubble.
That's fine.
We could still win this.
Yeah, I need heals though.
Oh.
Yeah.
I'm backing.
I, yeah.
We have to back up fully.
We could, actually, I might have to go strange just for the
team up for Aurora.
You can if you want.
They don't have, uh, well, the only counters for the cloak
hold, but you can play that.
Actually, no, it's fine.
I'll stay.
I'll stay, I'll stay, I'll stay.
i'm gonna make sure we break these aunts it's just damage
vomit
magnet bubble i should have my ult first compared to the
other what i'm fine i'm killing you i'm killing you for it
okay nice nice nice nice nice nice i got you i bubbled you
yeah string does no she does no bubble or shield string
stars hey no no no we don't need it we don't need it not yet
not yet Yeah, we got it.
Nice, nice, nice.
We got it.
We have the point.
Just play out of it.
Play out of it.
Use cloak.
Use it.
Yeah.
Let's get it.
No more else.
No more.
I got.
I got invis.
Sagger him.
He's low.
He's one.
He's a nice stagger.
Oh.
like right here yeah i can bubble it we can they're gonna
they're gonna want a strange alt here too so we gotta be
careful we have to be ready to back up yeah they're gonna go
past i might not hit it so there is a chance i will not hit
the bubble behind you guys whenever they walk up if we break
strange shield i can maybe do an early roll
nope but this is fine oh she went under the stairs it's not
on it's not on point just wait for it rocket rocket rocket
rocket rocket rocket oh they've got me down already you said
rocket all i'm not dead it's okay that's unlike cheap they
went under the street yeah we have one support so we can
play oh that's fine
That's fine.
They're gonna support soon.
They used Magneto Strange.
Magneto Strange, Cloak, Charlotte.
And they have Moon Knight ult.
Yeah, yeah.
We could.
When we rock out, they're gonna Moon Knight the Rocket ult
instantly, so we gotta be careful.
We could do Rocket Wanda during the Envis.
Yeah, yeah.
We have to call for it, though.
We don't ult this end then.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, we're gonna pick up a lot of damage.
Okay, I could ult him if you guys want to.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do it.
I'll think it's in.
No, it's nice.
That's good.
I'm going to go for the cloak.
Magna bubble.
Mag one, mag one.
No, it's like solo.
Yeah, I'm going for it.
Mag one.
He rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket,
rocket, rocket, rocket.
It's there.
Use Wanda, use Wanda.
Use the Wanda.
Where is...
Oh, I couldn't.
I couldn't see.
I see her.
Oh, we gotta be grouped.
I can, I'll stream.
Yeah, I'll tell.
Oh, okay.
We got shield.
I'm opening a portal.
My power cannot be quelled.
We're quelling.
Shoot the Invis.
I got Invis one.
I couldn't get her.
I don't know where you went.
I see her.
I'm in rest.
Blue Knights on the other side by himself.
They're down Invis.
Nice Invis down.
Yeah, yeah.
Sound point.
I run quick.
Get down both supports.
Just stay with those.
I have no support.
Yeah.
The Moon Knight.
Oh, I got hit.
It's okay.
I'm yummy.
I'm fine.
I'm down too.
Every time.
We're in overtime.
It's okay.
We're gonna team play.
Yeah.
Big oof.
I think, uh...
Moon Knight's really strong here.
Someone has to target, like, pin...
point the moon night there for us.
Yeah.
I can swap.
Yeah, I can look at him.
Make her cry!
No, we have one more.
Yeah, yeah, it's fine.
It's fine.
I'm still winnable.
Because we're gonna win this one!
Because we're gonna win this one, so we have to win.
Do you want to start with Strange Shult, or?
Yeah, we can.
I'm out too.
We can combo and then I can swap.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They still have Portal, so they might try to portal on top
of our heads again.
Yeah, but if we they portal, you can.
We're going to win this one, so it's going to be timed.
We're gonna do it.
We got it.
So we're in a strange alt and then...
Yeah.
That's my bad.
I pressed shift instead of F.
I could have like been okay with a strange alt.
Do you want to do you want to play mag?
And then I'll do that strange after?
Yeah, we can.
And we have time.
Oh, they're doing it.
Alright, just stick together.
Just stick together.
I can do it about like right here.
Like in the hallway.
We're all sticking together.
It should be fine.
They're just going to try and sit.
Yep, there it is.
There you go.
See?
We can just walk past it, maybe.
No, I don't think we can.
Get rid of it.
That's fine.
They're going to...
I got the cloak.
We can kill her.
Oh, we don't have damage.
We don't.
Oh, we didn't walk past the portal.
We couldn't.
Our team couldn't walk past it.
I'm going to swap.
You want me to keep Maggle or?
It's up to you.
I'm going to try Groot.
Alright.
Just going to go back Emma.
You see the pressure of the Moon Knight.
Oh yeah.
Maybe like Parma shooting the Moon Knight.
Funny here's here.
Thank you.
Come on.
Get the Mag grab.
He does.
Yeah sure.
You wasted all?
I got a cloak.
I got cloak.
No more else.
No more no.
Moonite.
There you go.
We got a push up here.
So get rid of this.
We can.
Get rid of the top.
They're gonna have cloak.
We're getting rid of the back end.
We're getting rid of this.
Did they use a support ult or not?
No, no, no, no.
They're gonna have Cloak.
They're gonna have... I already used my mag up.
Okay.
They're gonna break our rocket.
We might have...
I broke you.
I broke it!
They're gonna use Cloak or Invis here.
There it is.
I've got all...
Use it, use it, use it, use it!
Got it.
Nice.
Nice, nice!
I've bubbled it, I've bubbled her.
I'm gonna kill the moon night kill the moon night kill the
moon night They're down they only have two down too We're
stabilized we're stabilized We win that we win that's fine
Don't push up too far and die though You're down supports
I'm careful I'm gonna swap I'm gonna swap That's fine Yo!
Did you guys see that alt?
Yes He's massive We did You're in the way I'm gonna I'm
pushing up here a bit That's fine I'm not pushing too far
I'm just They use both support ults I'm pretty sure Yeah
they're looking for it Yeah they're looking for it break the
arc break the yonks yeah i'm trying to try to get my ult and
use that soon all right i'm watching for a strange empty
city breaking the arc again nice he's looking for auger i
cancelled it i cancelled it okay i don't have shield yeah
yeah i have um do you want your all first of me They're not
going to have a support ult.
I can use my ult when we walk in.
We can also use cloak.
Yeah.
Okay.
Use your ult and cloak then.
And then I'll use mine for emergency.
Yeah.
We don't have raccoon.
Careful.
I'm coming.
I'm right behind you.
All right.
We're here.
We're all here.
Yeah.
I had the bubble.
Do you want me to do it now?
Yeah.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
They can't use mag.
Yeah.
Can we kill the mag?
Flying one.
Strange behind up top?
I'm grabbing Strange.
I'm controlling the back line right now.
Don't kill him too quick.
Wait, I need help!
I need help!
I'm on you.
There's a lot of damage, there's a lot of damage.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm trying to- Strange is...
Strange is really trying.
I got the cloak right now.
I'm on my got Muna!
What's up?
I'm down!
Strange one, Strange one!
I got him We have to kill we have to kill we have to kill
Wanda Wanda Wonder Oh my god.
Don't have my gosh Just get back because you like Bag one
they have portal they have portal they do they do they do we
don't have heals Do you want me to go ANOVA, you want me to
go strange So we don't have to worry about that at that
point.
Winnable, winnable.
Do you want me to go strange or do you want me to stay mag?
Do you think you're getting value on mag?
I'm getting kills with my other, but...
Mag has better, like, the bubble is really nice for our
cloaks.
It might be better.
Yeah, I can do that.
As long as we live long enough, it's the only problem is the
moon night.
That's the only problem.
I think you have to deal with the angst for us.
breaking them when I can.
This time it's going to be a little harder because you can
go left and right.
I'll do my best to... I'll be anchored.
I'll be anchored.
Yeah.
If you see her on an off angle, you have more range than me.
So if you have time, try to poke her, but I'm trying to do
my best.
Break odds.
They're going to have support ults.
They do.
We can have both.
Yeah, we can try to get Storm early and use it to force one.
But we don't have one to match, so we're going to have to
force it.
We have to let Raccoon or Raccoon heal.
I'm at 87 right now.
Just let her heal.
I'll be behind.
Yeah, just let her heal and you just focus on blinds and
stuff.
Bounce.
Careful bounce.
Break the thing in the middle.
I'm breaking it.
Breaking it.
Give us some walls.
Got rocket alt.
That's good.
Yeah, pop it, pop it, pop it.
Pop it.
Oh.
Disappear.
That's fine.
Oh, nice.
We killed it.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
No, no, no, no, no.
I'm pushing up.
That's huge.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
Let our cloak heal.
Okay.
So, yeah, I'm just going to try and lay our cloak heal.
So you don't have to heal.
They have a Starlord now instead of...
He's up top.
He's going to be focusing our storm heavily.
He's probably going to come to that immortal.
Careful, we gotta go back a little bit.
Be careful.
Just back up a little bit.
Back up, back up, back up.
I have no bubble now.
I have no bubble.
Yeah.
Careful with the strings.
They're behind us.
I'll heal you, heal you, heal you.
I'm trying.
We have kills.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, nice, nice, nice,
nice.
They're on me.
They're on me in the back.
I have bubble.
You need it.
Oh, I'm coming.
Yeah, I'm trying.
I'm trying.
There's someone in the back.
bubble oh you oh my god you have to be closer I'm shooting
I'm shooting you back up back up Scarlet back up all right I
have all here for the did he cloak that or okay i'm gonna
i'll alter starlord i'll alter starlord i'll alter starlord
okay perfect perfect they're gonna have free cloak we don't
have anything for it or unless you kill it but you'd need
for starlord we can try to kite the cloak or did they
already use it no they already use it they already use it oh
okay they're on a moto okay on a moto yeah they're gonna be
looking for strange yeah strange they're looking for it
they're looking for it we can kill him right here Mag, mag,
mag, mag, mag.
Kaurwanda, Kaurwanda.
I got both supports.
Massive.
Holy shit.
You're actually here.
Wanda, Wanda, Wanda, focus on Wanda.
Nice.
They're poorly put on.
I have, I have!
They got me.
They got me down.
I'm almost at all guys.
No supports.
Mega, mega, mega.
I got mag.
Okay, I got strange.
I got mag, mag, mag.
I got mag.
I have ult for the last fight.
This is last fight.
I'm on the one.
Nice.
Oh, good job.
Good job.
I still have my ult too.
I'm just so good.
We'll save your ult for next match.
Oh my god.
Yeah, let me see it.
I'll carry over.
All right.
That was such a good comeback.
We're in the finals.
Top second.
We're in the finals now.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
Fucking hate tank.
I don't know how you do it, B-Habs.
I don't know why you would do this every fucking day.
This role fucking...
You didn't get the dopamine from your magle now?
This role fucking sucks.
I don't care.
This role sucks.
I don't know how you do this every fucking day.
You get bullied until you get your old.
Then you're a character.
That's the gameplay.
Oh, my God.
This role is terrible.
I hate this role.
I'm going to drag you in there.
It's B-Hops, right?
Not Bob's.
I think he's been talking.
B-Hops, yeah.
Both are fine.
It's okay.
All right.
I got it.
I told you.
You guys were like, wow, Doki, you're missing all your mags.
I was just fucking chilling.
I fucking told you.
Yeah, like, no, no, this is gonna be rough with Tokyo doing
marigolds.
That's fucking right.
I hit the ones that fucking count.
I still hate this character.
I still hate this role.
Oh No, this character this role sucks Main stream incoming
Yeah, no DPS is more fun DPS is more fun because people die
faster It's much more fun to play Yeah And I was whiffing my
shots too.
I was whiffing my like left clicks there but i hit i still i
did hit the ones that matter yeah i i kept my bubbles more
often too i was just like bubble bubble bubble i got my like
the bubble better yeah yeah at cps i feel more progress
going in i do not feel like anything is happening when i
play tank
Oh How was the interview it was good.
I was just glazing you guys basically.
No, that's all you W glaze W team W team W team Yeah
Sorry, I had a work message.
I'm still working even when I'm playing in this tournament
uh i you know what we got second if we get second place we
get second place i'm proud of us we have a room yet or not
um i think it's like i think it's like break time you know
it's like intermission break time for the finals these five
minutes yeah yeah yeah uh do what y'all need to do
all right guys time to disassociate i time to disassociate
guys i'm ready
Yippin' yeah you finally disassociating BRB I made some
fucking plays there literally killed the supports for us so
that we could make it to the end
god i made some generational plays for us there i'm just
glad it's over okay i just all right did you see that bubble
i was like oh my god did you see my oh it was like she
doesn't know in there already she doesn't know the bubble i
gave her to get her those plays the fucking bubble i chucked
out at the last second.
Looks like it was the exact same one.
Oh, that was a different password.
No.
The pain I went through.
The guardian angel.
Oh, my God.
Can you just copy it?
Does that work?
Oh, see, a tank is a thankless job.
Oh, it's the number two.
Yeah.
it truly is a thankless job start inviting anybody who's not
in there i'll help all right invite me uh all right so
what's the bad line one second do we want to ban the flying
creature yes yes yes i think i think we can deal with a i
think we could deal with a rogue more than a angela only
because yeah but as road it's you and i can handle the rogue
together when they were angela we can't help them yes um do
okay so the flying lady what's the other ones did you type
the wrong one wait i'll just type it because then it'll just
yeah they'll just start theory crafting you know he was
short on her mission anyways it's because froggy's on the
wrong one you're kidding um there you go now you can find
what's going on did you know that Aurora.
All right.
Let's see.
Oh, wait.
What?
Did I miss something?
You got a swap.
Let me check this out again.
Oh, yeah.
It was these two.
I can't see my cat tonight.
Okay.
Yeah.
If they play the third one, that's for sure.
I swear we had an idea.
Or do you want, oh yeah, you wanted to, you want, you think
you can handle that.
wanted to do this instead of the middle one yeah yeah okay
yeah i think that's probably good i will say if if that
character ends up winning for them i was right you have to
revoke your one above all status i will i'll be a one below
all i awash player made the better prediction one loss
available yeah i feel like we can handle it yeah we've got
this oh wait angela away from papa is it oh it's domination
it's random domination oh my gosh again i fucking i hate
domination it's so fast-paced yeah i don't i'm not a fan of
domination too so stressful it's an entirely different game
than the other ones for sure hopefully they don't get that
super soldier factory and oh we're no we're banning it and
it's good because you next afterward that's fine we'll just
wait until it's time back to disassociating guys i'm ready
they are for i think they're gonna play this um it's really
annoying for this character because they break it during it
yeah we can do that um well for the yeah yeah that works for
me oh yeah we just have to be careful how we use it because
uh they're all gonna essentially be invincible during the
ult and our ult is breakable so we have to protect it if
we're on magneto we can bubble it which helps what are their
dps that they play that they played last time against us um
else was something we all right captain you research it was
also moon night it was also moon night all right captain
that's your job we can kill that guy i mean we just beat a
moon night we just have to actually focus on them and break
the yonks that's not like unbeatable all right the
disassociation i'm not thinking too hard right All I do is I
help him.
I'm his soundboard.
I'm the captain soundboard where I'm his back and forth
while he's strategizing.
This is actually like the most chill I've been.
I'll have to be focused more on the road.
Also, I think it's because I'm on tank.
I can't go off angles as much until she's dead.
We just have to shoot her every time she goes there.
We can do that.
Last time they were like running Rogan.
probably when they go in yeah they don't play gambit right
um let me look we ban that against them um we did not oh no
but i don't think they banned it they only matters yeah okay
only matters i just do i just don't want like i had to make
sure they don't play rogue gambit because that's broken but
they don't so we're good
i am i am I'm tired now.
I can't wait.
Maybe I will Doom Q after whatever happens.
Toki, what do you mean, Doom Q?
The Doom is where I had to play Tank.
That's where the Doom comes from.
That's...
I need to cleanse myself with some support gameplay.
Oh, first match is domination.
It's going to be best of three.
I mean, yeah, we were talking about that earlier.
And you cleanse myself from this disgusting roll.
All offense to tank mains.
I told you, I'm not that OP.
People were like, oh my gosh.
Why is B-Hubs and Doki on the same team as the duo tank?
I'm not doing, fuck, I'm not as OP as people think I am.
Honestly, I am not as OP as people think I am.
I'm literally, like, around, like, the fact that I have only
an out, like, I had, like, basically no knowledge on tank
until now.
Like, I've been making a lot of money.
mistakes too.
I feel like you're really enjoying this tank, girl.
Hey, you're B-Hops.
Where are you?
We're going to drag you in with Shoto for a pre-match
interview.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Just give me a sec.
Okay, bye.
Like.
Have fun.
Can't wait to play support later nope okay whatever happens
i can't wait to play support after hey
that's where that's where things get oh yeah i should i
should add him on on this account N-R-G-M-L-Dara.
No, support is less.
Oh, yeah.
No, support for me right now, this is the least stress.
This is the least stress I've ever been in a tournament just
because I have no stakes involved in this.
I'm literally winning with...
I'm literally winning with a...
Cram session on tank.
Wait, actually.
Oh, we can't play this.
I've been playing tank and quick play.
So it doesn't matter.
Oh, yeah, the 29.
The 29.
Look at this.
Okay, wait.
The four minutes on Groot.
Four minutes of five minutes of one out.
There you go.
This is where I practice.
This is where I started practicing, guys.
This one was from the stream.
This is from early...
Amazing.
I can't believe the most played is this event.
Look, I'm literally winning with these stats right now.
I'm literally winning with these fucking stats.
Wait.
Look.
Look at that.
I have a negative win rate on all my tanks.
Yeah, 1.4 hours is from this state.
That's true.
The majority of these games have just been today.
You're not true.
A win zone.
a win that's actually true that's pretty look at here all
right season zero 10 minutes on on strange i think that's it
oh 10 minutes on strange uh oh my god most of this came from
season zero that's so sad okay season zero my less than one
minute on okay season one is when i was like i will never
touch tank again 10 minutes on on mag we did not win uh for
some fucking reason less than a minute on on thing when i
was learning the game trying to figure out all right three
minutes nothing oh this is where i didn't play all right no
tanks here
oh my god what happened that was intense that was intense
what happened dang he called you dumb he called us bad whoa
we gotta win we gotta defend our honor damn all right i'm
throwing
because he wants us to try hard i'm not giving him the
satisfaction throw so he gets mad for a different reason
All right.
And then, no tank.
Oh, my God, for the last...
Oh, my God.
This is where I was like, I'll never play.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, this was from Quick Play, I think.
Yeah, this was all from Quick Play.
Yes.
Yeah, I'm ready.
Okay, we got everything ready.
At a seat, at one point, there was a season where I
realized, where I was like, I will never touch tank again.
This was...
i think like after like i think in season four was when i
finally realized i would never touch take no one can make me
take touch tank
holy moly what hero do you think all right
i have mutant powers and a little demonic magic too
oh it's crocola okay so why did we just do those just do the
bad We do that Angela first.
Yeah, that way.
That we wrote.
Yaya yaya.
Yes, I'm playing take now as a favor for my friend.
I guess that's just a row against that character, I guess.
I was like out, out.
I literally was like, out.
I was like, I'm dropping it.
I was like, is that your five?
I was like, this is my final decision.
I'm dropping out.
Like, it's out.
They're gonna be all dangling a lot.
They're like, are you sure?
I was like, yes, this is my final.
final final decision nothing can change my mind and my
friend was like can you please oh can you play tank for this
team i'll never get to play it and then we're doing black
cat third no friend makes someone play tank
y 'all that's a bad gambit nice that's good for us all right
what should we do for tank line do you want me on actually
whichever one you want we could either do the team up with
strange or the magneto yeah you can do mag for our yeah for
our like we'll do i'll do mag to help uh our cloak too yeah
yeah yeah in case they mirror it so we have the bubble yeah
truing and i can bubble rogue stuff too and the fox ult too
because they're going to blow that jonna i'll try my best i
think the bubble is just going to explode instantly though
for the white fox domination first totally i hate domination
this map has those portals on it too yeah thank god the
flying lady's gone she's annoying on here yeah i didn't move
yet just uh frog me like half angle all right used to
supports just got played together a lot yep uh hold my hand
yeah just don't don't split up don't split up from each
other if if something happened just call for i'll anchor so
b house will come back so just call for the blonde white
woman that's not at the front okay yes capture the mission
area got it go on us we will just move up closer to the
tanks a little bit yeah because are they doing anything with
portal yeah they're not they're not cap america oh yeah you
just stick together you should be fine if you stick together
cap is hard to make it work in general oh yeah yep
i'm fine emma emma on the right careful they're on me
they're on me in the back help help out help out support all
right oh you were i got a bubble yeah i got a shield okay
it's fine What a little too deep.
Back up it, back up it, back up a bit.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You guys back up.
Oh, they're not on Loki either.
Yeah, that's fine.
They're on Moonlight.
I was going to have to play way further back because of the
cap.
Was that Captain America acting like a dive?
Yeah, yeah.
Captain is dive.
Okay, I mean, it's fine.
I have bubble.
Be careful, be careful, careful, careful.
I think you're being a bit too aggressive on what I'm not
gonna ult us okay maybe one we could swap I should still
have all yeah we can if you want all right here I'm down I'm
down I'm coming just wait just wait just wait i want to send
me uh we can use bucky all here i'm not bucky sorry a cloak
all here to engage honestly i don't know if they have one
yet are they yeah i think they're close i i healed faster
okay that's fine we can all right all right nice i'm i'm i'm
i'm in it i'm I got it.
I'm on.
I've got my ult.
White fox ult.
Yeah, we should, I need us.
Any, any us.
White fox, white fox.
Here, yeah, white fox.
Nice.
Come back, come back, come back, come back, come back.
Shoot and cloak.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
We don't have any ults though.
We're going to try to get my ult before they cloak.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's fine.
It's fine.
They're staggered him.
They're staggered, they're staggered, they're staggered.
Really nice.
They're going to have cap as well.
We're gonna have to stay alive with nothing.
They'll have cloak.
They're gonna have cloak.
Yeah, so I'm gonna let you try and farm stuff.
Yeah, we'll have mag.
Yeah, they should be able to get it before they use.
Yeah.
I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna shield it for you.
No more shield.
I think they're gonna do it soon.
Back up.
Yeah, back up, back up, puncher.
Back up, back up.
yeah just back up we play here we have all we have alts
anyway i got it i got it nice thank you for shooting her too
yes yes just live this just live just live you can train
soon if you want oh i got me i'm sorry i was dead i should
have saved my i should have saved my alt then They don't
have DPS ults.
No friend?
Just let Cloak...
You should change portal.
Yeah, I died last, so you guys have to protect me.
That's fine.
Yeah, come back, come back, come back.
We're portaling, portaling, portaling.
They're gonna have Invis soon.
We're close to Cloak.
In Freddy's Moon Knight, in Freddy's Moon Knight.
You can burst them if you can.
I got, I got, nice.
Very good.
Now's there's a portal.
Yeah, yeah.
No more else, no more else you can.
Thanks.
We're shooting.
Gap, gap, gap, gap, gap, gap.
I went cloak, I went cloak.
Cloak, cloak, cloak, cloak.
Cloak, nice, nice, nice, nice.
No more else, no more else, no more else.
Yeah, we don't have alts anyway.
We made TP.
We might need White Fox to heal.
Oh, no, they're not TP.
Yeah.
You might have to, I think our...
I need to get our Wanda and try to kill the Invis or someone
through Invis.
Yeah, if the Invis all...
I'll try to bubble you.
Go on inside here, go on inside here.
What Moon Knight protect his aunts if he dares?
Do they have cap?
Do we know?
They might be close to it.
They probably have it.
They're probably going to save it for the last.
Careful, careful.
Deporto, portal, portal, portal.
Change spots.
They're behind me.
Come to us.
Come to us, Cam.
You're going the wrong way?
Yeah, yeah.
I'm trying to shield.
I'm shielding.
I don't have shield anymore.
Oh, I got stunned.
Yeah.
That was a massive ammo.
When you, when they TP behind, just TP, come to us.
Just TP to us.
Yeah, we'll have to do it next round.
We don't have TP.
Okay, swing, swing.
They're still gonna have Invis.
Yeah, we could start with Scar- like Scarlet ult.
Wait, did they still have Invis ult?
They do, yeah.
Okay, we'll just save it for that.
I got Inla down the last second.
Yeah.
Yeah, so...
I think we should...
Yeah, I think it's fine because they're on Captain America.
But just, if you're getting Dive, just TP to us.
Like, TP to the other side.
We flip the point, basically.
Like, don't worry about the cloak at that point.
Because...
I don't think it's worth it.
Okay.
Because Portal Wanda?
Because then it's...
Do you want me to dive with my ultimate?
No, I don't anyway.
57.
I don't think it's worth it in the beginning.
Maybe what we should try to do is whenever they invisal, we
should try to...
I'll try to bubble you.
We can try to kill someone through it.
Yeah, yeah.
So they only have Emma shield and kind of...
So the moment they invisal, just...
Pop your ult.
All right.
But you have to be in this ult too.
You need to do is capture the mission area.
Got it?
It seems extinction is on the agenda once again.
How predictable.
We also don't have anything to match immediately.
So be careful.
We're close to White Fox though.
Yeah.
Just let White Fox heal.
It seems we have company.
Good medicine.
I need to reload.
I got White Fox.
Nice.
They're important now.
I'm coming over.
Am I out?
Lucky's hooking.
Be careful.
Oh, I need help.
I need help.
Oh, you have to communicate that, yeah.
You know, I'm just gonna...
Calm down.
Yeah, I should sort of want to swap.
But then we got surrounded.
Oh, you're gonna swap?
Yeah, I'm gonna peel the cap more because I just kind of
have to.
We just too much.
the only thing is i can't take space so it's going to be all
you for taking space yeah i'll do it wait all of us are not
here yet all right we can use we need aggressive punisher if
we want to yeah they're gonna match with them yeah
ready i'm trying to they probably doubled yeah gaffes in the
back be careful i can't do anything i got you want white fox
yet no we're all we're all we're all no no no we're all dead
we're all dead then it's fine don't use anything don't use
anything don't use anything i told you nobody ever listens
to me the elf is going to be annoying too it's like a
picture poison but i think we just have to yeah i told you
what else do they play they basically play all hit scans so
it's like i rather but she has the most hours i'm bucky
basically i just realized we didn't have invis so no have
fun huge huge huge huge huge huge huge huge huge oh he's
just a little cap right there i'm swapping man here for
actually i'll swap emma oh you're emma's here yeah man i'm
going mag then yeah we're gonna need like i'm gonna need
some help as well for the cap when he's in the back our dps
need to shoot him to my one is back up yeah bubble i have
bubble bubble we can do i have any oh no okay captain zombie
coming to you guys stay stay near your cloak and we should i
think we can we can use it here not here okay not okay never
mind just go with the shield i'm breaking it you shoot the
emma shoot the emma i'm trying to I have the bubble.
I have the bubble.
There's no bubble.
Help her!
Help!
Got cap on me.
Oh, we have the TP.
You want me a TP or are you?
I'll do it.
I already used my ult.
I'll go at Emma then.
I'll ult on.
I will summon you up.
Oh yeah, we can do this.
They push me out?
Nice!
Okay, I can save, I can save it.
Say no more else, no more else on the left.
Yeah.
Nice, nice, nice.
All right.
I guess you have to anchor then.
I'll try and go for the cap.
Keep captured more than half of the mission area.
Keep going.
They're probably gonna have...
Did they pop a...
They're doing a...
Up here.
Where they're gonna come from.
Or down there.
One of the two.
They're over there.
Oh, one of them dropped.
One of them dropped.
Everyone shoot the cap.
Shoot the cap.
Yeah, I'm trying.
Got him, my guy, got him.
They're down one, they're down.
They can't do anything without him, to be honest.
It won't overextend, but we can still pressure them.
Oh, I'm down!
Colo, Colo, Colo, Colo, Colo, Colo!
Colo!
Hold him, hold him, hold him, hold him.
Nope, yeah.
Oh, big, big, big.
Hooked your cap, true cap.
Cap one.
He's low.
Coming over, I'm coming over now.
They're gonna have injuries.
We don't have anything for it.
They popped in this.
Okay.
I'm probably dead.
I don't have a shield.
No, I'm down, I'm down.
There's nothing I could do there.
We had to...
Yeah, when they invincible, you had to...
You had to match it because...
Yeah.
We both... both tanks got pulled in.
that pull from invis is like big i think we need invis
honestly i can try the issue is like our old we both of our
picks like with rocket they can break it and white fox they
can break it we can't break their old yeah i guess we kill
with nag it makes it a lot it makes it really hard we don't
cap is so annoying the only thing we have is jeff though Is
that our Jeff rocket or white fox?
That's the only two or three choices we have.
I feel like our rocket is...
I don't think we've won with white fox.
I think we always win with rocket.
I mean, we can go with rocket.
We might have to try it again.
And the res begins nice.
You just have to play next to each other.
Do we want to keep cloak, though?
We can do cloak or invis.
It depends on the map.
Yeah, that's true.
Because I think the pulls are good, too.
I just want to know what we should play for tank line.
I know it's hard I mean I can one of us is peeling the cap
or we need a DPS that can do it like someone just needs to
permanently keep the cap as DPS when he goes in like a
Punisher or like Phoenix or Bucky I think when they do it
how about because if I'm sitting there peeling him then I
can't like pressure their front line and then it's either
one of us is doing it we just have to pick it's fine and we
abandoned Bucky I guess it could be like i think you're the
better peeler than me though to be fair but i do think like
has our dp as dps gone back to peel i can't tell because
we're on the front line i'm not sure have kikyu and aura
have you guys been peeling or no i've been trying been
trying yeah i think all right instead of because i see you
frontlining a lot you should stick with the supports just
peel we have to pick a map yeah oh we have to pick a map
yeah wait who I think like, yeah, Aurora, you need to peel
the supports.
Just don't.
Yeah, I was.
I was staying on captain that whole time.
Yeah.
So just stay with them.
You don't have to flank anywhere or frontline.
Okay.
Do we have a preference for the map?
Not domination.
It's only convoy.
Oh, it's only convoy.
It's just all of them.
I mean, all of the drollet or Shin Shibuya?
No, we didn't pick convoy or convergence.
So.
yeah um i don't really have a preference honestly i don't
know i think it's better if you want a better emma map or a
strange map or a mag map the thing is as strange it is hard
to play strange because i don't have two tanks to fire my
charge yeah we just need someone to we need a dps to sit on
the support line like 24 7 and shoot the cap it will help a
lot we could have like both dps do you want me to go uh
squirrel girl to do that you can yeah if you think that'll
work because wandas range can only go so far yeah that's
fine um i legit don't know what map we want uh central
park's gonna be annoying because they have moon night uh we
could do it's not a non-moon night map just do that all of
the jolly that one's super open yes you're okay with that
one yeah it's super hit scan it's super long range i think i
mean Do you think we could run Moon Knight?
We could do.
Or Moon Knight.
Like, every Moon Knight is just...
Moon Knight is such a good casual farmer, too.
If you just throw the Ox on the back line.
Yeah.
I think we want Moon Knight's Squirrel Girl and see how it
goes.
If we have first...
Okay.
Are they choosing Attack or Defense or are we choosing
Attack or Defense?
I'm not sure.
Are we picking Attack or Defense?
Because we could do.
I'll ask.
the Klintar map would be good if we're running that comp
because it's like super choke heavy at the beginning.
Yeah, but they're really good at chokes too.
Oh, well.
We already lost them on Spider Island, so probably not that
one.
I feel like Yigjusil Path is also not a bad map.
The museum I definitely don't want to do.
Shin Shibuya is bad.
The Jolly is okay.
I think Yigjusil.
Yggdrasil path or the Black Panther one is like the best for
us probably
All right, we're picking attack and defense as well Which
one do you guys prefer to Jolly or Yggdrasil the Loki one or
the Black Panther one?
Yeah, we can get Black Panther one I'm talking about it Um,
do we want attack or defense first?
But you think it's better?
I think maybe defense is better because then we can adapt
faster don't you think regular defense you think we could
adapt we could adapt fast because if we're attacking we
don't have limited time to adapt oh sure if we're defense
and if it doesn't work we can literally change your comp
while they push are we ready yeah i'm ready do we know we're
gonna ban i think it's the same bad but change uh change
elsa to bucky yes yes yes yes They might go Loki again on
this map.
I mean, if we're running Moon Knight, Squirrel Girl should
be fine.
And we're defense, so just farm the backline as much as you
can.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Okay.
Who am I going to banish from this match?
Alright, so this character...
Where's Bucky?
There he goes.
yep and then angel yes for sure and then they a hundred
percent play black cat like a hundred percent we have to
yeah yeah and it's especially when they're both diving
because if we're having trouble with one dive character
we're gonna have trouble with two yeah it would be
unplayable with two because there's already creating a lot
of distraction with one it's true
Yep, I think they're banning the scene.
Do you think you can play Dive, VHOPs, and just do what they
did with Captain America?
The only issue is their road or their Elsa is going to be
permanently shooting my back.
Or he's going to shoot me 100% of the time when I go in,
which is fine because it'll be less people looking at you.
But then it'll be only you guys.
Our DPS will have to deal with the cap 100%.
I won't be able to help if I'm on Dive.
Okay, because I'm just thinking.
i'm thinking like will their support because their support
back like backline has never dealt with dive they play
really good characters for dives okay all right their
characters are way better for dives that's true they play
super sustain you guys will be up like uh cloak or sue here
uh i mean i could go sing honestly yeah i could go sing
actually and then yeah i'll kill back right we could go hmm
i feel like cloaker suits up to you whichever one you feel
more comfortable on honestly because they're both good i'll
make changes as needed let me know all right you just have
to be careful with things because their dps are like they're
gonna have elsa she's gonna blow you if it doesn't work then
i'll just i just know i have to right click all the time so
if with you on thing if they're on a diver that's gonna be
like all you yeah I'm not gonna be looking back as much
because you have the damage reduction for the team okay I
don't know if they're gonna go I didn't even know they
played cap until this match but I mean they play dive
they'll play any dive characters but he doesn't go in there
they might be port alert no they're not okay he's on rogue
this time rogue Elsa okay I'm night yep Thing is really good
in a row.
So anytime you're going to get a shift and you can't really
do much.
Gotta be careful with the red pulse.
Let me know if anyone's spike lanes or anything.
Uh, Rogue is making her way.
Where was it?
All right.
I'm backing up.
The rogue's in the back.
You got a good deal with that.
I'm doing it.
I got it off.
Yeah, I got it off.
Sable eyes.
Don't die.
All right.
Go for picks.
Okay, that's both supports.
Nice.
i'll just come back whenever you say there's a rogue i'll
just come back yeah yeah sounds good sounds good breaking
bridge yeah okay they haven't swapped anything yet yeah i
hope i can get my old before they cloak because uh that'll
be a wincon if i kill her yeah i'm just gonna let you try to
hard farm it i'm gonna have you be careful of i got rocket
rocket i got mine mln oh that's fine uh don't be to alt i
can hold this support oh i got riser another one rocket
there's a rocket one sorry sorry we got blue we can still
try to kill that's fine guys i think i should be fine we're
live that's what's important we can use funny use funny yeah
yeah
play left side or just back up and live live just live i'm
trying to just live until it's over
I see you!
Invis!
I got Invis!
Rogue in the back!
Rogue is up!
Invis!
Oh, okay.
It's fine.
It's so cold.
Massive cover.
Yeah, yeah.
Good peel.
And we're about to get our ult again.
Which one first?
Yeah, okay.
How do you have Moon Knight?
They're gonna have Moon Knight.
ult so be careful we might be on cloak for monday if
possible we can do so if uh moon night old's out old but
anyone else talking we go ahead yeah you might have to call
it because i don't recognize any games yeah we can call it
just tell everyone if you can and help i hear come on rogan
back rogan back rogan back rogan back rogan back rogan back
i just didn't get anything it's fine off i'm done ct i'm
treating invis yeah me too we don't have rocket okay okay
okay i'm trying to yeah it's some uh i was getting i don't
think we can tp i don't think we can yeah because like only
tanks can tp this one that's a good first point they lost a
lot of time yeah all right they used emma for sure yeah
they've used I'm a moon night rogue they're gonna have L
salt they're gonna have L salt careful we can whenever we
feel ready we can go punny whenever you think it's good yeah
I can shield you she's looking for no run that's not her but
most of them.
Yeah, it's fine.
I think we could do it here.
Okay.
Yeah, we can.
Amok, hill pocket put a shirt, hill pocket put a shirt.
It's fine.
Rook can die, rip and die on forward.
Nothing else.
No more else, no more else.
Down.
Oh, nice.
I got to go up.
Really good spray ball.
Emma in the back.
No, get her a kill?
Oh, no.
That's fine.
That's fine, that's fine.
Yeah.
Careful here, bro.
Okay.
also i can try and we have rocket for that yeah i can try
and yeah i can try and yeah i can try and ult this rogues on
the right okay thank god i'm gonna try and
rock um
They're down.
Nice.
Careful to the Munaidol.
Big, big quick.
They're down Invis.
They're not invis.
Nice.
You wanna push it?
We don't have, we don't have.
We don't have a, we don't have one.
Moon Knight, one, one, one.
I got you.
I'm just gonna.
Nice.
Alright.
We have a minute.
This is good for us.
That's good.
They're down.
Nice.
They use Cloak, right?
So they're gonna have Invis.
Yeah.
Yeah, they did.
They used Moon Knight, too, right?
They still have El Salt, by the way.
Yeah, they did.
Yeah, they used Moon Knight.
So we have to use Cloak.
We could...
They won Cap again.
Okay, just tell me when you're done, Dome.
I'll come back.
I'll peel.
All right, I'm good.
I'm here.
No, no, no, no, no.
Nice.
Someone's in the back.
I hear him coming.
Okay, you're fine still.
I see him.
He's in the right position in the back if you need to.
I'm moving out the way.
Yeah.
We got a captain in the back.
Really good ult.
Yeah.
I got cloak.
That's fine.
Just live this.
Yeah, yeah.
Back out of it if you need to.
I was going to end a little quicker.
Back out, back out, back out.
Yeah, I'm backing out.
Back out already.
Cap is going in our back.
Be careful.
Just mark him and he goes away.
They're still solo support.
I'm shooting their Invis.
She can die.
Invis is one.
She had to double jump away.
Nice.
Ready?
Yes, yes, yes.
Go, go, go, go, go.
We're ready.
Oh.
Oh, they used the low.
They used everything.
vault here so we could portal uh i think we can make it yeah
oh there we're yeah we're just gonna or just hide like our
squirrels stuck behind them yeah yeah and we can scroll girl
and they might be chasing here though i don't think they are
all right we i can go yeah yeah you're portaling okay you're
portaling i'll distract you this way we got such yeah we got
oh i didn't realize i didn't i didn't realize i thought we
were doing it's like no problem yeah yeah i i thought we
were i thought the portal will go first yeah it's all good
it's all good yeah we can hold close now is our squirrel
girl back with us yeah um she's gonna come from the left we
need to help her just in case just hold a little close yeah
just hold here just hold here they use cap holds by the way
so they're done we got him in the back i've got rock rock at
all to look at my rocket i'm trying to help you right now i
have all i have protected you i protected i got rocket oh oh
i'm down i'm down i'm going no it's no it's no it's no it's
no it's no it's they wasted everything okay yeah you might
have to die you have to die you have to die or you have to
die down to 30 seconds okay who's ulting first i think maybe
what did they use elsa there i think We should do cloak
first, then.
We got cloak in, maybe.
We need it.
I will send my yoke.
Cloak whenever you can.
Yeah, we can cloak first.
Yeah, yeah.
You can rock it with me.
Captain the back just play on the old in your front.
That's good, that's good.
Rocket.
Oh, my God.
It's fine.
I got you.
I'm going to wait until...
I'm playing back there in the back.
I'm gonna add you.
Nice.
Nice, that's you, that's you.
Keep our 20 alive, we win this fight.
They have no support at all.
Huge, huge, huge, huge!
Mastery.
Alright, there we go.
Captain America, Captain America, Captain America!
There we go.
They have no TP.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's good.
They didn't they didn't get third.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
two oh i mean we basically like shut down their dive yeah
you'll need a top-notch team to win this one you want me to
play thing again for that or you think he's still on cap or
road it's really good for both do you want me to stay
squirrel or wanda um it's up to you wanda might be better
yeah okay with the team up yeah why staying this character i
don't know i feel like I feel like I need to play Magneto.
I can still get Bubba, you do.
Magneto is way more consistent, plus they have an Emma.
Okay, this is very winnable.
Don't tell.
We just have to make sure the cap does not disrupt our back
line.
And then like our front line dies while he's back there and
then we're good.
I won't have as much reach on my head, but I will protect
him with my life.
Yeah.
It's working!
All right.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Got it?
Make way.
All right.
Did they change anything?
I'm like, nope.
Not really.
I don't see their other tank yet.
Oh, it's Emma.
it's front line oh okay well let's try this nice it's fine
so hard
oh shit oh man yeah careful
i got we're even we're even we're even we're even yeah it's
good
crushing their back line as much as we're good shooting emma
shooting emma You see, I'm shooting for everybody.
I'm shooting him with you.
He's slow.
He's so low, Emma.
Emma could still die.
I got him.
Big, big, big.
I'm blocking the heals.
I'm blocking too.
Kill them back.
Invis, Invis, Invis, Invis.
I got it.
I'm on cloak.
Nice.
They're going to get it.
They're going to have to, the fight, wait, they might not
get it.
We have rocket.
Just keep three on.
They might not get it.
Yeah, I've got rocket all.
Memphis, Invis, Invis.
Oh, they brought you.
Shooter, shooter, shooter.
Rocket, rocket, rocket.
Rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket, rocket.
Good,
good.
It's so big.
It's fine.
We got it.
I got it.
I still have all two.
It's clobbering time.
Really good rocket all, by the way.
Really good.
If we win this, I'll tell them.
If we win...
It's up to Loki.
uh if we win the tournament i'll let them out if they we
don't they'll never know
whoa i'm okay i'm okay i'm okay i'm okay i'm okay yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna try to blow you that's fine i got
you a lot of damage we get cloak all into this we can look
all into this wait oh
bubble are closed.
I'm sorry.
It's fine.
And we can't use those at the same time.
Yeah.
I got, oh, the bubble.
Well, back up, back up.
Just kite it, we can.
You can only use Punisher with rocket from that one.
Don't use it with cloak.
Yeah.
Okay.
Calm down.
That's fine.
Just wait.
Just reset.
Reset fully.
We can.
Wanda ult is ready.
We can bubble the wand all up in.
Wait, do they have Invis?
Oh, wait, they don't.
Wait, we have Moon Knight.
We can swap to Moon Knight.
Someone swapped to Moon Knight.
Akikyu, can you play Moon Knight?
I can try.
They're on Loki.
We can just bully him off of Loki.
I'm at...
Oh, I don't even know if I can play.
Might have to hit off him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If you feel like you're drinking too much damage.
The Loki's on the roof.
Yeah, I can't really do anything about it.
Ooh.
Yeah, there's a lot of...
A lot.
That's a lot of picks.
That's a lot of damage.
Yeah, I can't do anything about it.
Caps on me.
Caps in the back.
I also have alt again.
Rock it all.
I'm going to remember I'm helping you.
I'm trying to help you.
Whenever we rock it all, we're going to have to break the
Phoenix hole.
We could use it soon if we want.
Use it like now.
Just use it.
Did it.
Nice.
Oh, they got me down.
That's fine.
I have my ult.
It's everybody.
She's going to ult it.
Nice.
Big, big, big.
That's huge.
I got three there.
That one?
We're losing people.
If you have to win the fight, you could cloak out this.
But only if the fight's not winnable.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm swapping now.
Cap's still here.
Cap's in the back.
Cap, cap, cap.
I'm swapping now.
No shield.
Oh, my God.
The cap's so low.
I'm coming back.
I can actually use my ult to win this corner fight.
We still have Scarlet.
We can do it.
We can still go down there.
i'm gonna go into bubble or bubble again i got someone at
the back yep nice that's big we got nice we got uh we got
the loki
yeah i'm glad we'll get the point here for sure yeah yeah
yeah nice good i got it i got it i got it got it nice nice
keep one or two on point yeah yeah we have to win like one
five once they get started on their form they're not uh loki
anymore we've bullied him off so you might you can swap out
when i whenever they're gonna have cloaks so i'll try to
hear the captain so i'm gonna try and peel yeah here just
keep the comms on the captain i got you i got you good calls
jump off he's off he's out he's out he's down helper help
you hop help you up
peppering the clove yeah oh she does she don't thanks
america They're down too.
They're down too.
Just live.
Okay, we're good.
They have no support.
Once we get one, we could just maybe go.
Just don't die.
Don't die.
You know, let's have one.
We have rockets, dude.
I got, I got, I got a heal.
I got a heal.
Kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill.
Kill, kill, kill.
Three on, three on, three on.
Kill, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap.
Nice.
I have one.
If they use...
I'm gonna try.
I should have my own here in a second.
Shoot Moon Knight.
Everybody shoot him.
I got him.
Oh my god.
Okay.
All right.
I don't know.
This is my first time.
Oh, it's fine.
When they go low key, we have to play Moon Knight.
Yeah.
That was amazing.
Holy.
Amazing.
Oh my god.
Let's go.
Winnable.
Wait, even though.
Nice.
Rockets.
Rockets coming in.
Good swaps.
Yeah, yeah, good swaps.
Yeah.
Do you want me to stay on Wanda or confuse them with
Squirrel Girl?
It just depends on what they play.
I think defense-wise you should play Squirrel Girl, though.
I think maybe.
What do you think, V-Hops?
What?
Say that again, sorry.
Oh, defense, we should play Squirrel Girl.
Um, yes.
I mean, if you think you're doing good on it, yes.
They choose now.
I was able to peel cap.
I was able to peel cap a lot, a lot easier with Wanda.
Yeah.
And the columns for cap are amazing.
Every time you call out that he's there, it helps so much.
Thank you.
Yeah.
It's going so good.
Keep it up.
Okay.
Let me, I'll start on Wanda because I do peel him off a lot
faster that way.
But if it's not working out, I'll switch the first time I
die.
No, let's see how it goes.
Yeah.
Those were good bands, too.
Mm hmm.
We keep the bands.
Like I said, Angela is not as oppressive and as well as
Elsa.
They may change up the bands.
When they go in Elsa, like she was so easier.
She was much easier to kill.
okay oh all right yeah the bucky was way more annoying it's
like i don't know i they just clumped up like i don't know
they just clumped up for me and i was fine with that i was
like all right i'm okay with that yeah
it still doesn't change how I feel about tank why also like
I like support more because I have to do less effort to win
a game I can do less I can do less to win games that's so
true less effort I don't like how much I have to try.
That's my Oshi.
That's her.
The bare minimum.
That's me.
I like the bare minimum.
Okay, they're going attack first.
Are we ready?
Uh, yeah, I'm ready.
Ready.
We'll see what their bad line is to decide because yeah,
yeah, because if they're doing if they're gonna do Phoenix
again when I'm on thing I think I'll just play Emma and then
you can play mag Yeah, because I think I have to be on yeah,
because I think when you're Emma you're you're too you might
be to a hyper aggressive Yeah
Probably don't walk out on thing though on defense because
we're just gonna immediately lose first point Yeah, I'm
gonna counter pick it.
I'll do Emma first then or will or will won't die in case
they're watching right now all right rebanned what last time
it was bucky angela black cat yeah i guess the order i feel
like it doesn't matter it doesn't matter it's rank bands
first anyway i doubt their bands are going to be affected by
the order yeah it's rank band so it doesn't really matter
like surely they don't uh ban this guy right the one i'm
actually clicked first because they play it also guys they
can't like they can't be like i mean oh my god look see toky
shouldn't have look at that she shouldn't have been on that
team it's so op this was literally the first time i've ever
played thing they can't do this to me it's literally the
first time i've ever played thing
they just don't like to see it they don't want to see the
deadpool day and then they tell us and then angela yep We
can't have one, they can't have one.
Same bands.
The right heroes could make all the difference.
All right.
There we go.
Travis.
Okay.
No matter what, I'm proud of this team.
good job we made it this far one day i mean yeah we all
practice this team like today so other teams have been
practicing yesterday fun fact we're the only team to take a
map off of them yet so yes i mean that was what happened to
me last time and then we won
i will aura i will okay i'm probably gonna start up top and
I'll drop down whenever you want me just in case you want to
stop up top with you um you can start bottom I'm just gonna
start top just to see if they go up there all right I'll
start here if they go low key just run uh run moonlight
again this is a really good moonlight map too cap is going
up left or he went bottom left one of the two so he's gonna
be in the back Caps here.
Caps here.
He has no idea where we're at though.
Okay, okay, okay.
He's not on us yet.
All right, just say when he's on, yes.
Nope.
Yeah, he was, he made the turn and then he missed the turn.
That must be super low.
Don't worry.
Okay, it's fine.
Just like, don't go too aggressive, don't blow up.
We're doing good.
Caps.
Nice, nice.
I turned around through it.
Oh, nice.
worked on those okay careful i got him he said he's that
he's that me someone heal me i need to back out i'm doing
the best i can i'm doing i'm back okay okay i'm just okay
imma low immo low immo low imma's also low yep yep massive
res by the way rocket really good res places all right we We
don't have res now, so we have to be careful.
Yeah, I almost have my ult.
Who's ulting first?
I got 20 seconds left on it.
All right.
Don't go off the 20 seconds.
I got rocket.
Rocket my ult.
Yeah, rocket first.
You know, it might be going top left.
Be careful.
I don't see him.
Capsy, are you on first rocket?
Well, whatever.
Right now.
Got it.
Oh, I'm bad.
That's fine.
He said no.
Yeah, Cap took me out as well.
Never mind.
I died.
Yeah, Phoenix.
No.
I think maybe.
think i have phoenix now yeah swap rocket to white fox uh
yeah i can yeah um can we touch yeah we can touch yeah we
can go in with cloak here i think we have to maybe yeah i
think we do okay poke in whenever i have my health
nice oh my god nice i think grabbed her did i no more else
no more else no more oh wait okay It's fine.
It's fine.
They're going to have capple.
They also have...
We have to...
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
You're going to have to kill the cloak.
And then we have to maybe scarlet the cap.
Yeah.
If you guys are free during that local shootout, it makes it
easier.
I'm at 97.
I'll try to chain down the phoenix.
We all gotta shoot it.
Yeah.
I'll cap it.
Bye, claim.
Got one death.
I don't...
I'm sorry.
i had so much so many people too i'm sad i think we can
always come with emma and yeah yeah i'm always really sure
you want to stay on fox hey one does uh one does ready i'm
in one we should always come on okay we what is it we were
down to is we're gonna be yeah wait wait wait we have to do
we should do still have cloak Yeah, these sub cloaks, okay.
I think we can engage with...
Actually, we can't engage with anything.
Yeah.
We're still waiting, so be careful.
We're going to Moon Knight all up soon.
All right, we're here.
Yeah.
I don't have Bubble right now, so I can be able to...
Backline, backline, Cat.
What?
Okay, I got him off.
I got him off.
We're going to Moon Knight all up soon, so be careful.
I think we could use Scarlet soon here.
Wait, Bubble Knight, bro.
bubble over i don't have it oh they grab emma killed the
emma oh yeah i got staple caps on me it's fine it's not yип
you're gonna have moon night all here i'm going i'm i need
help i need help he did i'm dead i'm dead i jumped out of it
oh that's fine best huge that's used yes he wheels to pop
caps on me i got her i got it nice cat in the back cap in
the back one Nice.
I just stabilized.
Don't die in there.
Don't die.
Get the point.
I'm good.
I'm going to go ahead.
Oh, he pushed me.
Really good push.
Might be able to get him right here.
He's still in the right of the left.
I might go.
We can combo.
They're coming back.
Just be careful.
It's staggered.
Yeah, it's staggered.
Stay down.
I have ults soon.
I might be able to use alt with the with the Scarlet here.
I think we should do that.
You have Fox ult soon?
combo.
I'm at 94.
Fox heal.
There's Fox here.
I'm running.
I'm at 91.
That's at 90.
Yeah.
Moon Night, all here.
We can't bunch up two.
It's close.
They used it, but they might have it again.
Okay.
Alright.
They're gonna have Emma then.
They're gonna have Emma, and they're gonna combo with the
Phoenix again.
Then I can pop.
Someone's up top.
I got Fox.
Me and Fox.
I'm done.
I'm trying to.
I'm trying to here.
We have Fox still in here.
And Fox, whatever.
Got it.
Nice and nice, nice.
I'm going to use...
Yeah.
Okay.
He grabbed me instead.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Wait, quick, quick, quick, quick, quick, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, go, cap, cap, cap, cap, cap.
All right.
On me.
He said, he said, he's one, he's one.
Nice.
Huge.
I have my ult for this one.
Phoenix on.
This one, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now they definitely have Moon Knight ult.
Yeah.
And maybe Cap.
Oh, yeah.
They're going to Moon Knight our Punisher.
Yeah.
You might though.
I'll say bubble for you, but I don't know if it'll be enough
to keep you alive.
Him and her shield.
Cap on the right.
Cap in the back.
Yeah, I got you.
He's already half.
He's out.
Okay.
Oh, they're going to come in.
They're going to moonlight.
Yeah.
No, no, no, no.
It's fine.
I can stall here a bit.
Both heels down.
It's fine.
No, nothing.
You don't have to use anything.
I can.
Yeah, yeah.
card time yep just yeah we have cloak all here we could hope
all this yeah cloak all first maybe the other other dagger
definitely has it yeah we can we have mag here yeah if you
think we can kill anything but if you don't then don't use
it we have to you're here go here yeah yeah
I didn't realize I wasn't in it we're gonna have to help our
cloak yeah I don't know if I'm gonna be able to kill their
cloak oh I'm down why couldn't get out of it oh Emma's
shield is insane yeah it's okay we got two every time yeah
yeah my way back you should reset I'm going squirrel I'm
going squirrel all right Okay.
I do not have my ult for cloak.
Wait, what did you use it for?
I tried to kill her there, but I would have killed her, but
they got blocked.
Oh.
Cap is on the right.
Slash, no.
Cap's on me.
Oh, I used my shield.
Nice TP.
Help!
Beyond, go, go, go, go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're gonna close.
I got that.
You're still even.
You're even.
Hey, yeah, yeah.
I need help.
Nice and nice.
Captain.
You don't have anything for that, by the way.
Yeah, just back.
Just just die.
Just die or, or back up fully.
Okay.
Because we don't have a lot.
Oh.
Can we even touch it?
I can stall it as Venom friendly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I might be like, grab all of it.
You have to go in soon.
You have to go.
Do we have alt here?
I couldn't do anything.
We at least got them to 13.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't know what...
I think you have to go to Squirrel Girl, honestly.
I think Squirrel Girl is doing more.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
The higher the pressure.
You still want Fox?
every time we don't think we can break the phoenix salt then
we have to go fox but i think the rocket is better if we can
break the phoenix salt we just have to all shoot it we try
the phoenix we try rocket just just try it okay it's not as
bad on attack we just have to shoot it whenever they do it
because they're going to win for sure because the res is
super nice as well if we just use punisher with rocket every
time i think we should run moon night
honestly I think moon night has been their moon night is
literally just getting random picks off of us and we can do
the same it's so fast I do you think we get more value out
of the Wanda ults than the squirrel girl ults or they're on
penny by the way oh okay just be careful for random minds
we're gonna have to like I can maybe go up top and break the
nests because it's probably just in the pinyardar room so
we'll be on the right or the left here to help take those
out i can i'll just shield it i don't know where it is no
i'm just gonna go i know where it is i can break it like
immediately don't stop me they won't know
oh thousand thousand needs all right i'm breaking it right
now just chill all right it's gone already and i'm trying to
help you
Okay.
I'll be more mean.
I need help here.
Okay.
You don't really have to take too many off angles at
midnight, by the way.
You can just sit with our team and do damage.
Yeah, just farm.
Yeah, just farm it.
In the back one.
They're gonna put the penny nest again.
I'm gonna break it immediately.
I have to back up.
I can't break it.
He's marking me.
Yeah, yeah.
I need help here.
He's gonna leave.
He forgot about me.
I broke the nest.
Whenever I'm breaking the nest, you have to just chill.
Yeah.
We got a light shield.
Nice good pick.
Oh, we're done with rocket.
Oh my god.
They jumped me immediately.
It's not the end of the world.
Just play safe.
Yeah.
You don't have too much healing or we still have damage.
Yeah, we're just slowly pushing it.
I'm going back.
I have my own.
You get to put, I'll sit in front of them, like back behind
them.
So then they have to push into us.
Yeah.
Oh, that's fine.
That's fine.
Don't use anything.
Okay.
Got my health here.
I can help nobody else.
I'm holding okay That's good.
That's good.
I broke the mines.
Oh, I've got rocket all good.
Okay, that's huge.
We killed him
Papa's trying to get me
Okay, they're dead they're dead.
Help B hops if you can I can't I can go one of these people
Yeah, I've got Rocket already.
It's fine, it's fine, I'm fine.
Three on?
Yeah, yeah.
Three on, three on, three on.
I can alt this.
I'll alt this and then we can scroll, go alt this.
Multi?
Kill Emma.
Alt this, scroll go, scroll go, scroll go, scroll go, scroll
go, scroll!
I can pop up.
Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma.
Shoot the Emma, one, uncurt.
Do we want Rocket?
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yeah, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Okay.
Oh, Phoenix is dead.
She can't break it.
I'm blocking it.
They can't.
They can't break it.
Nice.
Really good rock and roll.
Yeah, nice.
We let our cloak build all.
Let our cloak build all.
Yeah, we can push up with this.
Am I out here?
I'll keep him push up with this.
Keep one on cart for a little bit.
Yeah, I'll ride.
They're running captain now.
Just tell us when he's on on.
you so yeah because i when i turn around he just and he's
over away and i can't do anything about it uh he's he's
right there yep he's running up i i got him out of it that's
fine completely uh nice
trying to help you ricky on center it is true okay they're
gone guys i got me got me i was trying to get you they're
down one they're down where even you pegged yeah i'm helping
i'm on kurt one i got cloak nice nice here's that i'm on急
for one cap is taller or he's in the back all right so the
cap quick he does i need help i need help i need all that's
fine it's fine it's fine it's fine we're not shooting him
he's still in i'm trying to wait the cap is is somehow still
here oh my god wait the cap is still alive yeah he sure is
still alive i'm coming back now yeah overextended dude that
was my bad we're gonna have ml okay true pick up still he's
on me he's solo he's solo nice nice nice nice thank you i
need heels and heels thank you
i'm multi this that's huge that's you that's you that's you
that's you Cloak, Cloak, Cloak, Cloak, Cloak, Cloak, Cloak.
Emma, Emma.
That's right, that's right.
Bubble on side.
Everyone shoot the cap.
Everyone shoot him.
I got him.
They're going to TP.
There's three, three on, three on, three on, three on.
They can't, they can't, they can't, they can't.
Yeah, see.
Nice, nice.
Wait, I can't get you.
I'm going to kill you.
I killed you.
I shielded you.
I shielded.
Their cloak is so up here.
Yeah, I'm trying to shield you shield him.
They're down to support right now Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah
Moonite on the left.
He's gonna win.
Moonite win.
I got him.
Push card.
One of you guys push card.
On card.
I got it
They're on rogue now?
They're in rogue.
I think that's easier for us.
We have two ults.
Careful Moonite.
Careful.
I got rocket.
The rogue is near you.
Be careful.
Your supports can't see you up here yet.
Yeah, it's fine.
I'm good.
There's a bubble now.
She wasted it.
I'm gonna go.
I wasted my shield.
You want rocket?
Yeah, just...
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Rocket, rocket.
Oh, you killed.
You killed well.
Big.
Yeah.
Still the emma.
Kill the rogue on cart.
Nice.
Keep three.
Massive Moon Knight ult.
It's fine.
Yeah, good rocket ult as well.
Yeah, yeah.
I'll try to kill the cloak with mine.
Make sure you have that rocket peeking nearby.
Kill the cage.
No,
no, no, no.
No, no, no.
I'm just gonna die here.
I have all here soon.
That res right before this.
Oh my god.
We didn't have all here.
Back up.
Yeah, back up, back up, back up, scroll up, scroll up,
scroll up, scroll up!
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
And now there's hellfire today.
We're waiting for Dookie, and then we have Emma.
They're aiming for me.
Don't, don't, don't, don't look at her, don't look at her.
Scroll go, oh!
We have to wait.
We're going for a couple more seconds.
I almost have Reds back.
All right.
The world got me?
It's fine.
Careful, they're getting aggressive, they're getting
aggressive, they're getting aggressive.
I'm trying to try, I have to use this then.
Oh.
I'm Reds, I'm Reds.
Rogue, Rogue, Rogue, Rogue, Rogue, Rogue, Rogue, Rogue,
Focus on Rogue.
I got Rogue.
Everyone shoot Emma.
Shoot Emma.
She can die.
She's way too far up.
Careful.
You're by yourself.
You're by yourself, you're house.
Careful.
Yeah, I'm here.
I'm here.
Shoot the Emma.
She's isolated.
Block her heels.
I'm looking at her.
Yeah, yeah.
Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma.
Oh, you want it?
You want it?
Use it, use it, use your own- Oh, I got in, they took it
away.
It's bad, it's alright.
GG's though, we did well.
They TP.
I don't- Oh, wait, wait, wait, okay, here.
We have one more fight.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Here you go, here.
All right.
Don't die, don't die.
Oh, the car's in the way.
I can't- I can't- Oh.
We had a tie.
We put it on the car.
On the car.
Oh.
Move, did it move.
Wow.
I'm gonna move.
NT, NT, NT, NT.
Holy.
GG.
We did really, really well, though.
I don't want any of you to feel, like, bad about yourselves
or anything, especially for how much time we had to practice
and how much experience some of our players had.
We did, like, actually amazing.
this was a really stacked team we were going in yeah you
should all feel good about yourselves holy ggs guys that was
a good series all right i'll let you guys know that thing
play through that thing gameplay i did that was the very
first time i touched thing by the way that was the very
first time i'm proud of our team good job i'm proud of us
ggs guys ggs oh yeah That's second.
That's pretty good.
You know?
That's pretty good, guys.
You guys, like, our DPS, you guys were up against really
hard competition, so I get it.
It's very hard against that.
But, yeah.
GG's, everybody.
I'm gonna go play rank.
I need a... I'm gonna go play rank.
I want to play support.
I'm tired.
Yeah, have fun.
Have fun.
Good job.
Wait.
Yeah, never mind.
I was going to say you might have to do an interview, but I
think it's only Shoto.
So they said captains.
No, they said captain.
They said both.
Oh, both.
Oh, okay.
I'll stay a little longer.
I need to cleanse my tank run with some support later.
That was an aura tank gameplay though, for like not playing
it that often.
I was going hard, especially the thing.
Especially the thing.
I literally had one hour of tank knowledge before I came
here.
So, you know what?
GGs.
We all did the best we can.
Yeah, we did pretty freaking good.
Yeah, we did.
We did.
Yeah, I think a lot of us had to, like, pick up new
characters, too.
I think Shoto's team, they didn't have to flex as much as we
had to, to learn on the fly.
I think their team was very, very flexible.
I'm fine with second place.
I said whatever happens.
I'm fine with it with the stuff as a generational place with
the amount of game knowledge I have just watching my friends
play tank I think their team had more flexible players they
weren't like locked in with specific characters that they
had to play um because they had a DPS player my dog has been
yelling at me for the past they had a DPS player that was
super flexible as well thank you so much for playing thank
you thank you for the carry appreciate it you've been great
ggs yeah ggs everybody ggs we guys all did really well yes
yes uh anyone else to go you're all free to go i'm like
kidnapped here so it was super fun regardless like i think a
lot of us i think like i think our team i think our team was
just all mostly off rollers too i think yeah i think yeah oh
yeah a hundred percent showed us team is like flex flex tank
like they are all they all play their role basically so we
did pretty well like we fucking yeah neck to neck with them
i think we did really well we took a map i think it was just
like little mistakes like the like the small like alts and
the to like aggression and stuff that we did i think the
pressure got to us a little bit too is like kind of
stressful yeah just the little mistakes there like the
portal in front of in the cart there the portal i'm gonna
think about that i'm gonna have nightmares one above all
you're still making portal on the card mistake we saw me do
it yesterday but i had an excuse be ups 800 matches of
strange to make up for it to the portal on the card oh
that's gonna haunt me yeah the game changer there yeah we
actually could have like we could have yeah yeah that's what
that did i wasn't thinking about the cart was moving
backwards because they had it capped i never think about
that i forget it even does that angle i i'm a noob how much
hour like 3 000 hours in this game that's yeah now we'll
always remember i hope your chat never lets you forget i
hope the trauma continues to live on for years it's a be ops
portal now if it's in the card, it's a B half smile.
Just like just like an Ajax.
I don't know about that one.
I don't know what that one is.
You're going to be an Ajax soon.
I'm not lowered up enough.
It was just places.
Like when I was like calling like back up, back up.
And then there was like three ults that like two ults that
got in.
And I was like, oh, I was like debating so hard if I should
have alted our mag to like, alters to save our mag without
having to use the res, too.
I think that tilted me when I was, like, back up, back up.
And then I saw, like, an alt being, like, I saw the alt.
An alt being thrown out afterwards.
That was the one that tilted me the most, because we could
have comboed with, we could comboed with it.
Yeah, but I can't, I can't be too harsh, because they're new
players.
It's, like, you know, you can't really do much if they're a
new player, you know?
So it's all more so of just, like, you have to play around
them.
All right, that was one time I was aggressive as Emma.
And we still got, I, that was, okay, we didn't get the card
because I was just like, how did we not kill a Captain
America?
How, I thought my team had it.
I didn't realize I had to come back to help out.
Yeah.
I didn't think I had to come back.
micro magic the thing is i i can't i don't have what i don't
see what's behind me too but i was like fucking doing a lot
of stuff on emma yeah
yeah i think it's just like we uh uh it was just two little
mistakes you know but it's the thing is like this tournament
has like a lot of players in different brackets skill wise
so you can't you can't do much like you can't really what's
the word like it just like it it is what it is type deal you
just have to play around it as I was trying it was that's
why you can tell that it was me trying to be as flexible as
possible with as different tanks and just picking up
different tanks being like okay I'm just gonna run this tank
and I'm just gonna run that tank because I can be flexible I
can learn on the fly like as you guys saw I literally was
learning on the fly on Groot and thing and then it worked
for me it worked because i have lots of experience adapting
and i've watched so many games i watched so many games wait
they loki just ended the they're like ending the stream yeah
i told you it's just captains only it's just captains only
for what no i meant like it's just starting winning the
winner captain sorry not the not second place that's why i
was like oh they're doing second place now too they said
captains please oh okay yeah i think it was just in the
beginning all right ggs got the game let's fun playing with
everyone hi guys i'm meeting all of you have a good rest of
your time thank you for the games bye bye i'm playing with
you again ducky yeah bye bye everyone uh but what was my
what was my trina thought i already forgot
I can't wait to play support.
Fuck tank roll.
Alright, sorry.
What was my train of thought before they were like?
Oh yeah, so it's more so like...
It's hard...
It's very hard to adapt.
So it was like...
It's just more so like...
So I try to be the more flexible.
It's just me and B-Hops that are the ones trying to be as
flexible as possible but when we were against Shoto I was
just like just fuck it Moon Knight just didn't run Moon
Knight because that was everybody just kept running Moon
Knight and was working because Moon Knight is such a it was
such a noob killer and it was working I wish we ran Moon
Knight earlier it was working no take Toki will not return
in Avengers 3 It will not return.
Yeah, I just wish we ran it earlier.
But I was trying not to be too hands-on.
I think I still was.
Because I wasn't captain.
I was more so trying to be a soundboard.
Because I just wanted to chill.
I just wanted to chill.
So I was trying to be more of a soundboard.
But I had to put my foot down the bucket.
I knew.
I knew bad line.
My bad line is always accurate.
my I fucking knew it I was like all right you say so if you
fucking say I know my bad line I know man I got second place
I mean hey I made it this I was tank diffing people who had
more hours than me on tank I'll just say that I'm proud of
that uh i did i was co-igl because i had to co-igl because i
noticed like people get overwhelmed so i had to i as i got
more used as i got more used to like playing tank you can
tell that i started to know my buttons more i started to
know my buttons more so i was just like oh that's fine it's
fine yeah i think i did i'm proud of myself like i didn't
think i'd make it this far they're told beehives i'd be
happy with third place like i think they told beehives i was
like i'd be happy with third place man i don't care and he's
like we could we could get in the finals like oh i'd be
happy if we even get third i'm proud of myself i tanked if
people with more hours than me we all saw the proof these
were my hours before i had to go in or was it these were my
hours on tank you see all those juicy support hours 55
minutes one negative win rate by the way negative here look
at look at this where is it i ran in i'm picking thing guys
i I'm not making...
I ran it.
Guys, I'm gonna pick thing.
It's gonna work out.
It's gonna...
In the fourth minute, Groot.
In the fourth minute Groot.
God, you're so cool.
Please.
No!
She'll never return.
She'll never come back.
But yeah, like I said, like...
I think we did pretty well.
Because our role, like...
Everybody was technically...
A lot of people were off-rolling, too.
A lot of people were off-rolling.
And...
It was very limited character pool, too.
It was a very limited character pool.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, let me...
have to lock in on this i okay eternity games let's go
all right oh that's cool i'm fine with that i mean we could
actually have triple support back actually i'll do cloak i
won't chill oh i mean as long as not tank i'm fine i'm fine
as not tank honestly all
right here we go by two captain americas oh we should yeah
we got that i already missed tank toky she's dead
she's buried at sea
she's never coming back
all right all
right here
you go so i have to zone out a little bit before i come in
all right let's go
i mean i wouldn't mind being able to play dps but they have
to put me on like flat or diamond dps because or give me
time to actually learn dps on rivals i also have not played
a lot the only dps i play is sila or hella but even then uh
i've been aiming a lot in overwatch so don't worry buddy i
got you i got you buddy oh my god is this it all right oh no
it's a black cat it's a vibe It's fine.
Don't give me go.
I get to chill.
Woo!
Yeah.
I think it's also a lot of people's first time playing a
tournament.
So like, uh, so obviously a lot of pressure for them too.
It's understandable.
That's why like little mistakes and stuff, you know, you
don't know the...
haven't played like in these type of environments before so
it's understandable oh my god our widow does not care oh my
god what is our widow doing we're on i just realized we're
on triple tank yeah because like i've played so many
tournaments so so it's like easier for me.
I still get stressed, but...
Are we... Is she still alive?
Okay, we deserve to lose this.
I'm gonna say we don't have enough damage.
Holy shit.
What is my ping?
What is my ping right now?
What is going on behind?
This is a good first game back, guys.
First game in the Oh my god.
Chinando.
I don't think...
I don't think he's gonna live.
I might be dead actually.
No!
I'm fucked.
No, I have to die.
Just kill me.
Thank god.
I had to die there.
They're a good way, man.
But...
You really meant it.
Uh, Phantom.
And they turned into a meme.
Yeah.
What can I do?
All right.
Can you swap up, little?
It's time.
Three tanks.
I know.
Why are we?
Why are we three things?
I rather we have three supports.
Like, why are we doing this to ourselves?
Why?
All right, here we go.
Like, why are we doing this to ourselves anyway?
Oh Hello
Whoa Whoa Why are we doing this to ourselves?
There we go Like I don't understand why are we okay Now we
have no votes
Oh my god, he's here.
There we go.
Oh my god.
Woo!
He's alive!
See, look how much fun I'm having.
Even if we could be losing right now, but look, look how
much fun I'm having.
This is the fucking worst.
fucking cop I've ever seen but at least I'm happy I'm
happier I'm gonna try let her oh I'm gonna heal a little bit
all right you should have a listen at
least I'm happy
Oh shit.
Okay, we're gonna die regardless.
Oh unless Unless I die.
Yeah.
Oh fuck.
Okay, fuck it All right, I had to die I got fucking Alright.
Oh, that sucks.
Oh, no.
He's gonna B-Hops this.
Let me in.
I got scared.
I got... Oh, I thought that was a person.
Not gonna laugh.
He's gonna B-Hops it, guys.
He almost did.
Guys, he almost B-Hops it.
That's so scary.
where is my where's my rocket wait did he die where is he i
lost him oh nice
generational trauma he has to live live with it look it's
different if if you're a new player but how many hours have
you had
That's why I'm harsh here.
Mr. Lord Strange.
What's...
Yes!
He is!
He's literally one of us all take me!
He'll never...
I will make sure.
he never forgets.
Okay, I fed there.
I fed there.
I didn't think I would get shot.
I'll play more here.
She knows.
I didn't know who he is, but now I do.
Now I know who he is.
Holy shit.
Oh, it's a damage boost.
Cover close behind you.
Okay, that is crazy.
That guy did nothing.
Doesn't this feel more engaging?
I can actually see everything that's going on in this fight.
Wow.
I can actually see all the stuff that's going on in my game
right now.
It's great.
I can actually see it.
Oh, never mind.
Nice.
Bro!
Is it me looking at the front and just waiting?
Time to switch things up.
Including which side you're on.
You need a top-notch team to win this one.
We are cloak and dagger.
We are hope and fear.
Alright.
Bum, bum, bum.
Round 2!
I don't know, but um...
Ty and I create equilibrium.
So I had to disassociate.
I had to disassociate there.
Weeeeee.
They asked me to come back, I'm gonna say no.
I can't do that again.
I'm not doing that again.
I'm sorry.
I'm not.
I'm not doing BT Recon Rivals again.
I'm done.
I'm not doing tank again, guys.
I can't.
I can't do it again.
Unless they, like, I don't know.
Unless there's more, no.
They trap.
I do trap.
Honestly, trap.
I would rather it's a draft.
A snake draft.
Instead of a balance.
balancing because like it's just it it was just too last
minute it was it was just legitimately too last minute for
me uh yeah
looking at their back on three two one I don't even know if
we can there we go
Yeah.
Please kill him like killing the cap.
It's not hard.
Unless it's stake draft.
And like, it wasn't like two days notice.
I was just...
Uh...
Just too much.
Too much.
Like, I wasn't stressed out.
It was just...
I just didn't like how last minute it was.
You know?
Oh, wait, that hit him, right?
Yeah, it did.
Somebody...
She's so one.
Oh, we got it.
Oh, she's so dead.
That's crazy that we got that.
Fuck yeah, I'm just gonna stay here Can they find over
there?
Hello
Who the fuck is our Thor trying to kill that's what I want
to know Yeah
Is everybody fine?
Everybody's fine.
I love those I swear to god if they're I fucking knew it
horses are getting a dokey then I don't know it just feels
way too last minute so I don't think I'll be comfortable
doing another one too stressful I think like a way to
improve it's just just do a snake draft if balancing is too
hard if you do a snake draft and then give the captains like
the list of everybody what everybody played then like then
we'll like we can handle the draft live on stream i feel
like that'd be easier i would love to heal you
because people are gonna complain about
oh he's making it oh wait that's not good Oh my god, where's
my team?
Yeah, they don't have to plan out the balancing stuff.
If they draft the bad team, that's on the captains.
Because then if you're like complaining about the balancing,
if you're complaining about the balancing, then it's like,
you know, you complain about the organizers.
But if you pick your own team, you can't really complain
about the team you get.
it because it's the the captain picked the team in the end
there is more pressure on there is yes there is oh my god
there's more pressure on the captain to pick a better team
but then you know as long as the captains do their research
yeah that's all that matters yeah it's what the captain and
it saves time and also there's no unfair advantages because
it was all you know the of like uh uh like coaches and like
scrims and stuff no if you have no scrims everyone just
learns as we go everyone fucking figures shit out oh my god
let's go yeah just everyone figures it out don't need to
worry about people investing this is why why i feel really
bad because a lot of people invested lots of time in scrims
and stuff and if they don't do well in the final matches you
know they're like oh i i spent so much time screaming the
last couple of days no no people were screaming i saw some
teams that were screaming for six plus hours like from today
and today and yesterday too i felt bad it's like my team um
i mean i had to i did a crash course
I mean, I did a crash course, but we didn't scrim until at
three.
Yeah, like, we didn't scrim until, like, today.
And today was our first time we played together.
But, like, some teams, they've been playing together since
yesterday, like, non-stop to prepare for it.
To prepare for it.
Our team literally just practiced, like, today.
Yeah.
That's what I'm saying.
Like, it's whichever team, like, actually, so that's what I
was saying.
If you want it to actually be fair, and want it to be fun,
just do a snake draft on the tournament day.
It, um, it, it, like, clears up everything.
Like, all the complaints about balancing.
Just do a snake draft on the day.
We'll figure it out live.
We'll, we'll figure everything out live.
Every team comp, every character, every player.
that would make it more fun.
But right now, if it's, yeah, no prep just to adapt.
Yeah, we go in adapting.
Because then it's more, it's more like you know, some
players are like, I don't have time like the cat, like, you
know, like just oh, I signed up.
I didn't realize we have to invest so much time on it.
Yeah.
It was fun.
I mean, I get to fuck around on tank.
I make generational plays on tank, guys.
I think i had fun i just think to make it better overall and
make it better overall for like people to enjoy the game in
general um which hero do you think you want to be yeah i
literally we won the game because i had like five man ult
something and i played it for the first time i was just like
fuck it let's go we do it live fuck that shit let's go or
banning loki i'm not playing loki for you Oh, yeah, Black
Hat.
I am not playing Loki for you, bro.
I'm tired.
I just came back from a tournament.
Look at that.
Wait.
I'm banning Loki.
I don't want to play Loki Gambit right now.
I really don't want to play Loki Gambit.
I don't care.
They're like, why aren't you ban Tankpool?
I do not want to play Loki Gambit.
Are you picked up the thing earlier?
I think if I yeah I think if I picked up thing when we're
first when we're first getting dove at I think we could have
won the first map I just didn't pick it because I was like
I'd never touch thing before I like you know because it was
you know I was just like I've never touched thing before is
it really worth is it really worth risking it all and then
you know by the second game you know during like uh uh when
we are on our second game i was like that's it it's it's win
it or lose it it's all or nothing it's time to play thing if
we lose my bad if we win pick of the century adapt on i
adapt as we go along
Like literally you guys saw my profile less than a minute on
thing.
Right?
Like the thing is Angela is so easy to counter.
It's like you don't see Angela in high elo.
Like you see cat more than Angela.
She's so easy to counter.
But the thing is you need to have the mechanical skill to
counter Angela because you don't.
But the thing is our support backline isn't high elo.
So like that wasn't in my head because you know I usually
would be the one playing support and I'll be like it's fine.
support will be fine um but like it wasn't in my head that
they needed more than that because like uh because like
angela is very easy to counter so i wasn't thinking that and
i realized they do need more help they do need more help so
i'm just gonna and i think bhop is also like um he's not
used to playing with like uh lower elo players in a way
where oh my god jump to my gambit too where like uh they
need more help yeah and like also like he was like super
aggressive when uh when uh he needed to like chill a little
bit too which is understandable because like i played i had
more experience with that that's why i was like we gotta go
simple We have to, because he was like, you want to do
bunker on the point?
I was like, bro, they're not going to understand that.
We need to scrim that.
We need to scrim that, bro.
Like, there's no way they can pull that off right off the
bat.
Yeah.
Yeah, we just have to go simple.
Just go in.
What the fuck are you doing?
What?
No, you're not.
No, you're just gonna die.
There's no fucking way.
I've been saying, what do you want me to do?
Game bit one.
Do you not know how to de-hop on that fucking hill?
I just got back!
I just don't believe you.
Watch the fuck up.
I just got back, buddy.
I honestly...
What?
Excuse me?
He just randomly lobs in the direction, in the area I was in
while I was invisible.
How did that happen?
What?
That was actually bullshit.
I'm sorry, but that was actually bullshit.
Unless he completely...
I'm just that easy to read.
Maybe.
That's just it.
I know they're in this tazel, so.
I'm, like, trying to beat.
I'm, like, a little scared.
Nagito just knows.
I know.
Beehawks did a lot of crazy shit, though.
Like, he carried hard.
Like, as the one above all tank, that man fucking carried.
when needed
there you go oh he's back he just walked up
okay it worked but i don't know anymore though He's like,
where is she?
No!
Don't give him back, that bitch!
That fucking war!
I'm on a divorce- Oh wait, no, I'm not Gambit.
I hope he divorces you.
What the fuck?
Really?
Like, Gambit.
Oh shit.
Someone help him.
Jesus Christ.
I can't do that again, by the way.
Unleashing everything.
Also, I really appreciate that Bihar's helped with the cause
too, because I was so fried.
I was so fried with everything.
Like me, me learning, wait what's this, me learning how to
play tank on the fly and also trying to micro, macro, IGL
us, or co-IGL.
Oh, dad, that angie.
Even though he is already fed.
Daddy, I hope I made good calls.
I don't know.
The thing is, I don't know if I made good calls.
I was just chilling.
I was just, like, suggesting stuff because, like I said, I
don't know what meta is for this season.
What do you want?
They're kind of my only friends.
Yeah.
What?
All right.
He just went to tension.
Yeah, he does.
Don't get me to go.
It's like riding a bike.
Get that shit girl off of here.
Look at that.
Look at that fucking play.
Fucking hell.
Look at that.
Look at that play.
That's how you play support.
That's right.
Oh.
Kill your wife.
Kill her.
There we go.
That's right.
That's how you play support.
Oh, y'all got a key in the element.
Yeah.
I'm feeling it.
I think actually playing, I don't know, I'm more aggressive.
I'm in this now when I'm, I think I'm more aggressive on
support after playing tank.
Oh.
I hope.
Oh, oh my god.
Look at us, Joe.
You and me.
You, okay.
He didn't stack.
He, he didn't stack.
He, he didn't, you and me.
I see as he walked out, he walked out of the fucking silo,
like.
Yeah, everybody got to go to that wedding.
No, it's making me- I won't say a worse player, but like,
it's not good.
It's not good that I'm more aggressive because...
Because it...
Gambit?
Gambit never pulled?
Oh, we- we don't have heals.
give up so easily you're on heals right now i hope they kill
a healer i hope they kill a healer because there's no
there's no uh what's so weird there's no self heal
oh okay
all right
all right there you go He definitely the rogue has a lot so
I'm trying to...
Oh!
All right, nice.
All right.
Okay, we should be able to kill this technically.
Oh!
Why is our...
Where am I...
Oh, wait, how did...
Oh, okay.
Okay, that's fine.
both tanks are low it's gambit only oh let's hope all right
there's a tp that goes like right to point right blade or
you don't oh oh my god look at him go there was a tp let me
walk very slowly
very slowly to my team I didn't even realize there was a TP
let me just walk over to my team real quick we already have
a string what there's a teleporter on the left side of the
map that takes you directly to point buddy I didn't know I
didn't do either little do they know I didn't do either of
that
Please.
Where did our gambit go?
I was trying to find my gambit!
I'll fight for my family until the end.
Where did he go?
I'm gonna go strange.
Control lost!
There's more of them than us.
You'll have to keep fighting until the end.
We don't get it, we don't got it, we don't get that.
You like stall for a while.
I was just like, a gambit!
A gambit!
If I wasn't on like 200 ping right now, I would be folding
them, but like I'm not so can we, I need help, please.
I think I just have to go invis.
When they do gambit never folds, I just go Sayonara and go
invisible.
I think that's what to do
30 seconds before you just disappeared my gambit just
disappeared i was trying to find him i don't know where he
went all right here we go
one all you need to do is capture the mission area got it
it's lit up there you go
I do need all of those.
They're gonna have siloed up, and I swear to God, I better
get some help with that.
Oh, my God.
Oh, there you go.
We're trying.
Please get off, Blade.
Like, please.
Oh,
Oh my god!
They're gonna have silo called now.
As long as not me, it's fine.
Get ready for the silo call.
Are you guys ready?
It's getting me here any moment now.
It's... Oh, whoa!
I wasn't gonna live either anyway.
I hope they killed theirs
like what are you We're coming back, we're coming back No, I
need this
Oh my god, I'm trying my best
Oh my god I'm trying my best
Did she say Invis come back?
I can't hear.
I was not coming back.
You never came back for me.
Why would I come back for you when you never came back for
me?
I got him for you.
I got him.
Why would I care?
Alright, there you go.
Don't keep, please.
I remember what you did.
Okay, our Gabba needs to start healing.
I literally stopped healing these people for him.
I should have left.
Sorry, dog.
I tried to leave.
I don't give up so easily.
Almost have Gabba up.
Oh my god.
I didn't need it.
I didn't need it, I guess.
I didn't care.
It's okay.
Oh my god.
That's how you play support, baby!
That's how you play support!
sounds of a toky having fun takes could never make her feel
that way
that's how you do it baby
look at that easy fucking easy sub to toky who
That's the support of me.
There we go.
That's how it goes.
Oh my god, you see even...
Oh wait, they're in the custom tournament room.
That's right.
It's great to have fun again.
I'm so happy to have fun in this.
video game let's
fucking go
oh all
right over that solo queuing my way to the top let's fucking
go
bump I don't but up but up but
all right you know what I'm gonna do during to be released
even when doki's chain she'll never come back it's over for
her she's dead now you have to move on you you have to move
on now she's gone never to come back
the name of the super chat thank you what the fuck is it
bugged what's going on someone on my beat is the fbi agent
right now stopping this what's going on me thank you for the
10 gifted chips thank you thank you actually denied by my
fbi agent here we go we can't stop this i'll keep
All right, which hero do you think you want to be today?
I don't want to play support, please.
Oh, fuck.
Jeff?
I think it's cloak.
Oh, wait.
I only tank is tank wolf.
Now, who am I going to banish from this match?
All right, here you go.
oh that's awkward i was looking at i was going through
twitter and i had to tab in and actually liked somebody's
tweet and i unliked it oh no oh no no that
was awkward hope
they didn't see that
All right, cloak tab.
I don't know.
It was some random tweet.
I was tabbing in.
I accidentally liked it.
And I instantly liked it.
Because I was like, oh, shit.
And now they know.
Hope it wasn't racist or anything.
That's my fucking...
I can try filling tank guys.
But like, I'm letting you know right now.
I hope it wasn't bad.
I don't even know.
I fucking closed my tab after.
that would be okay guys if there was a if there was some
screenshot of me being like what the fuck why did doki like
this just remember that was the tweet i accidentally liked
that don't say that okay guys if a screenshot shows up and
they're like why the fuck didokie like just that was the
tweet i accidentally like remember this story i have an
alibi i i i have an alibi remember this
because i don't know what i like i don't know
i didn't pay attention i fucking i am this crazy where is my
jeff honestly wait a minute oh my jeff where's my jeff i
mean it's working holy shit i when the fuck did my jeff get
there
just remember i didn't know we have an alibi yeah but what
if like the poster be like what the fuck what if the poster
reveals it and i was like what That was what I liked.
That is my fear.
I don't know what I liked I instantly unliked it too just in
case
All right
I'm true.
Oh Jeff No Jeff What were you doing Jeff?
Oh God, okay.
I can save you.
I can save you you oh my god my god that's how you do it oh
sorry i couldn't save that though i'm sorry i'm sorry
see that's how you do it
much fun I'm having.
That was...
Couldn't have been Tank Doki.
Look at how much fun I'm having, guys.
Tank Doki could never.
I think Tank Doki would have lived that.
Tank Doki would never feel the same joy as support Doki is
feeling right now.
holy shit okay that there was no way i could do anything who
the what
oh my god oh my god live live
okay she didn't live
oh please please
So poor Doki is so happy right now.
That's right.
Where will you go now?
Tank Doki could never feel this joy.
Tank Doki could have carried...
Sir, this is an eternity celestial lobby.
Tank Doki would have got yelled at by 20 people.
already.
She would have got yelled at, reported.
It's been non-stop.
Alright.
You think he's gonna come for me?
No.
There we go.
Ow.
That still hurt me?
Oh.
Oh, God, goodbye.
I'll push the card a little bit for us.
Don't worry.
I got us.
Don't worry, I got you, hello.
I got you, hello.
Look at that.
Look at me, yo.
Look at that fucking pocket.
Take-Toki could be Goku.
I think you might not understand who Take-Toki is.
is.
Wait, do you think this is winnable?
You think this is winnable?
You know what?
Puppet, Puppet, Puppet.
There we go.
Look at that.
You have to.
That's called restraint.
He's like that restraint there?
Oh, yeah, you do.
Oh.
Yeah.
All right Oh Oh fuck where am I?
Where am I?
Where's that Elsa?
My god, what happened?
What's going on?
We made it.
We made it Take Tokyo would have updated her drive or Take
Doki is gone.
You have to move on, chat.
She's gone.
She's moved on.
She has left this plane of existence.
We're all free now.
Well, I'm happy and free.
She doesn't have to suffer no more.
Oh, fuck.
I just realized I have to wake up at 10 a.m.
am tomorrow for the oh shit i forgot about the apex 1v1 all
right all right i'll practice apex after i forgot the
practice apex
forgot about that shit actually let me see if i can get to
eternity guys Could be possible.
I don't know.
Yeah, Tank Doki.
Tank Doki would.
Tank Doki would remember.
Honestly, you're right.
I want to say I can get Journey.
That's my goal.
Whoa.
I hope she...
Uh...
Tank Doki never folds.
Why isn't Dylan...
Oh shit.
Hey, there is a Elsa behind us.
I hope someone is dealing with that.
Nice.
Let's go.
We got an iron for someone.
Come on, kill the bitch.
Let's go.
Let's kill this bitch, as they say in the old times.
I think I'm getting super good RNG with teammates too.
Not gonna let.
Alright.
Dude, I had some of the weirdest, like, weirdest ranked
games.
Like the first game with Triple Tink, the fact that we won
is crazy.
I just thought it was GG's.
I thought it was GG's.
Oh, hold on, let's get up.
I feel like that Jep was not supporting at all.
That jump is 67% alt.
I do not think he's been supporting.
If anything, we're down a DPS.
I can't believe he said we're down to support when the man
is at 67.
Oh, goodbye.
Goodbye.
Okay, let's hope that...
Holy shit!
Alright!
Woohoo!
We had no digs!
Wait, what?
We're going?
We're going behind them.
Get ready.
We got the...
For our teammates.
So they can heal us.
Go here, here.
I have 46% here.
What is it?
What is going on?
Pro-place the board.
going on what is going on oh no he's dead he is absolutely
oh oh shit um i hope everything is going okay over there oh
nice let's go i was like what is oh all right let's go i i
don't know how this is working.
Let's go.
Deadpool, thank you for that.
Give the ships, take it, thank you.
This is wild.
They should just, they really should just surrender.
But look how little our hella cares about that venom.
He did not care.
Look at her.
Look, she's, look.
Oh, this might be a...
No!
Oh, shit, let's go!
Oh!
We will kill you!
Wait, what are we doing?
Wait, wait, does this winnable?
Does this winnable?
Wait a minute!
That's how we roll.
That's how we do it, guys.
I think if we even win this map, it would be fucking insane.
If we win that area.
Never mind, Tank Dookie, we've been able to...
Bro, we just soloed to be that freak.
That fucking freak.
That beta shit.
You're that scared of a...
Okay, I'd be that scared of a cloak attack.
I literally got...
that I would too see this is why they had to roll lock me
guys this is why they're like don't you must stay on take
this is exactly why oh
my godless I got to look Don't worry That was personal Do
not let it the fact that I won that was crazy I was like
oops I threw Oops did I throw my own thing that oh when
everyone's dead JK Okay, I couldn't do anything about that.
That was way too far We are like a load now we're throwing
I'm like up here so it should be trying right oh never mind
Well the thing is I can't peel anything because I have to
say I'm gonna say my right click for the Venom dive because
our Jeff is chilling our Jeff is having a great time running
I mean She's good.
He's literally like soloing too like me and the Jeff
Is he doing okay?
All right Oh, yeah, I'm still here
Let's go Hello, yay Let's go Oh, fuck The last thing you
see...
Yeah.
Another fucking car crash waiting to happen.
That was insane.
That was actually insane.
The last second drama.
Not again.
I need to see what the fuck happened.
I... I need to know.
That was insane.
Oh, I have to win two games.
That's the worst, too.
When you have to win two games.
Okay.
Who's on Leaderbird right now?
Who the fuck is Junior?
I know.
Who is this guy?
Oh, you can't even tell.
Oh, yeah.
I see.
Look at me.
Do my speedrun.
Doing my little speedrun.
Um.
And I'm going to lose all.
Five games after.
That's how it usually goes.
What was this?
It's here, right?
Yeah.
Was it here?
Like, what the fuck happened?
I was like, oh, shit.
Oh, shit.
Let's go, guys.
Let's go.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, oh, my guys.
Let's fucking go.
Me and the Jeff, you and me, Jeff.
That's why we're going to take you down with us.
Me and you.
Me and that, Jeff.
We made it.
That Jeff is scary.
Not going to lie.
Oh my god.
Me and Jeff.
Look at that.
Actual teamwork.
He unkilled.
Me and that, Jeff.
We worked together.
Supports rise up.
What was it?
Jesus Christ!
Look at his fucking heels!
How did we make that work?
The fact that...
Look at his fucking heels!
Look at the... look at the enemy healing.
This was the other support.
I can't believe we fucking made that work.
GPS Jeff or I die.
the fact that we made it work was insane don't need to heal
if you killed exactly
i'm telling madara we got second place but it wasn't my
fault
so that's a win for me
B-Hops might have made a little oopsie That's right I'm
telling Madara B-Hops I'll never let you down I'm never
gonna let you live this down He TP'd and the TP was on the
cart so we couldn't jump through And then we lost.
Bruce.
He's gonna be haunted about this forever.
He's gonna be haunted.
About this forever.
Really?
We hopped so well, it's lurking 16 times.
You see, for that to happen requires me to join the next
VTuber Cup.
You can't kill me if I'm not in the next VTuber Cup.
True.
No, but you played great.
I'm just I'm just fucking I'm just fucking around because
like Madara knows B hop so I'm just like fucking with him or
just like bantering you know
yeah real homies remind people of their trauma
which hero do you think you want to be today
who am I gonna banish from this match all right
Madara is asking for details on how the game went.
That fucking liar, he says he's gonna watch my stream and
cheer me on.
That little bitch.
Anyway, anyway, thumbs up for Madara for coaching me like
today.
Shout out to Madara for coaching me today.
Goddamn.
cloak and dagger we are hope energy madara's by the way
all right let's go people are always afraid of time but they
just don't know him
all right four three two one you have to stop that oh no
solo tank mag he's not gonna have fun at all I know how you
feel, Mag.
I was just like you, Mag.
I was just like you.
I... What the...
I was just like you, Mag.
I know.
I know what it's like, bro.
I know what it's like.
What a shape.
Luckily, the captain came back from...
us also my god just realized they were so they they
literally got the only tank player that could play dive
which is so fucking strong against lower elo players they
that's like dive is scary as hell even like in this gilo
dive is like so hard to it's so hard to play with
really black cat is really good it's just it takes no it's
just that uh he's good but it's also like dive dive tank is
so uh what's the word it's just easy uh easy to use against
uh low uh casual support players or lower rank supports
Oh my god, I got fucking Punisher.
Because it's like you're not in lower elo.
There's not a lot of, like, you know, not a lot.
You don't really play.
Yeah, it's very oppressive.
So people are not used to playing against good dive.
Like, even then, I got yelled at.
I'd be like, have you never played dive before?
And I was just like, I don't like dive.
I'm sorry.
I got yelled at, too, in higher elo, for not playing, like,
for being bad.
Because I'm so bad against dive in general.
Yeah, I had to...
swap roles.
For last minute, I had to be the one that peels.
I had to be the peeler versus... I wish I...
We knew that earlier.
It might have helped, too.
Oh, nice.
That's right, get over here!
Yeah.
I think it should have been me peeling and then B-hop
anchoring.
Okay.
Because I play more passive.
Uh, I play more passive than B-Hop.
Yes.
Yeah, yeah, I'm just getting really good RNG right now.
It's gonna be, it's gonna get so close, and then like...
Oh, help me.
And then, like, I'll be one game off, and then I lose it
all.
And I lose it all.
I can already see it.
All right.
Try to let her heal more.
Healer, healer, healer, healer, healer.
Healer, healer, healer.
Okay.
All right.
Our Starlord...
Oh, our Starlord got pulled.
I was going to say, our Starlord died?
Ow!
Oh!
No!
I panicked!
Is anyone portaling?
No.
Wait, nobody decided- Oh.
Oh, no, don't- Who's- Oh, nobody decided?
Okay.
Oh, you're all- Oh, fuck, I'm fuck.
We were both- Yeah, you port- you port-o, you- No, you pour
it up!
Oh my god.
Maybe it works again, I should have to...
No!
Oh my god, he can't.
I don't want to lure his complaints.
That's funny, we're like, you pour it up?
No, you pour it up.
What?
We were both confused.
Oh, no, I jinxed it.
I jinxed it now.
All right.
Angelou really wants to...
Oh, no.
Oh,
we...
We almost have all.
What the fuck?
holy shit he did you guys see that he was so fast
he was so how is he still alive whoever it is i think okay
there you go
all right i even know adam was that fast now that's crazy
i don't know i'm scared i'm so scared like where do we go
Oh my god, I try, I try.
Oh, good.
Oh, we can heal each other.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, God.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, my god, I did that.
Yes!
Oh!
Oh, I live that!
We live that to come back.
You don't have a lot of heals.
They are running Adam.
Adam Cloak, though.
Hmm.
Oh!
fuck tomorrow's tomodachi life too i'm just like oh i might
have sketched too many things
all right 30 seconds before you attack get ready
support of the cart oh no did they also did a bee hop thank
you he's dead she'll never do until my dock my dokey island
is it Logan 9-9 like the best no there's no way she would
have been eternity by now never mind I know there is oh it's
bad there is a wolf That's like top 10 wolf player in the
world Like top 10 player in the world For some shit but
that's not him Because he's in Celestia right now It can't
be him
Alright nice Alright fine Oh what the fuck
What happened?
Where did they all go?
Like nobody came out of that portal I'm so confused
confused.
Nobody came out.
Yeah, I was like, where are they?
Oh shit, nice.
Whoa, shit, okay, that was me pretending I was a tank.
I thought I was the second tank there for a second, guys.
That might have been my bad.
Okay.
Oh, alright.
I didn't even know he at all.
I just didn't want to be close to him.
I got scared.
Legitimately, it was just like, I don't want him to touch
me.
I didn't even know he at all.
It was like, no touchy.
No touchy.
Nice.
All right, this is where I lose it all, chat.
This is where I lose it all.
16?
Excuse me.
What?
Okay.
I'm here a gift for TikTok.
Has anyone seen?
I want to tell her how cool she...
Oh, no.
Who's gonna break it to him?
Guys, who's gonna...
I think you have a super chat, I even...
Thank you, thank you.
She's in a better place now.
I think this might be the game where everyone starts yelling
at each other.
It could be.
This could be the game where they all just start yelling at.
And it just goes downhill from here.
Oh my god, what happened to my game?
There's an esport?
What is this?
Is it Ignite?
Ignite preseason.
Do you want them to have access to my cancel?
What is this?
Ignite.
Oh, Pack OCE.
Oh, they have a little thingy there.
Oh my god, how many can buy an Avengers team, Lami?
Oh, I want to buy this.
I wanted to buy the Loki
Is it still It's not pre Oh it's like pack OC I'm gonna say
I thought preseason ended I don't like this emo This is
Something wrong with the face animation There's I don't know
Same with the Captain America There's something wrong with
it It doesn't look right It doesn't look right at all.
The voices one looks so weird.
Somehow, I don't know why.
It just looks off.
We're almost there, guys.
We're almost there.
I can't even do the booty shake.
It won't let me.
Maybe I could do it in time square.
It won't let me do the shake.
I'm like restricted.
Holy shit, there's too much stuff in New York City now.
Oh my god.
Too many things to process.
Hey guys, why is everybody sitting down?
Highlight screening?
Oh, what is this?
Oh, I'm ready to cause some chaos.
It's here and I brought a little limbo with me.
Relax, darling.
Oh.
promo is i can't wait to get dmca'd guys oh it's the captain
america promo
steve rogers will return oh my god cinema oh fuck what the
fuck there's a one above all what is going on
Oh, shit.
Oh, this is bad.
Oh, no.
Why do they give the hardest fights with God's strongest
warriors?
How could they do this to me?
I just want...
But,
um...
Guys!
Oh my god!
Wait.
Uh...
Look what my manager sent me at Oshi Uplink.
Wait, what are you sending me?
Oh my god, I'm trying to resize this.
It's too big.
Why did he give me such a big picture?
Okay, I can't.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'm trying to get the picture.
The picture's too big.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
All right, I got it.
Read this
Please buy Doki's mistakes wonderful doggy shirts, please
help us get rid of them Please, please, please Please We're
real Wasn't I a mistake?
Yeah, it's just a little Oopsie.
I think I'm gonna get yelled at in this game.
This is too try hard for me.
There's a chance that I may or may not get yelled at.
Okay.
You won't be needing that.
Don't be needing that.
Oh no, that's bad.
He won't be needing that.
Oh, no.
Oh no, the eternity player is up.
I gotta get healed.
Yo, why are we in spawn, guys?
Okay, we're good.
Our hope, the way's the first banner.
I don't know why.
Okay, we got it.
He won't be needing that.
this is no this is a sweaty sweaty lobby that's why i'm
scared that's why i'm very scared
oh my god you won't be needing that strange that black
counter is spawn trying to spawn me but she's fucking
terrible Oh
Get dodge
You won't be needing that
Okay Oh my god, I have to be like so aware of the fucking
black cat You won't be needing that!
Okay.
Yeah, I like that.
Gotcha!
Okay.
Okay, there you go.
Alright.
You won't be needing that.
That's too good.
Okay, I still need Invisalt though.
I need Invisalt stat.
They have a Bucky carrot.
No hook though for a second.
Come on, I'm lucky half.
You guys need to go?
You're just playing around in front of me.
Oh!
You are getting good.
Okay.
We're down too.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
You have Invisal.
I don't have any.
Don't be needing that.
Let me force the ball.
All right.
Let him walk.
There we go.
I will.
Yeah, way better.
Oh, fuck.
Where am I?
Oh, shit.
No.
Oh, I'm definitely dead.
I'm TPing.
I'm too.
Oh, fuck.
Wait, it's cloaked.
Oh, wait.
There's still a chance to stop them.
Cart, cart, cart.
Oh, they got the res.
Yay!
Oh!
Time to smash things up.
Including which side you're on.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Boy, you're calling a raccoon, huh?
Alright, here we go.
go.
I'm not the type who fades.
Holy shit.
The most intense game for eternity.
You won't be needing that.
What won't I be needing?
I can't believe.
Please buy turkey's mistake.
That's the Oshi uplink right now, guys.
All right.
No.
Oh, oh, yes!
He turned it in!
So cute!
Yay!
This feels better than getting the tournament.
This is so cute!
Yay!
I'm taking a screenshot.
All right.
I'm tweeting that out, guys.
Second place with only, with less than an hour on tank.
it was learning a tank in 24 hours and then speed running
solo queue to eternity right after on support it's a good
day learning four tanks in 20 with some with the almost with
zero knowledge on any of them and then speed running solo
queue in eternity then then first trying first trying um
thing live in on in the tournament
There we go.
It's a good day.
Winning on thing.
Live in the tournament.
And then speed running solo go to eternity right after on
support.
After not touching Rink for three seasons.
It's a good day.
Yippee.
There we go.
let's go
yeah let's go in three days let's fucking go I'm so proud of
myself I'm actually so proud of myself chat where am I what
is this for I was watching a movie oh my god I'm so proud of
myself, guys.
I know I keep saying it, but today was a good day.
Even though the first 80% of it 80% of that day was me
suffering on tank.
Yay!
I did it.
Sorry, I'm just so happy.
I actually have to practice AP.
Apex Day of the Night.
Before.
Because I have the 1v1.
I know Apex Great awaits me.
Oh.
It's a good day.
That's crazy.
I'm actually so.
I'm actually so proud of myself today.
Honestly.
With all the stuff I did.
I'm sorry.
I'm like.
Wow.
I did that.
You know.
Like I'm so proud of myself right now.
out let's see like i did so many like things that i was just
like wow i did that today on rivals oh
that was a good see look at that that is our combo our
fucking our squirrel girl oh yeah i was like yeah we we had
we were trying to do the squirrel girl combo but it didn't
work out he's like I told him to die.
He's like, the squirrel girl and Makaba.
We had to do what we got.
We had to make do what we have.
That's me.
Oh, this one was sick.
This one was sick, though.
It was so risky.
Because of the moon night arc.
Boom.
It's clobbering time.
Let's go.
They don't know what to do.
And then...
This one.
The last footage of Tank... It's like a memorial.
Oh wait, this doesn't matter.
This is like last point.
And I saved it.
I really wanted to kill him.
There we go.
I missed Tank, dokey.
Doesn't that feel damn good, dokey?
Look.
It takes too long to get that serotonin.
It takes too long to get the adrenaline.
It takes way too long.
on to get there.
Then there was the group.
And then finally, I don't even know what I did here.
Oh, was this the one we're at?
It doesn't oh, this one.
And then there's this play.
Me be like, oh shit, that fucked that up.
Nah.
That was
crazy.
Me and that, Jeff.
Going in deep.
What a day.
Let me just...
Guys, I'm sorry.
I'm disassociating now.
Just processing it all.
I...
Like, dokey.
What's it dokey?
Sorry.
I'm just processing everything.
Like...
I'm just really proud of myself I'm really proud like I said
I told her I was like we even get third I'm just I'll be
happy we get third place honestly because I knew what our
weaknesses were we every other team had DPS players every
other team so like I had like high elo DPS players that like
played DPS a lot so I knew that was like our biggest
weakness so I was just like meta it's iron it's like dive
tank and dps is really strong right now in the current meta
too so that's why i was just like um i would be so happy we
get third place because i don't like i obviously because i'm
also coming in as a crutch too with my lack of knowledge my
lack of knowledge on tank so i was really worried about it
because i was like oh what if i can't i just don't want to
feed too much because i i literally i literally have to i
think i learned five tanks right today I picked up Groot,
Mag, Strange, uh, Thing and Emma in 24 hours.
I literally had to learn five different tanks in 24 hours.
And I'm, it's crazy that I was able to make plays with that
knowledge.
And like, I'm just really proud of myself because I was able
to go like toe-to-toe with other tank mains, too.
Being able to, uh, being able to...
play up to par with the other tank means because literally I
just went in blind.
Just went in.
You have to adapt very quickly.
I went in like, like went in like fucking, let's see how it
goes.
I literally have to learn five tanks in one day.
And I was just like, well, let's see.
Let's see how this goes.
And I had to be super flexible.
I was like, I know I can be super flexible.
So I was just like, so I'm super, and then right after I
played five, like, how many, four games of support?
Oh my god, two, five games of support, back to back to back,
and just won all of them.
Oh my god.
Mechanically, I think I got really strong mechanically
there.
Yeah.
Back to back, just straight up.
Five wins in a row.
thank you guys for all the insane support guys uh that this
is the last time you'll ever see tank dokey ever again she
will never come back she will never come back it is it was
even though we had some made some generational plays i
realized tank is just not for me
in the right game we're like people will be like can anyone
the tank i'd be like i have no hours on tank because it's
still sort of true it's i would love to i i would love to
learn more dps there i miss i miss playing dps that's why
i'm gonna have to warm up i have to like learn apex again
like not i learned but remember how to aim on apex um um but
this would be the first and last time you've ever seen tank
doki in her element enjoyed watching tank toky so long cow
space cowboy hey guys as always everybody stay hydrated
posture check get up and move around and get that blood
flowing you stay up for me head to bed because you deserve
it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye no
tank toky is tank is not fun guys don't do this to me no
take it was I'm sorry it was it was not as fun as you guys
think it is it's not as fun as you think it is guys I anyway
guys bye bye everyone but you see how much fun I had on
support guys you see how much joy was in my eyes of playing
that character and then you see how like miserable I was
like for it then and that's how stressed i was all right
anyway bye for real i like support more i like to win games
with less effort bye